Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Der Sommer ist da. Freust du dich auf die Zukunft?
Naja, momentan lebe ich ein bisschen mehr in der Vergangenheit.
Was heißt, du lebst in der Vergangenheit? Ich meine, wenn man dich anschaut und deinen Stil so verfolgt, du bist ja jetzt auch ein Instagram-Influencer. Merkt man natürlich, du lebst nicht in der Jetztzeit. Aber was ist mit Vergangenheit gemeint?
Genau. Und hier hätte man eigentlich, also hier hätten sie eigentlich noch eine Chance für eine echte Pointe setzen können, denn das Pendel schlägt ja gerade wieder um, dass man Bitcoin nicht mehr so als Währung, sondern wieder auf der Asset-Seite sieht. Man investiert in Bitcoin, aber nicht, um das mal wie ein Geld zu benutzen. Es gab ja früher so, dass er wirklich in Berlin dir einen Burger mit einem Bitcoin kaufen konnte. Das gibt es ja alles gar nicht mehr, sondern Bitcoin ist jetzt wieder ein Speichermedium wie eine Aktie. Bitcoin ist eigentlich ganz nah dran an so einer Berkshire Hathaway, links da oben, Aktie. Man sagt, die kostet halt viel, dann wird es immer mehr und das Ding wird irgendwie attraktiv, aber es ist nur so ein Gerede und Gespiele und so weiter. Und da sind eigentlich die Gleichnisse viel schärfer, wenn man sich vorher angehört hat, wie leidenschaftslos sie selbst über ihre eigene Aktie sprechen. Hätten sie das Gleichnis aufmachen können, dass sie über den Bitcoin genauso sprechen. Da investieren halt Leute rein, sollen sie halt machen. Das ist so wie, wenn man in Berkshire Hathaway investiert.
Nur hat man nicht mehr diesen direkten Bezug zu einem Produkt und das ist ja für Warren Buffett sehr wichtig. Was mich enorm gefreut hat, war, diese beiden alten Herren dort zu sehen. Und dann sieht man, was die beiden trinken. Warren Buffett trinkt Coca Cola und Charlie Manga trinkt Coca Cola Light. Also mein Getränk und der ist schon 97. Das sind doch beste Aussichten. Sie kommen noch mal auf das Thema Gambling zu sprechen, dann mit Bezug auf Robin Hood und machen da mal einen sehr, sehr schönen Vergleich und werfen dem Staat auch richtig was vor. Und ich finde, diese Kritik am Start im Umgang mit dem Spielen, die sollten wir jetzt mal übertragen. Die sollten vielleicht sich vor allem auch mal die Politiker in Schleswig-Holstein ansehen, wo ja eigentlich so ein Spieleparadies ist, kann man sagen. Also da wird ja sehr viel über Schleswig-Holstein abgewickelt, dass man da vieles umgehen kann.
Das ist einer der Dinge, die falsch sind. Es wird mir zu den Dingen respektabel.
Aber das war halt das Kalkül. Findet sowieso statt, wenn dann holt man wenigstens noch ein bisschen Profit für die Sportvereine raus in Deutschland und dann lässt man halt Lotto darüber laufen.
Aber sie sind da ganz puritanisch. Das Spielen soll eigentlich verboten werden und naja, es sollte zumindest eingeschränkt werden. Ich glaube, dass man ja doch deutlich sieht, wie da auch die Lobby am Wirken ist, gerade bei der FDP, wie man dann versucht, das Spieleparadies aus ganz Deutschland zu machen. Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt, dass man so zu verbinden und zu sagen, ja, was macht eigentlich dann der Staat da? Sicherlich ist das richtig, dass man damit eine organisierte Kriminalität bekämpfen will. Andererseits denkt man da auch immer an den schönen Satz von Augustinus, nimm das Recht, was ist der Staat dann anders als eine Räuberbande? Und das zeigt sich dann hier auch sehr, sehr schön. Also, da sind sie sehr dagegen. Und wir hatten ja uns diese Anhörung von Robin Hood auch mal zu Gemüte geführt. Und da war ja auch ganz klar, von den amerikanischen Politikern zu hören, dass Robin Hood so programmiert ist, dass man da am liebsten 300-mal am Tag draufblickt und irgendwelche Trades macht. Und darum geht es ja, dass die immer an den Trades verdienen. Normalerweise, selbst wenn man so einen Online-Broker hat von Sparkass oder was weiß ich, dann mag es mal den ein oder anderen Trade in der Woche geben, wenn es jemand macht. So kenne ich das zumindest von Freunden. Aber nicht so, dass das eigentlich wie Tinder genutzt wird. Und das ist aber darauf angelegt, weil jedes Mal die Plattform dann mit verdient. Zum Ausklang hören wir jetzt noch mal zweimal etwas humoristisches. Und zwar Buffett hat jetzt noch eine interessante Überlegung zum Thema Altern und dem Altern seines Unternehmens.
So kann man es auch sehen.
Eine schöne Überlegung zur Rentnerrepublik, oder?
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Sehr gut.
Und zum Schluss noch von Charlie Manga ein Bon mot, das er uns mit auf den Weg gibt. Und ich möchte hinzufügen, das gilt vielleicht auch für die beiden, dass sie gar nicht mehr so genau wissen, was sie da eigentlich wollen und meinen.
Genau. Was wollen und meinen Menschen? Insbesondere Politiker. Wir haben uns ja schon eine Weile hier auch die Frage gestellt, was ist mit Joe Biden? Der kommt dann nach Amerika, krempelt mit seinen blabla 70 Jahren irgendwie alles nochmal um. Übersteigt sogar diese progressive Agenda. Also selbst AOC oder so. Die wissen gar nicht, wie ihn geschieht, sondern die stehen staunend daneben und wundern sich über die Billionen. Und jetzt habe ich im Fernsehpodcast mit Thomas schon diese beiden Rede vorm Kongress gehört, die ja wirklich hoch interessant ist. Und einen Clip davon hatte ich auch in unserer Besprechung schon ausgeklammert und gesagt, den gucken wir hier nochmal, denn das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Auf die ganze Frage, warum schickt Biden jetzt irgendwelchen Familien ein Paycheck im Sinne von, also nicht ein Paycheck, sondern im Sinne von, wie soll man sagen, eigentlich bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, wenn auch nur mal als Einmalzahlung oder so, dass man als fünfköpfige Familie wirklich einfach durchgezählt bekommt, aber 5 mal 1400 Euro sind und dann kriegt man halt 5, 6, 7, 8, je nachdem wie viele Köpfe es sind, einfach in den Briefkasten. Und dann geht man damit zur Bank und kriegt dann dafür Geld. Und das ist auch nicht unter Vorbehalt wie in Deutschland, dass dann doch nochmal das Finanzamt nachschaut und sagt, sie müssen es aber zurückzahlen, sie haben das unberechtigt bekommen oder wie auch immer. Sondern nee, einfach nur, weil man eine 5-köpfige, eine 4-köpfige Familie ist, bekommt man so viel Geld. Oder eben alleine und dann 1.400 Dollar. Und es ist doch ganz erstaunlich, wie Joe Biden das hier so ganz geruhsam vorm Kongress, der natürlich nicht versammelt anwesend war wegen Corona, aber trotzdem vorm Kongress, also an höchster Stelle, an ihrem Präsident sprechen kann, wie er das hier begründet.
Er und andere Autokraten denken, dass die Demokratie im 21.
Um in die Zukunft diese Wettbewerb zu gewinnen, müssen wir auch einmal pro Generation in unsere Familien und Kinder investieren.
Deshalb habe ich heute Abend den Plan der amerikanischen Familien vorgestellt, der die vier größten Herausforderungen in der amerikanischen Familie und im Inneren Amerikanischen Lande vorstellt.
Also das ist einfach ein Wahnsinns-Clip, wo plötzlich die Familien an die Front gestellt werden im Systemkrieg gegen China, den man hier, und das ist jetzt der Plan für das nächste, für dieses Jahrhundert, gewinnen möchte.
Und das leuchtet absolut ein und man merkt hier auch beiden wird richtig beraten, liest auch vielleicht die Reden von Xi sehr genau, denn Xi verspricht ja den chinesischen Familien ein bisschen Wohlstand. Ich kriege jetzt gerade die Formulierung nicht exakt zustande, aber so ein bescheidenes Maß an Wohlstand verspricht er. Und das ist das große Versprechen, an das dann Patriotismus geknüpft wird, eine Renationalisierung, Militarisierung der Gesellschaft. All das, dieses große geopolitische Projekt wird immer wieder von Xi verknüpft mit diesem bisschen Wohlstand, dass man doch den Familien schaffen will und was wir gemeinsam erreichen, sodass wir alle aus der Armut gehoben werden. Und das ist deshalb sehr, sehr klug, da eigentlich anzuknüpfen und zu sagen, wir brauchen da ein Gegenstück auf amerikanischer Seite.
Genau. Wenn man das jetzt historisch aufschlüsselt, kommt man natürlich gleich in die Bredouille, weil man ist dann sofort gerade in Deutschland beim Mutterkreuz, bei der Verehrung der Mutter als und so weiter. Dieses Denken hat er aber nur im Nazireich sozusagen seinen Gipfel erreicht. Nachdem es dann, das hören wir nachher auch, so durchindividualisiert wurde, die Babyboomer, jeder für sich kämpfte und so weiter und uns jetzt so diesen Schlamassel hinterlässt. Auch damals schon bei der Kolonialgeschichte, als Großbritannien loszog, war es völlig klar, als Politiker an die Sache ranzugehen. Also wenn wir die größte Seemacht der Welt werden wollen, brauchen wir volle Kindergärten. Und da hat man schon an Kindergärten als, man kann auch außerhalb der Familie erzogen werden. Und da bekommt man auch mal das ein oder andere Denken mit. Also dieses kollektivistische Denken war damals ganz normal. Und das kommt jetzt bei Joe Biden hier wieder zurück. Dem einfach sagt, die Familie steht jetzt wieder im Zentrum. Wir müssen Amerika aus der Basis heraus neu bauen. Deswegen auch dieser starke Satz, trickle down has never worked. Also wir setzen nicht weiter bei den Reichen an, sondern wir gehen jetzt wieder ans Elementalteich in der Gesellschaft ran. Wir streiten sie nicht weiter ab, wie in der englischen Ideologie mit Margaret Thatcher und so weiter. Es gibt keine Gesellschaft. Nee, es gibt jetzt plötzlich wieder Gesellschaft. Und der Kern der Gesellschaft ist die Familie. Und das haben wir jetzt überall auf der Welt. Wir hatten ja gestern zum Beispiel die Meldung von Jens Spahn. Deswegen ist Twitter schon wieder in Aufruhr. Kinderlose sollen höheren Beitrag zahlen für die Pflegeversicherung. Also wer keine Kinder beisteuert in die Gesellschaft, der soll 3, 4 Prozent des Bruttolohns bezahlen, um die Pflege abzusichern oder, wie eben schon genannt und das ist von heute, dass China jetzt seinen Familien erlaubt, drei Kinder zu bekommen. Also sie wollen immer noch den Deckel draufhalten.
Aber von der Ein-Kind-Politik ist man ja schon lange abgerückt und jetzt sogar zu sagen drei Kinder.
Genau, also seit heute levelt man von zwei auf drei Kinder. Und das ist natürlich Wunschdenken. Hier hören wir mal im heutigen Journal vom 11.
China, das bevölkerungsreichste Land, droht zu schrumpfen. Wie das Statistikamt in Peking mitteilte, ist die chinesische Bevölkerung in den vergangenen zehn Jahren nur noch um jährlich 0, 53 Prozent gewachsen, auf aktuell rund 1, 4 Milliarden Menschen. Nach Jahrzehnten der Ein-Kind-Politik gingen die Geburten das vierte Jahr in Folge massiv zurück. Die Altersgruppe der über 60-Jährigen hingegen wuchs um gut 5 Prozent an. Experten warnen angesichts der Alterung der chinesischen Bevölkerung vor möglichen Folgen für das Wirtschaftswachstum der Volksrepublik.
Wir haben es ja oft besprochen, China droht wirklich alt zu werden, bevor sie reich werden und damit so das vietnamesische Schicksal. Und selbst wenn man es schafft, vorher reich zu werden, bevor man alt wird, hat man das südkoreanische Schicksal, weil es immer noch bedeutet, mehr als 50 Prozent der Rentner leben dort unterhalb der Armutsgrenze. Das droht Deutschland übrigens auch. Spätestens zehn Jahren haben wir hier eine ganz andere Sachlage in Deutschland. Schon jetzt ist ja die Hälfte aller Renten unter 1.000 Euro. Wird allerdings noch aufgewogen, dadurch, dass immer noch relativ viele Ehen einfach gemeinsam und so weiter sich da durchboxen. Aber jetzt ist doch einiges in Bewegung. Das wäre jetzt China. Also China, schlechteste Zahlen ever, obwohl die Politik wirklich krampfhaft versucht, gegenzusteuern. Wie sieht es in Amerika aus?
That's the most in nearly 50 years and due in part to the pandemic.
Und das hätte man nicht unbedingt erwartet, denn es gibt ja manchmal gerade dann in solchen Zeiten, wenn man mal wieder zu Hause ist, auch genügend Möglichkeiten, Gelegenheit schafft Diebe. Und das gab es ja immer mal wieder, dass es solche kleinen Peaks nach oben gibt, aber hier offenbar überhaupt nicht. Beziehungsweise vielleicht wäre es uns noch schlechter, man weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, man kann dann auch fragen, ist es da noch mal eine Überlegung geschuldet? Oh Gott, wir sind in pandemischen Zeiten, kann ich jetzt das verantworten? Will ich das jetzt gerade? Aber ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, man kann diese Ereignisse doch auch abziehen. Und ich kenne ein paar Leute, die jetzt Eltern geworden sind oder zum zweiten, dritten Mal Eltern geworden sind. Und für die spielten diese pandemischen Sachen gar keine Rolle in dem Sinn in der Überlegung, sondern vielleicht nur noch bei der Frage bei der Entbindung, wie wird das jetzt sein? Darf der Mann mit in den Kreißsaal oder so? Das waren dann Fragen, die sich da noch mal stellten in Bezug auf Corona. Aber ich glaube, dass diese Tendenz generell einfach die ist. Und zwar weltweit. Und zwar hängt sie ja wohl dann auch mit einem Wohlstand zusammen, der natürlich eine gewisse Individualisierung bedeutet und auch eine berufliche Laufbahn, die gar nicht mehr darauf ausgelegt ist, dass man viele Kinder hat.
Also Berufslaufbahnen sind heute hoch spezialisiert am Ende und vor allem sehr geplant. Also man muss relativ früh überlegen, was macht man denn? Und dann zieht man das durch und so nach zehn Jahren ist man dann durch die Ausbildung durch und ist dann wirklich angekommen. Das ist schon mal eine Sache, die uns zum Beispiel von nicht allzu fernen Vergangenheiten unterscheidet. In Südkorea, in Iran, auch in Deutschland war es zum Beispiel völlig normal, dass eine Frau fünf, sechs, sieben Kinder bekommt. Also so als Familie aber runtergebrochen hat die Frau, weil sie bekommt die Kinder. Und dann rechnet man ja immer pro Frau. Und jetzt sind wir ja in Deutschland so bei 2, 1 und in China nähert man sich. In Amerika sind wir noch weit drüber, in Frankreich auch. Aber es gibt eben auch Orte wie Südkorea, wo es einfach 1, 4 ist. Also wo quasi gar kein Nachwuchs mehr zu erwarten ist. Und so was, dass man von sieben Kindern pro Frau auf 1, 4, also auf unter zwei fällt. Also sozusagen das exponentielle Wachstum mit einem Faktor über zwei plötzlich runterfällt auf weniger, also auf nicht nur stagnieren, sondern sogar Schrumpfen der Gesellschaft. Das braucht nur eine Generation. Und das ist immer die Generation, die für sich Reichtum entdeckt. Also die wie in China aus der Armut geholt wird, weil man dann plötzlich Frauen hat, die tatsächlich recht früh anfangen ihre Biografie zu planen. Und dann sind Kinder nur noch eins unter vielen. Und dann hat man irgendwann diese deutsche Situation, dass zuerst der Mietvertrag und dann der Arbeitsvertrag und dann der Ehevertrag, alles muss in trockener Tüchern sein. Und dann, 15 Jahre biologisch zu spät würde man sagen, kommt dann tatsächlich das erste Kind mit 43 Jahren oder so. Und dann traut man sich von dem Zweiten nicht mehr zu, weil dann auch die Ärzte so ein bisschen warnen.
Was aber auch an der sozialen Frage natürlich liegt, also man hat jetzt die Perspektive des Aufstiegs nicht mehr ohne Weiteres. Man hat auch nicht die Perspektive, ich arbeite ein paar Jahre und dann können wir bauen und können uns ein Haus leisten, können uns Eigenheiten leisten. Das heißt, das ist alles unbezahlbar. Und dann ist da eine sehr große Angst, sich noch weitere finanzielle Lasten aufzuhalten, dann in Form von Kindern, weil die auch schon dann eine Ausbildung wahrscheinlich brauchen, um noch dann wirtschaftlich fit zu sein bei dieser globalen Wettbewerbssituation, für die man wieder privat relativ viel investieren muss vielleicht. Also das sind ja dann auch Überlegungen, die man hat, oh wird das dann noch alles so sein, brauche ich dann auch nochmal 80.000, um das Kind irgendwo hinzubringen, wo es ganz toll studiert und schon die entsprechenden Kontakte dann hat. Sodass das ja sehr, sehr verständlich ist, dass man dort eher zurückschreckt.
Genau, diese Zuspitzung haben wir jetzt 2020 gesehen, dass die biografische Planung wirklich ins Ewenken gerät und man sich dann sagt, lasst uns lieber noch ein Jahr warten. Und da ist vor allem die zweite Welle in Deutschland, die so ab Oktober dann losging, weil die erste hat man noch so locker mitgenommen. Da war auch für die Künstler noch so, ja jetzt machen wir mal ein paar Monate Auftrittsverbot, das geht aber dann im Sommer wieder los und so. Und ab eine zweite Welle kommt, wissen wir ja nicht. Und dann kam plötzlich eine zweite Welle und die hat dann auch, das kann man auch später dann in Deutschland, dauert die Aufarbeitung noch ein bisschen, an den psychischen Aufarbeitung ablesen und an den Geburtenzahlen eben auch. Also diese zweite Welle als es klar war, die Corona ist noch nicht vorbei und der Winter beginnt jetzt gerade erst. Es ist gerade noch Herbst, es dauert jetzt noch sieben Monate bis Mai und sowas. Diese Überlegungen haben wir sehr reingeschlagen in Amerika, bei uns hier in Deutschland auch. Die Zahlen haben wir aber noch nicht. In China wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weniger, aber da haben wir es grundsätzlich als Phänomen. Und wenn wir eben schon in Amerika gehört, das betrifft alle, alle ethnischen, sozioökonomischen Bereiche. Also das ist einfach eine Entwicklung, die ist jetzt grundlegend. Geburtenzahlen sind aber nur das Einzige, was Volkswirtschaft nicht am Laufen halten. Es gibt ja auch noch die Migration. Und da haben wir in Amerika mittlerweile eine Schizophrenie, die ist wirklich erstaunlich. Nach vier Jahren Trump, wo wir über alles gejammert haben, was an der Südgrenze zu Mexiko vorging und so weiter, sind das hier im Mai reportiert, die Aufarbeitung des April 2021. So, also nach vier Jahren Trump hat Biden im April 2021 mal richtig zugeschlagen und hat gesagt, hier werden erst mal alle festgenommen. Und wir machen hier auch ein großes Statement, hier kommt keiner mehr drüber. Gleichzeitig hat allerdings Biden einen neuen Homeland Security Secretary, der ja auch für solche Sachen zuständig ist, Alejandro Mayorkas, der sich hier in der gleichen Sendung zum Thema äußert. Wie gehen wir jetzt mit Migration eigentlich um? Jetzt haben wir eben die Realität gehört vom April 2020. Jetzt hören wir die politische Semantik dazu im Mai 2021. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass wir heute hier sind. Wir sind überhaupt nicht mehr zusammen.
Müssen wir denn, wenn wir jetzt über Migration reden, nicht komplett einmal den Diskurs verschieben? Also wenn wir uns jetzt mal die Migrationsdebatten der letzten zehn Jahre ansehen in Deutschland, dann war das immer unter dieser Rubrik, wie viel können wir uns leisten? Das war die eine Frage. Und dann gab es die Gegenseite. Also das ist eher der, ich sag mal, rechte Diskurs. Und dann gibt es den, ich nenne ihn linksliberalen Diskurs. Er sagt, aber die Menschenrechte, aber wir sind doch verpflichtet und wir müssen den Menschen helfen. Was ist, wenn diese beiden Diskurse vollkommen unsinnig sind? Erstmal, weil sie komplett aneinander vorbei reden. Also das eine ist ein ökonomisches Argument. Und das andere ist eines, mit dem man wahrscheinlich relativ schwierig auf Dauerpolitik machen kann, wenn man sich immer auf diese Gefühle konzentriert. Beziehungsweise, glaube ich, nimmt man eine eigenartige Fokussierung vor. Dann sucht man sich auch Flüchtlinge aus und schaut sich aber andere Migrationsbewegungen nicht mehr an. Und es gibt dann so eine mehr deutige Politik dann auch. Also man konnte das jetzt bei Saskia Eske nochmal so schön sehen. Ich hab ja jetzt auch wieder dramatische Bilder von Flüchtlingen, die nach Europa kommen wollten, die dann wieder dort ins Meer gestoßen wurden. Anders kann man es ja nicht nennen. Und dann auch selbst noch kleine Babys, die da hochgehalten wurden von ein paar Monaten. Und dann schreibt dann Saskia Esken bei Twitter, dass ihr das Herz zerbricht, diese Bilder zu sehen. Zugleich stimmt sie aber dann dafür, dass weiterhin die Migrationsregeln verschärft werden, dass Deutschland keine Flüchtlinge aufnimmt. Also da sieht man schon, wie widersprüchlich das ist. Und sollte man nicht mit dieser demografischen Perspektive im Rücken und auch mit dem ökonomischen Wissen, das wir haben, auch mit dem Wissen, was jetzt da in China ist und wo das Problem für China bald liegen könnte, erkennen, dass wir von links, sage ich mal, komplett anders über dieses Thema reden sollten. Also nicht die ganze Zeit immer nach Menschenrechten rufen, weil man damit auch wenig Gehör erhält. Und das kommt auch, glaube ich, so in der Bevölkerung. Es ist zu abstrakt, dass man ganz klar sagt, Migration bringt Wohlstand. Und Mama, Onkel, Tante, ich erkläre euch mal, warum und wie es eigentlich aussieht. Und ihr habt auch alle Einzelkinder. Ich bin ja auch Einzelkind. Und was bedeutet das dann eigentlich für die Entwicklung für die nächste Generation? Und was bedeutet das für die Pflege? Was bedeutet das für neues Know-how, das wir eigentlich bräuchten, das aber dann nicht hier ist, weil es hier nicht entsteht und nicht genug Kinder da sind, all das. Also könnte man nicht eigentlich mit diesem Sorge, Migration bringt Wohlstand zunächst einmal diesen Diskurs verschieben und dann auch noch mal anders nachdenken, wie Migration organisiert wird. Also es gibt ja von Branko Milanovic solche Beispiele, wie man dann durchaus auch so für einige Jahre Migration in gewisse Gebiete macht zu so Sonderreglungen. Also wo dann die Frage ist, dürfen die Leute dann, die das hier sind, die nichts gleich die Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen, dürfen die trotzdem wählen oder nicht? Wie werden die steuerlich belastet bzw. wo zahlen die eigentlich dann ein, wenn sie vielleicht in zehn Jahren woanders hingehen? Also nicht, weil sie wieder vertrieben werden, weil sie wieder zurückgeschickt werden, sondern weil sie sich vielleicht umorientieren in ein ganz anderes Land und sagen, ich war jetzt hier Maschinenbauer in Deutschland, ich gehe jetzt nochmal nach Amerika. Also das müsste ja auch anders geregelt werden. Aber wir haben ja nach wie vor eine konservative Politik und Seehofer ist an erster Stelle zu nennen, die stolz sind um jeden, der abgeschoben wird, wo man eigentlich sagen kann, jeder der abgeschoben wird, ist schlecht für unseren Wohlstand. Also ganz egoistisch gesprochen, mal von dem, was dort an Leid produziert wird, abgesehen, produziert das auch einfach eine Wohlstandsminderung.
Also darauf gibt es eine ganz eigentlich, eigentlich eine ganz einfache Antwort. Wir haben erstens eine Bundestagswahl. Zweitens haben wir eine Bundeskanzlerin, die mit dem Jahr 2015 eine politische Verknüpfung anbietet medial, bei der man wirklich sagen kann, können wir doch jetzt mal aufarbeiten, oder? Der große Rückblick auf Merkel könnte ja sich durchaus mal auf 2015 zuspitzen. Und wir haben den Vorteil, wir liegen jetzt schon sechs Jahre, sechs Jahre nach 2015. Das heißt, die jungen Menschen, die mit 14 Jahren hierher kamen, sind mittlerweile 20. Die mit 12 hierher kamen, haben jetzt Abitur gemacht. Die machen in diesen Tagen Abitur hier in Deutschland. Oder die machen ihren Schulabschluss, haben ihn entweder schon, oder im besten Fall kommen sie mit dem Abitur und kamen aber eigentlich als kleine Kinder, die gerade so in die weiterführenden Schulen dann reingekommen sind. Und man kann sich ja durchaus die realen Zahlen jetzt angucken. Ich weiß noch genau, wie nach 2015 in die Spitze hinein die neue Zürcher Zeitung getitelt hat, die Migrationskrise wird Deutschland 1 Billion Euro kosten. Und wir können heute die volkswirtschaftliche Rechnung machen und kommen genau zu dem umgedrehten Ergebnis, sie bringen uns 1, 5 Milliarden, sie bringen uns 1 Billion mindestens. Und wir können eben auch hier wirklich jetzt breitflächig Bilanz ziehen. Es gibt diese Zitate von Jens Spahn und so weiter. Die Hälfte der Flüchtlinge, die damals kamen, in diesem Millionenjahrgang 2015 ist mittlerweile sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt, bringt also Zusatz. Es geht hier um 300.000, 400.000 Menschen, die zusätzlich in die Sozialversicherung einzahlen. Und wir haben mit 2015 das einzige Jahr, wo Deutschland wirklich mal im Plus war. Also demografisch gesehen, wo wirklich rein, also alles gewachsen ist. Deutschland ist an sich gewachsen. Das Arbeitnehmerpotenzial ist gewachsen. Alles deutet immer in die richtige Richtung. Eigentlich müssten wir das verstetigen, denn wir nähern uns so langsam. Der Rentenrepublik 2023 geht's los. Der 1964er Jahrgang, der größte der Baby-Boma-Jahrgänge mit über 1, 4 Millionen Geburten, geht 2029 in Rente. Das ist nicht lang hin. Das ist sozusagen noch mal von der Flüchtlingskrise 2015 bis jetzt. Und das noch mal eine Etappe weiter nach vorne. Dann sind wir schon fast bei 2029. Und eigentlich wissen wir, und das ist auch wieder ein Zitat von Jens Spahn, es gehen doppelt so viele Menschen ab jetzt in Rente. Und ab jetzt ist 2023 gemeint und sind nicht wirklich doppelt so viel. Aber das Zitat von Jens Spahn ist, ab jetzt gehen doppelt so viele Menschen in Rente wie von unten nachwachsen. Wir brauchen also Zuzug.
Was aber Jens Spahn dann selbst nicht tut. Also Jens Spahn hat ja dann jetzt noch mal ganz deutlich den Schuldigen bei Migranten gesucht, was Corona-Infektionen anbelangt, was die zweite Welle anbelangt. Und er ist ja auch damit bekannt geworden, dass er zusammen mit Klöckner so ein neokonservatives Think-Tank, aber ohne viel zu denken, gegründet hat, wo er dann noch mal ganz klar machte, wir versuchen uns jetzt mal ein bisschen von Merkel abzusetzen und versuchen doch wieder mit einer migrationsfeindlichen Politik Wählerstimmen zu bekommen. Und das versucht ja die CDU jetzt überall. Also das ist ja ganz, ganz erstaunlich, dass da überhaupt gar kein Bewusstsein für diese ökonomischen Zusammenhänge da ist.
Genau, das ist der amerikanische Weg, wie eben gehört. Ein Rekord an Festnahmen und verhinderten Grenze überschritten. Und gleichzeitig eine Politik, die dann dasteht und sagt, natürlich sind wir das offenste Land der Welt und wir glückwünschen jeden, der es geschafft hat zu uns zu kommen und uns zu bereichern. Klar, ich hab's jetzt auch erst mal richtig volkswirtschaftlich kühl runtergebrochen. Ja, also wenn wir unseren Wohlstand erhalten wollen, brauchen wir erstens eine Klimapolitik, die die Industrie wirklich umkrempelt, damit wir mithalten, wenn China und Amerika vorangeht. Und wir brauchen natürlich ein gleichbleibend großes Arbeitnehmerpotenzial. Und das schaffen wir nicht über Geburten, sondern das erfordert mindestens 400 neue Menschen pro Jahr durch die Zwanzigerjahre. 400.000 Menschen pro Jahr, genau. Ein wirkliches Zuwachs. Es gehen ja immer noch Menschen weg aus Deutschland. Das wird ja auch mal ein bisschen übersehen, dass sehr viele auch auswandern. Also wir sind eigentlich ein richtiges Migrationsland, wie alle außer Japan, alle reichen Länder. Aber da halten wir uns irgendwie raus, um wie Diskussionen so verlaufen. Und da finde ich eben immer noch interessanter, so die Gemütszustände sich mal anzuschauen. Das wird auch im Rentenopublik ein großes Thema sein. Nicht so sehr die volkswirtschaftliche Rechnung, die kann man auf drei Seiten machen. Aber dieser Gemütszustand, warum klafft die Semantik, die politische Semantik so weit von der Sozialstruktur weg? Das ist eigentlich die interessante Frage. Und hier hören wir mal Antje Höning von der Rheinischen Post, die im Presseclub saß am 9. Mai, um mal das Gerechtigkeitsargument hinter dem Klimaurteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts für uns darzustellen.
Sie haben ja in dem zentralen Satz gesagt, ihr müsst auf die Generationengerechtigkeit achten. Ihr dürft keine Politik mehr machen zulasten künftiger Generation. Die erste Frage, wo wir das anwenden, ist jetzt beim Thema Klimaschutz. Ich freue mich schon auf die Rentendebatte über die nächsten 20 Jahre, wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass wir da natürlich auch nicht heute Politik für Rentner machen dürfen, die möglicherweise später auf die Kinder zurückfällt.
Das heißt, das Urteil geht weit über dieses enge Thema Klimaschutz hinaus?
Absolut. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Dieses Klimaurteil ist ein Generationengerechtigkeitsurteil, bei dem man auch Klima als Thema austauschen kann. Da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht wieder eine Grundlage gelegt, um die eine oder andere, vor allem finanzielle Argumentation, mal zu machen. Eva Hummers, eine Ärztin, saß bei Markus Lanz und hat hier ganz interessanterweise mal Familien zur kritischen Infrastruktur erklärt.
Diese Frage, was ist eigentlich kritische Infrastruktur?
Genau, Eltern können kritische Infrastruktur sein.
Eltern sind ziemlich kritische Infrastruktur, finde ich. Die kommen dann da nicht vor. Im Moment ist es so, dass ich in Niedersachsen ein 18-Jähriger oder eine 18-Jährige impfen lassen kann, wenn sie Mitglied der freiwilligen Feuerwehr ist, was den vermutlich Zulauf beschert, der ihnen gegönnt sein soll. Aber nicht, weil sie Abiturientin ist und in die Schule gehen muss.
So, und jetzt habe ich ja am Anfang gesagt, es gibt diese historische Dimension, die Gipfelte in der Nazieherrschaft, die dann gesagt haben, für uns ist Familie alles. Das ist der Kern unserer Wehrfähigkeit. Also sind die Argumente, die wir heute sagen, Erwerbspersonenpotenzial, war damals Wehrpersonenpotenzial. Dass man einfach die Verteidigungsfähigkeit über volle Kindergärten hochhält. Das muss man natürlich einfangen. Denn natürlich kann man das einfach verteufeln und sagen, also diese Art von Kollektivismus, die hat uns alle ins Verderben geführt, das geht ja gar nicht. Deswegen spielen wir das kurz mit dem, von dem wir uns jetzt gerade verabschieden, nämlich von dieser hochklassischen, durch und durch von uns allen inkorporierten Individualisierung. Diese Singularisierung, Reckwitz und so, die haben sie alle aufgeschrieben, ist alles sehr gut. Und das kann man hier wunderbar runterbrechen mit Robert Putman. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt The Upswing, und da geht es um die Zeit, als das begann, als nämlich alle dachten, es ist mein persönlicher Wunsch, nach Woodstock zu fahren und dort eine geile Party zu machen. Und alles andere ist mir so ein bisschen egal. Ich lebe mich jetzt hier aus. Das ist ja eine ganze Generation, die plötzlich so aus der Kindheit herauskam und ins Leben startete. Und er hat ein Buch geschrieben, The Upswing, und spricht hier bei PBS mal darüber. Das ist ganz interessant. Drei kleine Clips dazu.
Which then expressed itself economically.
Every man for himself, würde er sagen.
Ich bin erstaunt, die tragen noch beide Hut, die Herren, die sich da unterhalten.
Das ist ganz klassisch. Na ja, inhaltlich ist das natürlich hochinteressant, denn nicht nur können wir den Baby-Boomern jetzt unterstellen, sie gehen mit ihrem eigenen Erbe falsch um, indem sie es nicht weitergeben. Davon sagt Sarah Wagenknecht, ich lese jetzt ihr wirklich sehr schlechtes Buch im Salon, aber die eine gute These, diese auf einem Satz zusammenstehen, ist dann doch drin. Irgendwann hat die Gesellschaft gesagt, nee, politische Macht kann man nicht vererben. Und dann war irgendwie klar, das nennen wir heute Vetternwirtschaft, und das ist illegal und das macht man nicht. Und natürlich muss man sich in der Ochsentour durch die Parteien kämpfen und nicht einfach, weil man der Sohn von Willy Brandt ist, wird man hier irgendwo her, sondern das ist klar, da ist einfach ein Generationenabriss. Politische Macht lässt sich nicht vererben. Was es mit ökonomischer Macht, die wird natürlich vererbt wie Mittelalter mittlerweile immer noch. Und da kann man natürlich nicht mehr drüber nachdenken, warum eigentlich. Und jetzt kann man hier dem Booman sagen, erstens, ihr geht völlig falsch mit eurem eigenen Vermögen um, das euch in den Schoß gefallen ist durch historische Zufälle. Ihr seid halt nun mal die Glücksritter-Generation. Nur, und das kann man jetzt ergänzen, ihr seid auch mit dem Erbe, das ihr bekommen habt, falsch umgegangen. Ihr habt hier einen Erbekollektivismus, allen geht's gut. Also dem Einzelnen geht's gut, wenn allen gut geht und so weiter. Ein bisschen Gleichheit, wir achten mal drauf. Und dann sind sie reingestartet und haben das alles kurz und klein geschlagen und haben nur noch den individualisierten Glücksritter gespielt. Das ist natürlich ein Problem.
Du kennst den bösen Satz von Peter Sloterdijk, alle Wege von 68 führen in den Supermarkt.
Genau so, genau so. Und da lebt man sich aus, weil man unter 100 verschiedenen Jogurts seinen Besten, der nur einem selber gefällt, aussuchen darf. Genau, und das ist das Problem. Also in den 60ern haben die Babyboomer aufkommend Amerika zerstört. So, und das finale Argument ist hier folgendes.
Lass uns mal gerade hier einhaken, weil das ja eine ganz erstaunliche Sache ist, dass man hier noch ein paar Dinge dazu gebracht hat. Nämlich, es geht ja nicht nur darum, dass hier aufgezeigt wird, also ökonomisch wird es schlechter, politisch wird es schlechter, sozial, sondern auch noch kulturell, also was die Bandbreite ansieht. Ich erinnere mich an eine Talks-Sendung mit Bettina Boettinger. Da war Romy Haag zu Gast. Romy Haag ist ein Travestie-Star und hat sich irgendwann auch dann umwandeln lassen in eine Frau, war zeitweise auch zusammen mit David Bowie in den 70er Jahren. Und Romy Haag wurde gefragt, ob sie das nicht unglaublich genießt. Jetzt heute diese Freiheit, die man dann hat. Trans-Personen haben ganz andere Stellenwerten in der Gesellschaft und so. Da sagte sie was sehr Interessantes. Sie sagte, nee, eigentlich war es in den 70er Jahren freier für mich. Also das fand ich sehr interessant. Also der Eindruck hier ganz eindeutig war, nein, es gab da eine große Freiheit und die ist keineswegs jetzt immer größer geworden. Das ist immer diese Fortschrittsgeschichte, die erzählt wird. Aber zu fragen ist, ob das wirklich so der Fall ist, ob wir nicht auch wieder so eine Rekulturalisierung erleben, dass Leute sich auf ihre Identitäten zurückziehen, dass es da wieder ganz große Konflikte gibt, so eine Tribalisierung, die wir nicht nur in den sozialen Medien verfolgen, sondern auch, dass eben die Identität so wichtig wird und dort wieder ein Platz des Kampfes ist und dass man in den 70er-Jahren vielleicht eher so ein Nebeneinander herhatte, dass eine gewisse Buntheit und Vielfalt war, ohne das jetzt zu verklären, weil ich ja auch nicht leugnen kann, dass es einfach rechtliche Dinge gab, die heute besser sind, beispielsweise für Homosexuelle als in den 70er-Jahren. Aber dennoch scheint sich da mental auch sehr viel verhärtet zu haben, was man ja deutlich erkennen kann. Also was, auch zum Beispiel, wenn man sich bei YouTube was ansieht, was dort so kommentiert wird. Also wenn dort Transgenderpersonen oder so, wo sitzen, welche Kommentare dort drunter stattfinden. Und die Frage ist, wo ist eigentlich da die Toleranz so unglaublich? Gewachsen. Andererseits haben wir es wieder mit einem modernen Kapitalismus zu tun, der diese alternativen Lebensweisen wusste, sehr gut zu inkorporieren. Also ich bin, ich bin dazu gespalten, was diese Idee jetzt von Putnam anbelangt, inwieweit die stimmt. Es gibt ja so ein berühmtes Buch, Die kulturellen Widersprüche des Kapitalismus heißt das, glaube ich, das ist von Daniel Bell und da wirft er eigentlich schon dieser neuen Generation, also diese 68er Generation vor, oh Gott, die werden hier Amerika in den Bankrott treiben und die sind zu hedonistisch. Und dann hat man aber eigentlich gesehen, dass zumindest der moderne Kapitalismus ja sehr gut darauf reagieren konnte und konnte all das auch integrieren. Und zugleich haben wir aber dann nicht mehr eine so sehr blühende Volkswirtschaft. Also wie geht das eigentlich alles zusammen?
Ja, das sind alles Fragen, die nur ein guter Ideologiekritiker beantworten kann, denn wir haben es hier auf so einer Semantik-Ebene mit Verwirrung zu tun. Und die strukturelle Grundlage, ob die dann wie die dazu passt und so weiter. Also das sind genau diese Gemütszustandsfragen, auf die es vielleicht nicht immer auch eine Antwort gibt. Deswegen kann man sich immer darauf beziehen, bei der Behandlung solcher Fragen einfach auf Leute zu kommen, die sich damit beschäftigt haben und auch ein gewisses Lebensalter mitbringen, um so Vergleiche anzustellen. Jetzige Generation später. Und das haben wir ja mit den beiden. Also sowohl der Journalist als auch der Robert Putnam. Die sind beide 60 plus. Die reden also über Woodstock im Sinne von habe ich im Fernsehen gesehen und so. Und dieses Finale, was der Robert Putnam hier einwirft. Und dazu haben sie noch mal ein zweites Interview geführt, später über Videokonferenz, weil er dann doch noch mal so ein paar Fragen hatte und so. Und da packt er Patman noch mal so richtig aus. Denn all diese Fragen, die du eben auch gestellt hast zum Thema, wann hat man sich wirklich freier gefühlt? Also dass man wirklich auf ein Gefühl abstellt. Da kann man natürlich unendlich viel darüber, was ist Freiheit? Freiheit und die Freiheit der anderen und so. Die ganzen Sprüche kennen wir. Vor allem hier in Deutschland. Und klar, wenn man in so ein kollektivistisches Sozialkontrollding eingebunden ist, ist das Freiheitsgefühl ein anderes. Aber eben auch das Zufriedenheitsgefühl ist ein anderes. Man fühlt sich anders aufgehoben. Wir reden nachher noch über Einsamkeit und so weiter. Diese ganze Gemengelage ist dann doch anders gewichtet. Was aber interessant ist, ist wie der Putman Putman Putman hier das nochmal runterbricht auf eine Zeit, die er auch nicht selbst erlebt hat. Und die er trotzdem mobilisiert, um noch mal Gegensätze der Gemütszustände aufzuschlüsseln am Ende. Und er beginnt damit, dass er Ingram genutzt hat, also bei Google über Google in Google Books nachzugucken, wann hat man eigentlich welche Wörter wie benutzen.
You see a real shift, not just, you know, away from using the first person pronoun to the we pronoun, but in asking Americans to rethink what this nation is really about in terms of our core values. And we saw a shift away from the social Darwinism, that sort of dog-eat-dog mindset of the time, into what historians call the social gospel, which was a movement that tried to get us to think more about what we owe to each other, what responsibilities do we have to each other in a society, rather than simply the idea that a society is one giant competition.
Wenn die Amerikaner vom großen Krieg sprechen, meinen sie nicht den Zweiten Weltkrieg so wie wir, sondern ihren eigenen Bürgerkrieg. Und jetzt sagt der Putman hier, ja, wir sind heute polarisierter, weiter auseinander als damals zu dieser Zeit. Wie auch immer das empirisch sozusagen das Argument gemacht ist, aber er macht es eben heute so im Fernsehen. Und ich finde, das sagt doch einiges über die Gemützustände, die hier so zugrunde liegen. Und naja, es klappt jetzt wirklich auseinander.
Und ich würde sagen, die Frage ist, ob die amerikanische, ja, die ökonomische Grundlage ist das A und O bei dem, denn es gibt ja diese ganz furchtbaren Kommentare dann in unseren Tageszeitungen. Ja, wir dürfen die Spaltung in der Gesellschaft nicht vorantreiben. Das sind aber die, die das schreiben. In der Regel Leute, die sind gegen den Mietendeckel, die sind gegen eine Erbschaftssteuer und all das und wundern sich aber dann, wo kommt dann diese Spaltung her? Oder wo kommen denn diese Shitstorms her? Und ich glaube, wir sind natürlich auch extrem fokussiert auf diese Arten der Konflikte. Also dass uns das ja gar nicht so interessiert. Also das war ja jetzt noch mal ganz deutlich, wenn man sich die Wahl ansieht, die wir ja dann im September hier haben. Es ist personenzentriert. Wir werden eine Tri-L-Inflation erleben. Wahrscheinlich wird Bild hier auch noch ein Tri-L machen wollen. Wenn sie jetzt TV-Sender sind. Wir haben eigentlich jetzt nur solche Streitigkeiten. Was hat Baerbock wo gesagt? Hat sie damit Habeck verletzt? Wischt Söder jetzt noch mal Laschet einen aus oder nicht? Das heißt, das ist auch ein Resultat dieser Me, Myself und iKultur, dass man nur noch auf diese einzelnen Personen blickt und auch dann sich fragt, komm ich jetzt mit denen aus gerade? Sondern es geht nicht mehr darum, was ist dann eigentlich das Programm? Die CDU hat ja noch gar kein Programm veröffentlicht. Das ist ja auch erstaunlich. Wir haben nur über Kandidaten gesprochen. Niemand vermisst offenbar auch dieses Programm. Man sagt, ja, das ist schön, mal gucken, was passiert, wenn der Laschet auf die Baerbock trifft und so. Oder wenn er mal von der Luisa Neubauer vorgeführt wird. Das ist immer wieder Theater für uns. Aber was eigentlich programmatisch die CDU will, interessiert gar nicht mehr. Ist ja auch für die meisten Politikjournalisten offenbar nicht mehr von Interesse, sondern man schaut nur, wie man diese Kindereien dort journalistisch begleiten kann. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was hochproblematisch ist, wenn man überhaupt noch an eine Transformation glauben will. Denn diese kann ja nie davon... Also jetzt hat man bei beiden Glück, dass der jetzt da durchgreift. Aber das liegt ja jetzt einfach daran, dass der ein sehr gutes Programm im Hintergrund hat. Das ist ja nicht, weil er einfach sich mal als irgendwie ein Macher aufspielen will. Aber wenn man diese Fokussierung vornimmt auf die Personen und was die, wo, wann, wie gesagt, haben, dann möchte man eigentlich keine Transformation mehr. Dann möchte man eigentlich ein ewiges Schauspiel dort haben, das nur dazu führt, dass man eigentlich in so postdemokratischen Verhältnissen dann lebt, dass irgendwann nur noch die Konzerne tatsächlich etwas ändern können. Dass dann die große Entscheidung von Google getroffen wird und die ändert dann auch unser politisches Dasein. Aber das ist dann nichts mehr, was von der Politik und von einer Programmatik herkommt.
Dann mache ich dir doch den Vorschlag, wir bauen unser Programm hier kurz um, denn wir wollten eigentlich jetzt so einen Brückenschlag, du willst ja viel über Twitch sprechen. Und wir sind ja eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit auf so Medien. Was ist mit den Medien und so weiter? Wieso fragen die Medien nicht nach Programmen bei der CDU? Warum reicht es völlig, ein Medien-Schauspiel mit den Protagonisten vorzustellen? Ich habe nämlich noch einen anderen Brückenschlag im Angebot zum Thema Fernsehen. Also dann bleiben wir jetzt mal direkt bei den Medien und auch bei den Generationenfragen. Am 9. Mai 1961 wurde in Amerika eine ganz wichtige Rede gehalten. Und zwar direkt in Beauftragung des Weißen Hauses. Damals hat John F. Kennedy regiert und der betreffende Typ ist 35 Jahre alt. Wir hören uns das hier mal an. PBS hat auch aus eigenen Gründen, das hören wir gleich, denn PBS, wir fragen uns ja immer in Amerika, da ist doch alles drunter und drüber. Da gibt es ja nur CNN, Fox News, MSNBC und die machen alle dieses hochpersonalisierte Catchen, dass da Wrestling stattfindet. Es gibt ja auch noch PBS, die einfach eine Stunde am Tag ohne, dass da irgendein Politiker eine mennenswerte Rolle führt, als ist halt der Präsident und hat Folgendes gesagt und so weiter. Also dass man wirklich sich eine Stunde Zeit nimmt, was man nicht mal in Deutschland sich getraut. Heute geht es nur eine halbe Stunde um die Tagesthemen, aber wirklich mal eine Stunde lang einfach nur sachlich in Familien. Das gibt es ja hier eigentlich nicht. Warum überflügelt uns Amerika an diesem Punkt so? Das wurde hier mal ganz gut aufgearbeitet. So. So, da ist also ein 35-jähriger Mitarbeiter des amerikanischen Präsidenten, der noch gar nicht in öffentliche Erscheinung trat. Und dann beauftragt wurde, jetzt den großen Aufschlag zu machen, das Fernsehen aus einer Wüste in ein produktives Medium zu verwandeln. Und der Typ lebt noch, er ist natürlich heute entsprechend alt. Also das ist 60 Jahre her und er war damals 35, also ist es 95. Wir haben es aber heute mit alten Männern, wir konnten ja auch Munga und Buffett schon gut zuhören. Dem Minnows, Newton Minnows kann man glaube ich auch ganz gut zuhören, trotz 95 Jahren. Er erklärt hier mal, wie es dazu kam und was sein Auftrag war.
Es war 1961, du warst der, was, 35-jährige, präkutigere Chef der kommunikationsfraktionen.
Ich war sehr beschäftigt mit Kindern, und auch mit dem Lack, was wir dann als Bildungsklärung nennen, jetzt Public Television. Ich war fest, etwas darüber zu machen.
Vor 60 Jahren hat aber die Amerika die Erfahrung gemacht, die Jugendlichen sind fasziniert von Medien, sind den ganzen Vormittag in der Schule, dann gehen sie aber nach Hause und was machen sie? Sie verbringen noch zweimal so viel Zeit am Nachmittag bis abends vor dem Fernsehen, als sie in der Schule sind. Eigentlich wird alles, was sie am Vormittag gelernt haben, abends wieder ausgetrieben, weil irgendein Typ kommt und meint, ich löse das mit meiner Pistole und dann guckt man sich so eine Krimiserie an, wo irgendwer. Diese Art von Medienkritik kommt einem ja heute bekannt vor. Die Jugendlichen sitzen nur an TikTok und Twitch und scrollen da durch und machen irgendwas und verschwenden eigentlich ihre Zeit. Und jetzt kann man ja sagen, nehmen wir uns doch mal den Newton Minow hier zum Vorbild. Was hat er denn damals gemacht? Also wir können ja hier einfach nehmen, YouTube, Twitch, TikTok und so weiter und sagen, ja klar, das sind alles Unternehmen, die wollen unglaublich viel Geld verdienen, nur wie wär's, wenn man denen auch mal ein Public Interest unterjubeln? Im Fernsehen ist das natürlich einfach möglich, weil die haben ja so eine Sendelizenz und so weiter, da kann man auch Sat.1 einfach sagen, du musst eine halbe Stunde am Tag und dann darf eben Alexander Kluge da irgendwie Quatsch-Interviews mit Harald Schmidt führen oder so, ja.
Aber das ist ja dann auch um 1 Uhr nachts, also da würde ich sagen, das ist ja auch nur noch ein Placebo oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte, ein Falkenplatt vielleicht.
Man kann es groß und klein denken, damals haben sie sehr groß gedacht.
And what I envisioned, my dream has been fulfilled.
Die Sesamstraße, die Sesamstraße ist noch wirklich gutes Unterhaltungsfernsehen für Kinder. Und die Sesamstraße hat ja auch eine enorme Pluralität reingebracht. Also die Sesamstraße hat ja viel mehr Pluralität schon abgebildet, gesellschaftliche, als das die großen Serien oder so getan haben. Also da gab es das auch in der Nische, aber die Sesamstraße ist ja nicht zu verachten, was sehr reaktionäre Leute ja auch immer mal wieder erkannt haben und die Sesamstraße als gefährlich eingestuft haben. Zum Beispiel gab es ja mal wohl in Deutschland den Fall, das ist aber schon Jahre her, dass ein Priesteramtskandidat einen Alumne-Ärger bekam, weil er so ein Fensterbild von Ernie und Bert hatte. Denn wir wissen ja, Ernie und Bert leben zusammen. Warum eigentlich?
Weil sie gute Freunde sind.
Weil sie gute Freunde sind, ganz genau.
Genau, also die Sesamstraße, PBS News Hour, bis heute ja auf Sendung dieser Walter Cronkite, der da immer genannt wird, weil er auch diese Namensgeber jetzt für verschiedene Instituten ist und so. Also große Blütezeit des informativen Fernsehens vor 60 Jahren durch einen politischen Akt. Im Weißen Haus wollte man das so. Also hat man den Weg dafür bereitet, einen Weg gefunden, das zu institutionalisieren. Und ich würde sagen, das kann man ja eigentlich mal übertragen auf heute. Und der Minow wurde damals auch inspiriert von einem Zitat, das ihm heute noch wichtig ist, deshalb er es hier in der Sendung nochmal vorliest. Und es bietet sich wirklich an, dass wir jetzt auch die Transferleistung herstellen und sagen, das ist heute genauso drängend. Man kann die Medien jetzt einmal austauschen, nimmt sich das neue Internet, guckt sich die ganzen Phänomene dort mal an und fordert im Grunde dasselbe.
Sie sollte die soziale Dilemma und die politische Schmerz aufsteigen und in einigen Minuten machen.
Also wo ist eigentlich das schöne, wahre und gute bei TikTok, YouTube und Twitch?
Wo ist das auch im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen, kann man sich fragen. Es gibt in den aktuellen Blättern ja einen sehr guten Artikel von jemanden, der aus diesem Rundfunkrat mal ein bisschen plaudert, wie das da ist und welche neue Strategie das öffentlich-rechtliche dort hat. Und da wird einem Angst und Bange, da geht es ja nur noch darum, wir müssen irgendwie das Publikum erreichen, wir emotionalisieren alles und das bedeutet auch immer personalisieren. Also das, was wir jetzt hier erleben, was ich eben kritisiert habe, ist das Prinzip Emotionalisierung durch Personalisierung und dadurch hat man eigentlich dann Desinformationssendungen geschaffen. Anders kann man das nicht nennen. Und wenn man dann in die anderen Medien schaut, also Twitch, YouTube, dann ist das ja noch alles viel schlimmer. Also ich hab heute Beispiele dabei. Es wird schlimm werden, aber ich glaube, wir müssen uns dem einmal aussetzen.
Genau, dann lass uns einen letzten Clip als Brückenschlag gucken. Denn jetzt haben wir es aus der politischen Richtung. Das ist jetzt PBS und so weiter. Es gibt allerdings das Gleiche noch mal aus der anderen Richtung beobachtet. Denn es gibt ja aber noch eine Gesellschaft, die damals empfänglich war, für dann das neue Fernsehen und so weiter. Und Ronald Braunstein Steen hat ein Buch geschrieben über das Jahr 1974 in Amerika. Eben der Minnow, das ist John F. Kennedy, 1974 heißt, Nixon hat zweimal die amerikanische Wahl gewonnen. Gleichzeitig haben wir aber schon im Untergrund sozusagen, dieses ganze Woodstock Zeug ist auch schon wieder fünf Jahre alt. Man war schon auf dem Mond und man hat schon das ein oder andere. Und jetzt geht eigentlich so diese neue moderne Gesellschaft los, technikgetrieben, Finanzialisierung und so weiter, das kennen wir alles. Und das Fernsehen musste tatsächlich erst lernen, sich mit der Realität auseinanderzusetzen. Also es ist ganz interessant, wie man aus vielerlei Richtungen, natürlich wieder mal nur im Fernsehen, wir gucken wieder PBS News, aber drüber aufgeklärt wird, wie schwer es sich das Fernsehen mit der Realität getan hat. Genauso schwer wie wir heute, wenn Influencer und so Thema sind, wie wir immer mitlaufen lassen, dass das natürlich fake ist und dass das zu falschen Emotionen und zu falschen Ängsten, also falschen Sinne fanden, dass es zu Ängsten führt, die eigentlich nicht gerechtfertigt sind, sondern die mehr über das Medium kommen als über die Leute, die im Medium sind, sondern dass das Medium selbst da generative Mechanismen hat. Und wie der Ronald Brownstein hier, also der hat es auch eine ganz wunderbare Formulierung gebracht, die man sich merken kann, um einfach dieses Problem mal auf den Nenner zu bringen.
Ich sage in dem Buch, dass Walter Cronkite eine halbe Stunde jeden Abend alle Fischers, die in der amerikanischen Gesellschaft geöffnet werden, dokumentiert hat. Das naheste, was wir in Vietnam waren, war Gomer Pyle und Michael's Navy.
Die Wall zwischen dem Medium und dem Moment, also der Realität und dem Medium. Da gibt es einfach eine große Klufte, die musste dann irgendwann mal eingerissen werden.
Und diese Kluft hat ja zur Krise Hollywoods geführt damals. Das kann man übrigens bei Margaret Nünse dann auch noch mal sehen, weil sie immer sehr schön zeigt, wie abgewirtschaftet das alte Hollywood ist. Sie zeigt dann, wie diese Kulissen nicht mehr gebraucht werden. Und man kann dann noch für ein paar Dollar sich mal durchfahren lassen. Aber was ja dort stattgefunden hat, war in den 70er Jahren, dass diese großen Studio-Produktionen nicht mehr angenommen wurden vom Publikum. die alle dann ihre Filme machen, die ganz anders sind, die also dann diese Mauer einreißen. Und das ist sehr erstaunlich, dass das erst da stattfindet. Und vorher hat man immer mehr in Großproduktionen Geld hinein investiert, das man aber dann nicht mehr rausbekommen hat. Also man hat solche Monumentalfilme gemacht, Musicalfilme, wie immens viel Geld, aber die hatten nichts mehr mit dem Moment zu tun, in dem das eigentlich gezeigt wurde. Und wir können das vielleicht sogar noch ähnlich erleben in der Schlagerbranche in den 70er Jahren in Deutschland. Ja, denn es war jemand wie Udo Jürgens, der ein bisschen die Wirklichkeit in den Schlager geholt hat. Udo Jürgens hat immer gesagt, ich möchte auch mal ein Wort wie Kreditkarte in einem Schlagertext haben. Ich will nicht immer nur Herz auf Schmerz gereimt haben. Ich möchte, dass da jemand eine Schachtel Zigaretten holen geht. Ich möchte ein bisschen die bundesrepublikanische Wirklichkeit auch haben. Und ich möchte Worte im Schlag haben, die Menschen im Munde führen in unserer Gegenwart. Und das soll nicht klingen, als wären wir noch im 19. Jahrhundert. Und das kann man da auch erleben, dass man in den 70er Jahren sich plötzlich dem öffnet, wie das dann hier im Fernsehen stattgefunden hat.
So, dann spiel uns mal Twitch vor. Und meine Arbeitshypothese, die ich jetzt mitlaufen lasse, ist, wir sind hier wieder ganz am Anfang eines Mediums, das dann irgendwann auch mal den ein oder anderen, entweder von außen her beigeführten oder aus innerer Motivation, eine Zäsur braucht.
Ganz sicher braucht das eine Zäsur. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie wir jetzt am besten anfangen. Ich fange persönlich an. Und zwar war es so, dass ich vor ein paar Wochen mit einer guten Freundin telefonierte, die Sozialpädagogin ist und eine junge Frau, 18, 19, ist die betreut, die gewisse Probleme hat aus der Familie und so weiter. Und die muss betreut werden, bzw. die soll so ein bisschen in das Arbeitsleben eingeführt werden, was dann eine Sozialpädagogin so macht. Und sie erzählte mir davon und sagte, jetzt sei etwas Eigenartiges passiert. Dieses Männchen sagte, ja, ich brauch mich gar nicht so sehr, jetzt um den Job und alles zu kümmern. Denn ich bin jetzt Streamerin und meine gute Freundin wusste überhaupt nicht, was ist da jetzt los? Und ließ sich das dann erklären. Ja, sie sei bei Bigo TV. Ich hatte das auch noch nicht gehört, sie auch nicht. Und das ist eine Streaming Plattform, die wirbt Leute an, dass man dort zum Livestreamer wird. Und dann sagte ich, ja, was macht sie denn da? Ja, sie sitzt da, sie malt dann so ein bisschen, was ihr aber schon aufgefallen sei, dass sie sich sehr freizügig kleidet. Also sie kennt die schon ein bisschen länger, betreut die länger und ihr fiel dann auf, weil sie die dann auch mal besuchte, als sie mit so einem Livestream gerade fertig war, dass sie wohl jetzt sehr viel Dekolleté dort präsentiert. Und dann hat sie dann auch gleich irgendwie so gedacht, was ist da los? Nee, nee, das ist jetzt so ihre Art, sich da zu zeigen. Also es ist natürlich keine sexuelle Plattform, aber interessant war es dann schon, also es fiel ihr auf. Naja, und was ist dann Bigo? Das hab ich dann nachgesehen und wir hören uns jetzt mal hier so einen Clip an von irgendeiner Agentur, die einem Ratschläge gibt, wie man auf Bigo, das ist eine Plattform aus Singapur, wie man auf Bigo erfolgreich sein kann, beziehungsweise wie man dort so eintritt in die Bigo-Welt.
Wie verdiene ich auf Bigo Geld und vor allem was kann ich verdienen? Um Geld zu verdienen, brauchst du unbedingt eine Agentur, die dich als offiziellen Streamer registriert. Du hast dich jetzt also für eine Agentur entschieden und schon einen Termin mit der Agentur für deine Audition vereinbart. In der Audition kommt es darauf an, zu zeigen, dass man für das Live-Streaming gemacht ist und dass man in das Gesamtkonzept gebogen ist. Ob du nun als offizieller Streamer zugelassen wirst, das entscheidet Bigo. Wichtig ist, dass du in deiner Audition wirst.
Ja, du hast also ein Vorstellungsgespräch bei einer Agentur. Und so war das wohl auch bei ihr. Und dann hat sie so gesagt, wer sie ist, was sie kann. Man muss nicht so viel können, muss man hinzufügen. Und dann wird man aufgenommen in diese Agentur. Das heißt, man ist also nicht selbstständig dort, wie man jetzt nicht einfach einen YouTube-Kanal machen kann. Und wenn er erfolgreich ist, kann man vielleicht auch ein bisschen Geld damit verdienen. Sondern man muss in einer Agentur, um überhaupt auf Bego stattzufinden. Ich hab jetzt das hier ausgewählt, weil mir das jetzt nahe war durch diese Anekdote, die mir erzählt wurde. Es gibt ganz viele solcher Plattformen. Und dieses Bego ist sehr, sehr dubios. Ich hab mir dann so ein paar Erfahrungsberichte angehört bei YouTube. Da war dann jemand, der hat sich einfach mal angemeldet dort. Hat aber dann nur so ein Testscreen eingeblendet, also wo man nichts sehen kann. Und hat dann zig Nachrichten bekommen, mit direkt links zu irgendwelchen Porno-Seiten. Das heißt, das ist eine Plattform, die enorm von Bots beherrscht wird. Und jetzt fragt man sich aber gut, man streamt da. Aber wie kommt man dann eigentlich an Geld? Beziehungsweise wer zahlt denn da?
Innerhalb von wenigen Minuten bekommst du im besten Fall dann eine Zusage durch deinen zukünftigen Agenturschef. Um wirklich effektiv Geld zu verdienen, gibt es ein paar Grundvoraussetzungen. Bigo gibt dir in den ersten zwei Monaten einen kleinen Weltenschutz, so nenne ich das immer. Du musst lediglich 30 Stunden im Monat voll bekommen, um dann im besten Fall 280 Dollar zu verdienen. Pro Tag werden dir hierbei nur drei Stunden angerechnet. Ab dem dritten Monat ist dann der Weltenschutz vorbei und es liegt an dir, 10K Beans zu erreichen. Beans bezeichnet die Währung auch Bigo. Das heißt, sende ich dir ein Geschenk, erhalte ich dementsprechend. Grundsätzlich gilt, du kannst zwischen 280 und 8000 Dollar verdienen. Dein Geld wird dir immer zwischen dem 7. und dem 15. eines jeden Monats in Form von Beans ausbezahlt. Diese Beans kannst du dir dann mit Hilfe von Payoneer ausbezahlen lassen.
Du musst nämlich dann, das habe ich dann auch erfahren, ich meine Freundin, du musst dann noch irgendeine Kreditkarte dir bei diesem Unternehmen zulegen und auf diese Karte bekommst du dann Geld ausgezahlt. Also es ist schlimm, aber dann fragt man sich ja, wie kann das denn überhaupt sein, dass man auf so eine Plattform in Singapur stößt, aber offenbar wird das beworben und da gibt es jetzt viele Glücksritter, die unterwegs sind, um Leute in den sozialen Medien und so weiter anzusprechen und zu sagen, hier Geld verdienen kann so leicht sein. Du brauchst dich jetzt nicht, um eine Ausbildung zu kümmern. Wir hier bei BigoTV mit unserer tollen Agentur, wir sorgen dafür, dass du 30 Stunden streams und dann 280 Euro verdienst, wo man ja sagen muss, das ist ja ein relativ schlechter Stundenlohn, das ist ja unter Mindestlohn. Aber dann kannst du irgendwann richtig reich werden, wenn dir viele Beans gesendet werden, so die Währung dort. Ich meine, wir lachen jetzt darüber, aber es scheint ein größeres Phänomen zu sein, wie schlimm das ist. Und auch, dass diese versprochene Selbstständigkeit natürlich überhaupt keine ist, sondern du bist einfach da in einem neuen Angestelltenverhältnis. Und zwar in einem, dem du noch nicht mal normal entlohnt wirst, sondern schlecht entlohnt wirst und dann noch so eine komische Mitgliedschaft da abschließen musst, um überhaupt deinen Lohn zu bekommen. Ja, also das ist absurd. Ich habe das aber mal als ein Beispiel rausgesucht, also wie wichtig dieses Streaming-Business generell ist, um sich jetzt auf die Plattform, die ein bisschen seriöser ist, zu konzentrieren, nämlich Twitch. Twitch hat einen enormen Zulauf erlebt. Durch die Pandemie sind die Aufrufe dort, bzw. die Streaming-Zeit, also was dort gestreamt wurde, die ist jetzt mit der Pandemie um 82 Prozent auf Twitch gestiegen. Bei Facebook Gaming um 79 Prozent. Facebook Gaming ist natürlich nur sehr klein im Vergleich zu Twitch. Aber auch ein starkes Wachstum ist da zu verzeichnen. Also Twitch hat jetzt pro Monat, werden auf Twitch 1, 8 Milliarden Stunden gestreamt. Das heißt, das sind also fast 2 Milliarden Stunden, werden auf Twitch monatlich gestreamt. Das sind bei Facebook Gaming noch sehr viel weniger. Da sprechen wir von 345 Millionen Stunden Streams. Und wir sehen aber auch, dass es bei Facebook einen erheblichen Anstieg gibt. Also möglicherweise kann Facebook Gaming sich dann wieder erwarten, doch noch besser etablieren, als man das erst dachte. Das wird sich noch herausstellen. Es gibt ja auch bei Facebook Gaming nicht nur Gaming jetzt, sondern dort gibt es jetzt auch schon andere Streams, die angeboten werden. Also mal sehen, wie man sich dort neu aufstellt. Was man festhalten kann, ist, es wird extrem viel gestreamt und ganz viele Menschen sitzen davor und schauen sich an, wie Leute irgendetwas streamen. Du streamst ja auch schon mal hin und wieder über Twitch den Podcast. Aber ich glaube, das hat rein pragmatische Gründe, oder?
Bei YouTube wird ja sehr hart durchgegriffen, was Content-ID angeht. Und da wir im Fernsehpodcast viele Clips spielen, die dann auch immer mal rausfallen, wird ja immer mal gesperrt. Dann greift dieser Automatismus, ich lege einen Spruch ein. Dann hat die Gegenseite 48 Stunden Zeit, Widerspruch zu machen, was sie nie machen, weil sich niemand dafür interessiert. Also weiß ich, okay, der ist jetzt erst mal zwei Tage gesperrt. Manchmal ist es dann auch nur ein Tag. Das ist dann ganz komisch, dann taucht er plötzlich wieder auf. Deswegen nutze ich jetzt das Angebot von restream.io, wo man nämlich ein Stream hinschickt und die verteilen das dann an alle Plattformen. Das heißt, der Fernsehpodcast ist dann immer in einem Tweet eingebunden. Also der ganze vierstündig in einem Tweet. Also du läufst einfach live mit in einem Tweet, der in dem Moment gemacht wird, wo der Podcast losgeht. Bei Twitch lasse ich es mitlaufen, weil Twitch kann ich dann wiederum auf der Webseite einbinden, bis dann das YouTube-Video fertig ist. Weil auf YouTube kann man immer noch besser gucken. Ich hab auch nie verstanden, warum Twitch so hinterherhängt. Einfache Annehmlichkeiten, wie ich hab den Anfang eines Streams verpasst. Also lass mich doch mal zurückspulen und in eine höhere Geschwindigkeit aufholen. So hab ich zum Beispiel deinen. Du hast ja auch 10 Jahre Filmanalyse Livestream gemacht, 2 Stunden. Da hab ich die erste Stunde verpasst, konnte dann sozusagen in doppelter Geschwindigkeit aufholen und war dann 5 Minuten bevor du fertig warst, bin ich vorne angekommen. Die letzten 5 Minuten liefen dann noch in Echtzeit sozusagen durch. Und das fehlt mir bei Twitch, dass man diese Möglichkeit hat, da einfach mal ein bisschen mitzusteuern als Zuschauer. Und was ich wirklich krass finde, weil du eben Facebook-Gaming ansprachst, mein Lieblingstreamer KingGathalion, der immer Destiny gespielt hat, und das hab ich dann immer geguckt, nachdem ich Redaktionsschluss 2015 geschrieben hab, nachmittags immer noch 2 Stunden Dings, ist auch erstaunlich, der war ja immer online so, ne? Wurde dann aufgekauft von Mixer, der ist also von Twitch zum Mixer gegangen. Mixer hat dann irgendwie Microsoft gehört oder so, ich hab's nicht ganz verstanden, ist dann, hat den Laden zugemacht, weil sie es nicht gelohnt hat. Und die sind dann alle gesammelt gekauft worden von Facebook. Also sind die jetzt bei Facebook angekommen, wo ich's natürlich nicht gucke, weil ich ruf keine Facebook-Seite auf, um mir das anzuschauen. So, und jetzt hab ich Twitch wieder ein bisschen für mich entdeckt, um na klar, selber das da einfach mit hochzuladen. Und manchmal guck ich aber eigentlich wenig, muss ich sagen.
Ich hab das jetzt mal als Experiment gemacht. Ich habe mir in diesem Monat extra für den Podcast jeden Tag bei Twitch ein bisschen was angesehen. Nie besonders lang. Also ich hab da jetzt nicht fünf Stunden gesessen, sondern ich hab mich einfach so durchgeklickt, habe mir ein bisschen irgendwelche Gamer angesehen, aber das kannte ich ja schon, das war mir jetzt nichts Neues. Aber was ich doch festgestellt habe, war, dass es dort sehr viele Leute gibt, die auch anderes streamen. Aber bevor wir mal zu diesen Inhalten kommen, wollen wir vielleicht erst mal so schauen, was ist eigentlich dieses Twitch bzw. aus welchem Geist heraus ist es entstanden. Und das wurde ja gegründet von Justin Khan. Und hier haben wir von CNBC so eine kleine Doku über Twitch. Und da hören wir uns jetzt mal den ersten Ausschnitt an.
Aber bevor Twitch das Internet von Storm nahm, die Karriere von Streamern wie Tyler Ninja Blevins, ging es um einen anderen Namen, JustinTV. JustinTV wurde 2007 eröffnet und wurde von Justin Khan und Emmett Sheer entwickelt.
Klärst du uns noch darüber auf, was dieser Justin damals gemacht hat? Das habe ich nämlich ganz eng verfolgt damals.
Ja, dieser Justin hat etwas gemacht, was Big Brother 2.0 ist. Er hat nämlich ein Programm entworfen, das wir dann alle uns runterladen können. Wir können oder bzw. er hat diese Seite entworfen. Und da konnte man sein Leben 24 Stunden mitverfolgen als Livestream. So und deswegen heißt es JustinTV. Das ist die Ursprungsidee von Twitch. Denn mich hatten auch schon mal ein paar Leute darauf hingewiesen, Bezug auf unser Buch, weil wir da von Twitch sprechen, wie das für die Influencer interessant wird. Da wurde gesagt, nee, nee, Twitch ist nur für Gaming. Das hatten wir welche geschrieben. Und hier kann man noch mal ganz klar sehen. Nee, an Gaming hat anfangs überhaupt niemand gedacht. Es ging darum, dass dieser Justin Khan, der ein hohes Aufmerksamkeitsbedürfnis hatte, dass dieser Justin Khan dort gesehen werden kann und dass man ihn dort verfolgen kann, mit ihm leben kann, indem man ihn sieht. Und dieser Justin Khan ist immer noch jemand, obwohl er ja ganz gut das Ding dann verkauft hat, jemand, der eigentlich in den sozialen Medien nach Anerkennung gierte, hat jetzt einen YouTube-Kanal seit ein paar Monaten und bettelt dann auch immer regelrecht um Abonnenten und sagt, ja, es wäre toll, wenn ich hier bald 250.000 Abonnenten habe. Und dann denkt man, meine Güte, der hat das für fast eine Milliarde verkauft, das Unternehmen. Was will der jetzt mit ein paar Abonnenten hier anfangen bei YouTube?
Also das war damals ganz irre, weil Twitch heißt ja für viele immer noch, sie sitzen in ihrem eigens geschaffenen Home-Studio und streamen halt von da, was sie tun. Und der Justin hat sich aber damals, und wir denken also 2007, das iPhone war nach gar nicht vorgestellt, das wurde erst 2007 dann spät vorgestellt. Oder nee, es wurde früh im Januar, Februar vorgestellt, aber es gab noch kein iPhone. Und der hat sich gedacht, okay, wenn ich jetzt draußen rumlaufe, mache ich mir an meine Mütze oben eine Kamera. Mit einem Kabel in einen Rucksack. Und im Rucksack ist da ein Handy und so weiter. Und das sendet das irgendwie ins Internet. Also der hat diese Pionierleistung erbracht, als es noch gar kein mobiles Internet gab, einfach einen Livestream von unterwegs zu machen. Deswegen gibt es ja auch, wird selten genutzt, aber die App ist tatsächlich ganz gut, dass man über die Twitch-App auf seinem Handy wirklich einfach sendet, was man sieht. Aber auch die ganze Twitch-Sache, also inklusive Chat und so weiter, dargestellt bekommt. Also man könnte, so wie Justin damals, rumlaufen und mit seinem Handy streamen. Er hat damals als Kamera an seine Mütze geklemmt und ist dann immer wie so ein Cyborg irgendwie rumgelaufen. Und das hat damals eine ganz schöne Welle gemacht. Ich hab das auch immer so ein bisschen verfolgt.
Und wir hören jetzt mal seinen Kompagnon Emmett Schier.
Es waren wahrscheinlich etwa 10.000 Leute in der Korn-JustinTV-Kommunikation.
Das war so erstaunlich, dass das da wirklich einer macht, sich so dauerhaft zu zeigen. Und dieses Experiment ist jetzt aber eigentlich so ein Flächenexperiment geworden, bzw. es ist kein Experiment mehr. Es ist jetzt die neue Realität von Twitch mit zu dem Erfolg beigetragen. Hat dann vor allem ein Konzern, nämlich Amazon, denn als dann Twitch gegründet wurde, also was sich aus Justin TV ergeben hat, hat Amazon dann dort sehr früh das Potenzial entdeckt. Und die haben dann dieses Unternehmen in den Zehnerjahren gekauft, 2014 war das, für knapp eine Milliarde Dollar. Und da kann man jetzt im Nachhinein sagen, das war ein Wahnsinns Schnäppchen. Dass viele, die uns zuhören, noch nie auf Twitch waren und man kann es ihnen nicht verübeln, aber um das mal ein bisschen klar zu machen. Also es ist so, man geht auf diese Seite, man braucht erst mal nichts runterladen, wenn man nicht selbst was streamen will oder so. Man geht einfach auf diese Seite und kann dort Leute sehen, wie sie streamen und zwar immer live. Es gibt zwar auch ein paar abgespeicherte Dinge dann von einigen Usern, aber entscheidend ist, was live stattfindet. Deswegen ist das vielleicht gar nicht verwunderlich, dass du dich darüber geärgert hast, dass es nicht wie bei YouTube ist, dass man mal gerade nochmal nachholen kann, was hat der Wolfgang vor einer Stunde gesagt hier, sondern man muss dabei bleiben. Man kann auch nicht sagen, ich lad das mal schnell runter oder ich mach das mal in doppelter Geschwindigkeit, sondern es geht darum, dass man einfach live mit Leuten Zeit verbringt und man kann diese Zeit dann auch in der Form verbringen, dass man ihnen Geld zukommen lässt. Und das ist dann durch dieses Partnerprogramm von Twitch, das 2011 schon startete und eigentlich YouTube sehr ähnelt, etabliert wurden und was dann optimiert wurde mit Amazon Prime. Das heißt, ich kann mir gewisse Abonnements dann kann ich verteilen. Also ich kann sagen, das ist jetzt so ein toller Streamer, der bekommt jetzt 4, 99 Dollar im Monat von mir. Das wird dann alles über Amazon Prime abgerechnet. Oder das kann auch höher gehen bis 9, 99 Euro oder 24, 99 Euro. Außerdem habe ich dann die Möglichkeit, sogenannte Bits zu senden. Also das ist so ein Tokensystem, dass ich also Trinkgelder gebe. Und das kann auch extrem hoch sein. Auch kann ich dann dort gewisse Emojis oder so einblenden, die Geld kosten. Also die kann ich dann meinem Streamer zukommen lassen. Und dann haben die auch so richtige Preislisten, dass die sagen, also wenn mir jemand für 24 Euro irgendwas zukommen lässt, dann sag ich noch, danke Stefan, vielen Dank für deinen Support.
Genau, das kann ich mal kurz erklären. Ich nehme meine Podcasts, alle, also Neue Zwanziger Fernsehpodcasts damals auch am Podcast, alle mit dieser Software auf, die auch damals, also die von den Streamern kommt. OBS, OBS Studios, Streamlabs, verschiedene Richtungen, alles das Gleiche. Und das ist ganz interessant, weil das ist eine große Entwickler-Community, die das mal ohne finanziellen Incentive arbeitet. Also es ist Open Source. Und es geht mittlerweile so weit, dass man tatsächlich verschiedene Layer auf seinem Bild hat. Und bei Ereignissen, die auf der Plattform stattfinden, also bei YouTube neue Kommentare, neue Abonnenten bei Twitch, wie auch immer, gibt es dann Dienste, die dir anbieten, dass sie in dem Moment Einblendung machen auf deiner Seite, die du als Streamer und das Publikum gleichzeitig siehst und auch hörst. Und dann kannst du da verschiedentlich, die Technik ist ja bekannt, Chroma Key, alles, was vor grünem Hintergrund stattfindet. Das Grün kann weggeblendet werden, also kannst du auch mit Transparenzen und so weiter irgendwelche Figuren über dein Bild tanzen lassen. Und es macht auch wirklich Spaß. Also ich erlebe es an mir selber, dass ich manchmal einfach einen ganzen Abend da sitze und einfach nur die Einstellung des Programms so weit optimiere, dass die nächste Aufnahme noch leichter von der Hand geht. Und in der Ansicht haben sie da wirklich so ein Volltreffer gelandet, so insgesamt, also so als Twitch-Plattform. Alle anderen, die das jetzt auch machen, YouTube und so, die sind alle Nachzügler. Twitch hat wirklich Pionierleistung erbracht.
Ja, und das ist dann vor allem groß geworden durch die Gamer. Und wir hören jetzt mal hier den erfolgreichsten Streamer von Twitch in der Gaming-Sektion, und zwar Ninja Tyler Blevins eigentlich. Und der war vor einer Weile in der Daily Show zu Gast und redet dann mal, wie so sein Arbeitsethos ist.
Und nicht nur acht Stunden, aber auch acht Stunden auf dem Grinden und den Übungen.
Ja, aber wurde dann auch mal weggekauft von Twitch. Ist auch so eine Figur, wo es dann drunter und drüber ging. Ja, aber er war der erste, der irgendwie 10 Millionen Abonnenten hat oder so. Nee, das will man nicht. Acht Stunden. Ich finde es auch ganz komisch, weil diesen Typ, den ich da immer verfolgt habe, King Cothelion, ich fand es halt gut, dass er immer da war, aber der Typ spricht ja immer nur in eine Kamera hinein. Also für den ist ja Null Interaktivität.
Ja, der muss den Chat mitlesen oder hat noch jemand, der den für ihn mitliest und ihm noch ein bisschen was reinfunkt. Und sonst hat man dort Leute, die mit wirklich viereckigen Augen da sitzen und irgendwie versuchen, diesen Tag dort zu verleben. Denn das ist extrem anstrengend. Also man kann dann mal sehen, wenn dort Leute sind, die seit sechs, sieben Stunden streamen, wie die dann aussehen. Also das ist Akkordarbeit. Manche werden da natürlich fürstlich entlohnt, andere versuchen es dann irgendwie. Und da sind dann auch ganz viele Leute, die 50 Zuschauer haben oder 10 Zuschauer haben und dann aber irgendwie versuchen, diese Show da zu machen. Was ich ganz interessant finde, die Zahlen generell sind ja nicht so hoch. Also wenn dort jetzt jemand ist wie Montana Black oder Knossi oder so, dann haben die mal 40, 50.000. Aber ganz oft sind auch so bekanntere Leute dort und die haben dann 6, 7.000 Zuschauer. Und da das ja nicht nochmal irgendwo anders ausgewertet wird, also ist das ja eigentlich eine relativ kleine Gruppe, die da zusieht. Also ich weiß jetzt zum Beispiel, dass es bei meinem YouTube-Livestream waren, dass knapp 3.000 die live zugesehen haben. Aber im Nachhinein haben halt über 50.000 das dann gesehen. Da würde ich sagen, das ist schön, auch für die, die das live gesehen haben, direkt eine Frage stellen können, ist es vielleicht dann nochmal besser. Aber wenn ich jetzt dann denke, ich hätte das gemacht und es hätten nur die Leute gesehen, die anderen hätten es gar nicht sehen können, weil sie es nicht aufrufen, frage ich mich, das ist doch ein bisschen für die Cuts.
Genau. Und die Twitch-Aufnahmen, also man kann ja sagen, bitte archiviere den Livestream. Ja, das ist dann auf der Seite irgendwo nochmal verfügbar und so, aber der verschwindet auch noch sechs Wochen. Also der wird dann automatisch gelöscht, da kann man auch nichts gegen tun. Das ist wirklich verrückt, dass dieses Live-Ding, also das spielt eigentlich nicht die große Rolle. Ich habe mich auch damals in Redaktionsschloss schon darüber gewundert, dass immer alle so vom Echtzeit-Medium sprechen und dem so eine hohe Attraktivität beizuschreiben. Aber das Echtzeit-Medium per se ist im Grunde die Tagesschau. Alle sitzen gleichzeitig 20 Uhr da. Und das war aber auch vor 50 Jahren möglich. Also dafür musste kein Internet entwickelt werden. Und für das, was wir heute Echtzeit nennen, das ist im Grunde die Archivfunktion. Diese auch kulturelle Archivfunktion von YouTube ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viel wichtiger als diese Live-Funktionalität, die dir Twitch gibt, um irgendwie kurze Einsamkeitsgefühle oder so auszutreiben. Also in deren Sicht finde ich das auch sehr merkwürdig. Und dieser King-Cathallion, drei, viertausend Zuschauer halt. Und ich war dann einer davon. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht weltbewegend.
Aber es scheint wohl so zu sein, dass die Haltung bei den Leuten, die dort streamen, ich will jetzt nicht immer für alle sprechen und sicherlich würden wir auch Leute Ausnahmen jetzt nennen können, aber doch die Haltung ist eher, naja, man macht halt diesen Stream, wie man so irgendeine Arbeit verrichtet. Aber es geht jetzt, glaube ich, nicht darum, dass man einen besonders tollen Inhalt kreieren will, dass man sich in irgendeiner Weise jetzt groß vorbereitet. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die sind wahnsinnig versiert in diesen E-Sports-Dingen, aber viele Laber-Streams, die es da gibt, oder Leute, die sich einfach zeigen, wie sie was essen, wie sie ja ein bisschen erzählen, wo sie gerade in Urlaub unterwegs sind, da geht es ja überhaupt nicht darum, in gewisser Weise noch eine Unterhaltungsshow zu machen. Also es gibt ja diese Phrase bei Filmkritikern, der Film war so spannend, wie Farbe beim Trocknen zusehen. Und den Eindruck hat man aber sehr häufig, wenn man dabei tütscht ist, was gucke ich da eigentlich, sehe ich da der Farbe beim Trocknen zu. Bevor wir uns zu diesen Inhalten noch weiter äußern und auslassen, würde ich noch mal gerade ein bisschen auf diese Monetarisierungsebene eingehen, auf diese Marketinggeschichte. Also wie kann man da jetzt eigentlich mit Werbung umgehen? Denn du kannst ja auch darüber Geld verdienen, wenn du als Partner anerkannt bist. Also wenn du eine gewisse Reichweite hast und eine gewisse Regelmäßigkeit, dann steigst du im Status nach oben. Und das wird hier einmal erklärt in dem Podcast Marketing Nerds.
Ist halt, dass ich direkt buchen bei Twitch mache. Da spreche ich dann so in Europa so von 10.000 Euro Mindestbudget, UKR 20 und USAR 50. Und das ist dann der klassische Direktbuchungsweg, wie beim anderen Publisher auch. Aber dadurch, dass halt Twitch auf Amazon gehört und die jetzt auch ihren Vertrieb gebündelt haben, kann ich halt auch über die Amazon DSP buchen.
Ja, Scott Galloway war sehr überrascht in seinem Podcast. Pivot, wir haben es schon häufiger hier erwähnt, ist sehr gut. Das Amazon-Ad-Network bringt mehr Geld ein als Twitters Netzwerbeding und so weiter zusammen. Also das wird immer ein bisschen übersehen und unterschätzt. Aber klar, die sind natürlich boosted direkt bei Amazon. Dann wird gefragt, wollen sie jetzt bei der Produktsuche das platzieren oder bei dem Twitch-Stream? Und dann sind wir da relativ nah dran.
Ich war völlig überrascht und vor allem jetzt, wie Amazon eigentlich da auch eine Plattform wie Google ist, mit den User-Daten, was hier erklärt wird auch noch mal Marketing-Nerds.
Die Amazon DSP bietet im Grunde genommen drei sehr starke Features. Oder sage ich mal Audiences. Das eine ist das Thema In-Market. Das heißt, wie verhalten sich die Leute gerade aktiv auf Amazon? Das heißt, sie sind in der Kategorie Baumarkt, da sind die in der Kategorie Bohrmaschinen. Und dann sind die gerade in dem Bereich Schlagbohrmaschinen. So was kann ich targeten. Und das kann ich dann entsprechend wunderbar kombinieren mit den anderen Audiences, die sie bieten. Das ist das Thema Lifestyle. Der Nils, der kauft immer gerne die teuren Produkte. Damit ist er ein High-Price-Item-Purchaser. Das kann ich dann wunderbar mit meiner Schlagbohrmaschine kombinieren und ihm die Hilty anbieten. Und dann das dritte Thema, wo sehr viel Musik drin ist, ist das Thema Retargeting. Und da gibt es einmal das Thema Retargeting von Produkten. Aber auch zum Beispiel Retargeting von Twitch-Usern. Also die entsprechend bestimmte Themen auf Twitch gemacht haben, um die anzusprechen. Der Fokus liegt wirklich eigentlich eher auf dem aktuellen Verhalten auf Amazon. Beziehungsweise auch zum Beispiel auf IMDB. Welche Trailer hat er sich angeguckt auf IMDB? Kann ich halt die Leute, die Kriegsfilme geguckt haben auf IMDB, kann ich dann wunderbar auf Twitch targeten für das neue Call of Duty?
IMDB gehört auch zu Amazon, vergisst man manchmal.
Andreas Weigend ist ein deutscher Software-Ingenieur, der damals vor 20 Jahren bei Amazon groß mit Einstieg um diesen wer suchte, wer interessierte sich für, interessiert sich auch dafür, wie diese Verknüpfung, die er damals mitentwickelt. Und er hat auch ein Buch geschrieben über Daten und so weiter, eines das mal nicht kritisch damit umgeht, sondern so richtig warum nicht und so. Und der hat schon vor zehn Jahren, als es noch keine, also als IMDB noch nicht dazugehört, als Twitch noch nicht dazugehört und so weiter, da schon gemeint, ja, also wir werten ungefähr 500 Signale aus von unseren Nutzern. Allein dadurch, wie sie die Amazon-Webseite benutzen. Wo verweilen sie, was klicken sie an, wo gehen sie wieder zurück. Und die Katharina Nockun hat ja für ihr Buch auch die Auswertung gemacht, sich das mal schicken lassen. Und du hast natürlich die sekundiöse Klick-Historie von deinem eigenen Amazon-Verhalten über Jahrzehnte mittlerweile, die du dir da abrufen kannst. Und die wird natürlich komplett verwertet. Und wenn da sowas wie Twitch dazu kommt, dann will man natürlich genau wissen, was für Vorlieben kann man da rauslesen. Und in der Ansicht sind wir da alle offene Bücher. Die kennen uns wirklich besser als wir uns selbst.
Und da ist die Google-Suchleiste gar nichts dagegen, wenn man bedenkt, was bei Twitch nicht gelesen werden kann. Aber wir werden ja bei Google gleich noch mal sehen, was in Bilderkennung oder sowas noch anbelangt. Und da fragt man sich dann, wie wird der Amazon auch diese Bilder analysieren können? Was ist da eigentlich noch zu sehen? Welches T-Shirt trägt Stefan heute? Wie viel hat er dafür bezahlt? Und was steht eigentlich da hinten im Schrank? Das ist vielleicht auch dann bald möglich oder wird schon gemacht. Es gibt auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Unruhe im Twitch-Universum, weil es nicht mehr so ist, wie ich das eben noch sagte. Ja, dann kann man ja so ein Abo da abschließen für seinen Lieblingsstreamer von 499. Denn wie ist das denn eigentlich auf der internationalen Ebene? Wir sagen 499, das ist okay, aber in einem armen Land 499 ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel. Und deswegen ist jetzt Twitch mal dazu übergangen und gesagt, ne, wir brauchen da auch regionale Preise. Wir können nicht so einen Einheitspreis machen. Ist ja auch was das Internet anbelangt oder die Telekom anbelangt. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass das überall gleich wie kostet, in welchem Land auch immer. Und das hat man jetzt gemacht. Und jetzt gibt es große Aufruhr. Jetzt verdienen ja vielleicht manche Twitch-Streamer nicht mehr so viel Geld. Und da hören wir jetzt mal ganz kurz einen Ausschnitt aus dem Mikroökonomen-Podcast.
Und zwar haben sie einen Dreimonatsdurchschnitt für jeden Creator errechnet, was er in diesen drei Monaten, also in den letzten drei Monaten, an Einkommen erzielt hat. Diesen Durchschnitt wollen sie erst mal halten. Also sie sagen, okay, ihr werdet jetzt erst mal Einbrüche haben. Aber da kommen so viele neue Leute auf die Plattform, dass sich das trotzdem für euch lohnen wird am Ende. Also so ist zumindest die Überlegung. Und wir helfen euch über diese nun schwierige Zeit hinweg. Über die nächsten zwölf Monate wird Amazon diesen Durchschnitt ausgleichen. Aber natürlich nicht zu 100 Prozent über zwölf Monate, sondern man kann sagen, es wird jedes Quartal werden 25 Prozent gesenkt von diesem Durchschnitt.
Genau. Dann ist halt die Frage, wenn die dann dadurch, dass es jetzt günstiger ist in anderen Ländern, mehr Abonnenten wieder dazu gewinnen, dann haben sie kein Problem. Aber zunächst mal bekommen die jetzt so drei Monate das ausgeglichen, dass jetzt nicht gleich große Umsatzeinbuße droht dadurch, dass jetzt vielleicht in einem Land, das nur noch 99 Cent kostet, jemanden zu abonnieren. Aber die Hoffnung ist jetzt dadurch, dass es in anderen Ländern billiger ist, wo ohnehin nicht so viel Geld unterwegs ist, dass man dann viele animiert Abonnements abzuschließen und so könnte sich das dann wieder ausgleichen. Man kann daran ganz schön sehen, wie prekär die Lage von Streamern auch immer wieder ist, wenn die Plattformen irgendwas ändern und sagen, die machen wir jetzt ab sofort so. Dann ist es nämlich mit dieser Unabhängigkeit, die die ganze Zeit suggeriert wird, sehr schnell rum.
Ich gucke nicht mehr so viel Twitch wie vor fünf Jahren. Also hier ist auch ein Markt ausgereizt. Und das hat ja Facebook auch. Irgendwann ist die westliche Welt, wo man 19 Dollar pro amerikanischen Kunde Werbekosten abrechnen kann, ausgereizt. Und dann ist der nächste Markt immer in der Obert-Indien. Aber da kriegt man nicht 19 Dollar pro Jahr pro Person, sondern nur noch 19 Cent und so. Und dann muss man das halt irgendwie einpreisen in seine Kalkulation.
Ganz richtig. Das Monatsexperiment von mir sah ja so aus, dass ich zu verschiedenen Tageszeiten einfach mal so reinschaue, was machen da Leute? Und dann ist mir zum Beispiel aufgefallen, da ist eine junge Frau, die lötet irgendwelche Dinge. Man sieht sie dann mit dem Lötkolben dort und dann kreiert sie dort etwas. Das schauen sich Menschen an. Oder man sieht irgendwelche Landwirte, die mit dem Traktor durch die Gegend fahren. Man sieht sehr viele Leute in Planschbecken sitzen, leicht bekleidet, dazu kommen wir gleich noch. Aber bleiben wir erst mal bei dieser Arbeitszeite. Und zwar haben wir ja vor einigen Wochen ein ProSieben-Ereignis erlebt. Nämlich hat man ja dort eine Intensivpflegerin mit einer Bodycam ausgestattet und hat ja dann mal sieben Stunden live gestreamt.
Just in the morning.
nicht live war das, glaube ich, nicht live. Aber man hat es aufgezeichnet und dann nachher etwas zusammengeschnitten. Aber man hat die gesamte Schicht einer Intensivpflegerin gezeigt. Zwischendurch gab es ein paar Kommentare dann mal von Alexander Jorde und ein paar anderen bekannteren Pflegern oder unbekannteren Pflegern. Aber man wollte einfach mal die Arbeit wirklich zeigen. Und das wurde ja dann auch entsprechend gefeiert. Und man kann aber bei Twitch sehen, eigentlich gibt es dieses Genre schon ganz lange. Also das hat jetzt nicht ProSieben erfunden, sondern das machen die eigentlich da die ganze Zeit. Vielleicht nicht in der Intensivpflege, ist ja auch ein bisschen schwierig. Aber es gibt beispielsweise einen Backer, der heißt Pavel Boldt. Und der streamt auch auf Twitch, wie er dann morgens in der Backstube so herum werkelt. Und da hat Deutschlandfunk Nova ihn mal getroffen und ihn mal dazu befragt. Und Folgendes sagt er da.
Als er vor zwei Jahren mit dem Streamen anfing, hatte er nur ein paar Follower. Inzwischen könnte er mit seinen Fans ein Fußballstadion füllen. Pavel Boldt will so nicht nur Werbung für seinen Betrieb. Und seinen Online-Shop machen. Ihm geht es auch darum, nicht unterzugehen. Es gibt eine Bäckerei, Sterben. Es ist einfach so, dass kleine Bäckereien immer weniger werden. Und die großen immer größer.
Es werden nicht weniger Bäckereien, sondern die großen übernehmen wir noch wieder.
Das verstehe ich nicht ganz, aber gut.
Naja, der Wunsch ist, glaube ich, dass man dieses Handwerk noch dort präsent hält. Und wahrscheinlich auch, dass man dort noch mal eine andere Einnahmequelle hat. Denn eigentlich denkt Pavel Bolz schon größer. Er denkt in Finn-Kliman-Manier, wie wir jetzt hier hören.
Aber warte, sagt er, will er uns sagen, nicht unterzugehen im Sinne von, dass die Leute, die bei ihm konkret einkaufen, ihn über seinen Stream da schon kennen und deswegen lieber bei ihm einkaufen gehen. Weil wir haben es ja hier mit, auf der einen Seite, jeder kann zuschauen, egal wo auf der Welt, aber zu einem Bäcker geht man ja doch, das ist das maßgebende Kriterium, ist er nah genug, kann ich schnell hin oder nicht?
Ganz genau und ich glaube ihm geht es da um was anderes. Ich glaube es geht ihm darum, er mit diesem Beruf eine Reichweite zu erzielen und die Zukunft sieht vielleicht schon ganz anders aus, wie er hier schildert.
Seine beiden Gesellen sind froh, wenn sie nicht gefilmt werden. Pavel Boldt denkt dagegen schon weiter. Er träumt davon, mit seiner Frau und seinen zwei Töchtern eines Tages irgendwo in Schleswig-Holstein einen alten Hof zu kaufen, auf dem Urlauber in den Pony reiten könnten und in der ländlichen Backstube selber mit Hand anlegen. Natürlich alles gestreamt.
Ja, es vom Influencer-Virus erfasst.
Gewissermaßen ja. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was aber sehr viele sich erträumen, dass sie eine Selbstständigkeit mit diesem Stream kreieren können und dass sie dann in einer Weise unabhängig werden von Dingen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel so eine Kapitalkonzentration, was die Bäckereien anbelangt oder was man auch sehr viel sehen kann, ist, dass Leute sagen, ich reise eigentlich gerne, aber ich kann mir das ja eigentlich nicht leisten. Und jetzt versucht man das über so ein Stream zu machen. Also ich habe zum Beispiel einen regelmäßig jetzt in diesem Monat geguckt, der ist in Thailand unterwegs und ist dort in so einem Apartment eingemietet, aber mit Hotelbetrieb gleichzeitig. Also er hat missermaßen Platz, aber auch noch den Hotelservice dabei. Und der reist dann so durchs Land und erzählt ein bisschen was, fährt dann mal Boot, nimmt einen mit. Und da sind dann Leute, die ihm da bei permanent zusehen, die aber auch solche Abonnements abschließen oder kleine Spenden machen. Und er sagt dann, na ja, ich zahl hier die Woche 80 Euro oder was. Das reicht dann, davon kann ich das machen. Und dieser Wunsch ist wohl bei sehr vielen präsent, was man dort eindeutig beobachten kann. Hier noch mal in dem Nova-Beitrag kommt ein Landwirt zu Wort, der Landwirt Eike.
Oder Landwirt's kleine Farm, wo Eike aus dem schönen Niedersachsen zeigt, wie der Alltag als Landwirt ist. Fast 6000 Follower sind dabei, wenn Eike mit dem Traktor neue Strohladungen holt und ihm Beifragen zu seinem Beruf beantwortet.
Tendenziell soll der Betrieb so aufgestellt werden, dass wir mit Eigentumsflächen leben können. Das ist eigentlich das Ziel, dass man nicht unbedingt auf Pachtflächen angewiesen ist.
6.000 Leute mit auf dem Acker, das ist viel.
Das habe ich mir auch angesehen und es stimmt. Die Zahlen stimmen. Ich habe das auch gesehen an einem Samstag, einem Sonntag mal. Ich glaube auch Jenny, unsere Podcast-Kollegin, hat sich auch diesen Landwirt mal angesehen. Ja, das ist erstaunlich, was dann auch so für Fragen kommen. Also diese üblichen Twitch-Fragen und so bla bla. Aber es kommen dann auch ganz klare Fragen zum Thema Landwirtschaft, die er dann beantworten kann. Ansonsten ist das jetzt auch nicht übermäßig spannend. Und ich bin ja jemand, der noch Filme guckt, der eigentlich nicht zu dieser Streamer-Generation gehört. Und deswegen habe ich da ein anderes Verständnis von Dramaturgie und Spannungsaufbau. Und ich musste selbstverständlich an einen Film denken, der schon das Streaming vorwegnimmt, nämlich Das Fenster zum Hof von Alfred Hitchcock. Den kennst du bestimmt auch. Wir haben es ja dort mit jemand zu tun, der einen Unfall hat, James Stewart. Er ist jetzt erst einmal dazu verdammt eingegipst, da zu sitzen und der kann nur aus dem Fenster blicken. Und was sieht er dort? Er sieht den Innenhof, er sieht die Nachbarn und schaut in diese Fenster hinein. Und wir hören uns jetzt eine ganz kleine Szene an. Er sitzt da, blickt mal wieder raus, beobachtet dann manchmal auch die eine Nachbarin, die da im Bikini irgendwelche Übungen verrichtet. Und jetzt kommt die Pflegerin rein, die ihm immer einmal am Tag den Rücken massiert und kommentiert das folgendermaßen. Ja, wir sind eine Gesellschaft von Spannern geworden.
Von wann ist der Film?
Von, ich glaube, 54 oder 56. Grandios, wer ihn noch nicht gesehen hat, sollte ihn jetzt mal einfach nur unter dieser Rosproprik Streaming sich nur mal mit dieser Brille quasi ansehen. Es ist ein genialer Film, der auch noch das hat, was Twitch nicht hat, nämlich Spannung. Was passiert eigentlich auf Twitch? Ja, es ist ganz grästlich und ich hab jetzt mal Beispiele rausgesucht. Und zwar hab ich jetzt nicht irgendwas da abgefilmt und das jetzt hier reingeschnitten, sondern es gibt ja auch schon Material über Twitch. Und zwar gibt es ja von Funk dieses Format Wire Collektiv. Und die haben damals zwei Streamer besucht, unter anderem Fräulein Freitag. Und da wird das jetzt mal eingeführt, was Fräulein Freitag dort eigentlich so macht bei Twitch.
Das ist von Fräulein Freitag's Stream. Vivi heißt sie in echt und sie ist 23 Jahre alt. Sie streamt auf Twitch, hier gerade im Just Chatting Bereich. Manchmal streamt sie auch, wie sie spielt. Insgesamt wurde dieser Stream bisher über 15.000 Mal angeschaut. Im Chatfenster rechts kommen ständig Nachrichten rein. Auf die meisten reagiert sie.
Wird ihr wohl nicht mal allen geholfen? Das ist schön. Das ist das, wie es sein sollte.
Mein Eindruck? Die Themen sind eher belanglos.
Hauptsache keine weißen Wände. Also ich muss sagen, ich mag so dunkelgrau, finde ich schön.
Dafür gibt es aber verbale Fürsorge für jedes Wehwehchen.
Das ist gar kein Problem. Du darfst gerne schlafen. Ruh dich ein bisschen aus.
Und sie macht das hauptberuflich. Pro 5 Euro Monats-Abo geht die Hälfte an sie. Und man kann ihr während des Streams Geldgeschenke machen. Dann sagt sie meistens.
Eveli, Dankeschön. Dankeschön.
Also, die große Anke Engelke hat ja irgendwann mal das Fernsehen damit revolutioniert, dass sie zwar noch Witze im Fernsehen macht, die aber keine Pointe mehr haben. Die nämlich einfach nur albern sind. Dann guckt man sich das an und nach 30 Sekunden ist Schluss. Und hier geht's halt ein bisschen länger.
Naja, also dieser Vergleich hinkt mir doch sehr. Da Anke Engelke nun ein riesengroßes Talent ist und die natürlich diese Nicht-Pointe zu einer enormen Pointe ausgebaut hat. Aber das ist schon ganz erstaunlich, was hier stattfindet. Und ich musste ja schon bei der Beschäftigung mit den Influencern immer wieder denken, nicht nur die Follower, auch die Influencer selbst scheinen sehr einsam zu sein. Bei den Streamern wird das noch offensichtlicher, wie wir hier auch hören.
Das bedeutet mir einfach so viel, dass ich es gar nicht wirklich in Worte fassen kann. Es ist halt die Möglichkeit, dass ich nicht einsam bin. Das ist die Möglichkeit, dass ich damit Geld verdiene. Das ist eines der größten Träume, die die meisten Menschen haben. Das ist unfassbar.
Die meisten Menschen, da projiziert sie einfach wild herum.
Ja, die meisten Menschen wollen vielleicht eine andere Form der Anerkennung, vielleicht auch eine im Kollegenkreis oder wollen irgendetwas produzieren und wollen sich nicht die ganze Zeit ausstellen. Denn das ist ein Leben, das ja auch den 8-Stunden-Tag nicht aufhebt, sondern eigentlich ihn noch verlängert und auch noch weiter auf den Samstag und den Sonntag dann ausweitert. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz eigenartige Vorstellung von Selbstständigkeit, die hier aufkommt. Es ist eher eine Art des Rückzugs aus der Welt und man sieht dann auch mal eingeblendet, wer ihr so folgt. Also es gibt noch so einen Chat danach immer. Das macht sie dann mit ihren Usern, die sie dann besonders finanziell unterstützen. Und das ist eine junge Frau von Anfang 20. Und man sieht dann diese User, die alle über 30 sind, die alle Männer sind, die sich das ansehen. Und ich will jetzt den Männern nicht irgendwie unterstellen, die machen das aus einem sexuellen Interesse, weil dann könnten sie auch auf andere Seiten gehen. Aber dass das für sie wichtig ist, dass sie dann eine junge Frau sehen, weil sie vielleicht sich auch eigentlich sehen, eine Freundin zu haben, die sie aber nicht haben. Und dann finden sie die aber ganz sympathisch. Und das wäre eigentlich auch schön, wenn man zu Hause gemeinsam saß und überlegt, wie machen wir eigentlich die Wände, weil wir beide keine weißen Wände mögen. Also das ist eigentlich das, was da transportiert wird.
Aber was heißt Chat danach? Was meinst du mit Chat danach?
Das machen die dann nochmal über Discord zum Beispiel. Audio only. Oder hier machen die das per Zoom, glaube ich. Also zumindest sind diese dann alle mal kurz zu sehen dort in dieser Doku. Das heißt, Discord ist ja auch ganz, ganz wichtig. Also das unterschätzen wir auch ein bisschen wie du hast ja Discord auch schon ewig genutzt. Ich weiß, als wir das erste Mal ein Podcast zusammen gemacht haben, als ich bei Aufwachen war, da hast du gesagt, ja, du musst dir aber Discord installieren. Und Discord ist aber für diese Streamer ganz, ganz wichtig und auch für solche Community Bildungen, die dann auch mit Pay, Abos und so funktionieren. Ganz, ganz entscheidend. Naja, das ist also jetzt Fräulein Freitag, die nochmal gefragt wird von der Moderatorin hier, wie meinst du das dann mit der Einsamkeit?
Du hast gesagt, das hilft gegen die Einsamkeit. Kannst du das noch genauer erklären?
Als ich angefangen hab zu streamen, hatte ich einen recht großen Freundeskreis, die alle dagegen waren. Die fanden das überhaupt nicht gut. Dementsprechend haben sie sich alle von mir abgewandt. Und ich hatte irgendwann nur noch den Stream. Aber dadurch, dass ich halt, wenn ich live war, so gesehen Leute hatte, die mit mir geredet haben, mit denen ich so gesehen meine Zeit verbringen konnte, war das dann irgendwann so die Alternative für mich.
Ja, das vertiefen wir gleich noch mal so ein bisschen. Aber da kann man nur spekulieren, was das alles so bedeutet. Wie meint sie es wirklich? Was fühlt sie da? Gibt es da einen Leidensdruck? Ist das jetzt, sie projiziert das ja auch auf alle anderen und sagt, ich erlebe gerade den Traum der anderen. Weiß sie das überhaupt?
Ist das so? Es ist auf jeden Fall recht traurig. Und es wird auch traurig bleiben, wenn wir uns jetzt mal Andi anhören. Der ist gamingsüchtig, sagt er von sich und hat auch lange Zeit als Twitch-Streamer gearbeitet, kann man ja sagen, obwohl er nur 15 war und eigentlich das schon in die Rubrik Kinderarbeit fällt, hat er dort bei Twitch enorm viele Stunden gerackert und schildert jetzt mal so ein bisschen, wie er sich fühlt.
Vielleicht aber auch durch Andi. Auch er war bei Twitch unter Vertrag, hat damit Geld verdient und ist gamingsüchtig. Er ist 16, lebt bei seiner Mutter. Er sagt, es sei besser geworden. Trotzdem hänge er um die 10 Stunden am Tag vorm PC. Ich will wissen, warum.
Das frage ich mich auch, warum ich das mache. Das ist langweilig, wirklich. Das ist einfach nur noch langweilig. Die Spiele sind langweilig und es gibt ja keine neuen Spiele. Und es ist ja langweilig für mich. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich es noch spiele.
Eigentlich finden alle Spiele langweilig, weshalb man ja anderen zuguckt, wie sie für einen spielen, damit man währenddessen was anderes machen kann. Und ich hab gerade, als wir hier kleine Pause gemacht haben, heute kommt auch die neue Unreal Engine Nummer 5. Da gibt es ja auch diesen großen Streit nach. Epic gegen Apple und so weiter, den wir heute nicht groß behandeln, aber der liegt auf der Liste. Und mittlerweile sehen die Welten ja aus, als hätte man sie abgefilmt, als hätte man sie fotografiert. Und das kenne ich mal von mir selber. Ich will diese Spiele nicht spielen, aber ich finde es nicht schlecht, wenn es so als Kulisse, ich habe das ja auch für James Bond schon mal gesagt, wenn es als Kulisse einfach so auf Bildschirme nebenherdudelt. Und das Angebot machen ja diese Streamer, dass sie für einen diese Welt eröffnen, ohne dass man selber die Hände voll hat, eben sich in dieser Welt zurechtzufinden, sondern die machen das. Und wenn er sich aber selber schon darin langweilt, ist natürlich problematisch.
Ja, und das ist die Tendenz zum Second Screen selbstverständlich. Also man ist noch mal auf dem Smartphone mit anderen Dingen dann beschäftigt oder hat noch mal ein Tablet auf dem Schoß. Und wir hören jetzt noch mal Andi, was er sagt, weil er sich irgendwann ja entschied, damit aufzuhören. Und die Community hat dann schon geglaubt, hat er sich jetzt umgebracht oder was ist da los?
Erlösend. Ja, wirklich sehr erlösend, weil ich finde, ich hatte immer so einen Druck und diese Pflicht, diesen Streamingplan einzuhalten. Also als Partner ist es schon wichtig, sagt Twitch, dass du dir einen Streaming, also dass du geregelte Streamingzeiten hast. Das war immer so ein Druck, dass ich dann immer dann und dann zu der Uhrzeit da sein musste.
Man kann ab 13 Twitch Partner werden, also Einnahmen erhalten. Dann müssen aber die Eltern einen Vertrag unterschreiben. Im Grunde verstößt ein solcher Stream aber gegen Kinderarbeitsgesetze. Nach denen hätte Andi mit 15 nur zwei Stunden täglich neben der Schule arbeiten dürfen. Und das nur zwischen 8 und 18 Uhr.
Ja, das ist interessant. Da kann ich auch mal schildern. Twitch macht ja die Pflicht, exklusiven Inhalt anbieten zu müssen. Also wenn du Streamer bist im Affiliate-Programm, muss die ersten 24 Stunden das Zeug exklusiv bei Twitch sein, was ja für einen Fernsehpodcast bedeutet. Ich bin ja nicht exklusiv. Ich hatte aber noch diesen Affiliate-Status, also wollte ich mich von dem abmelden. Also Twitch mitteilen, ich will jetzt gar kein Geld mehr von euch haben und ich will auch keinem User die Möglichkeit geben, mich für fünf Euro zu abonnieren oder sonst irgendwie. Und es geht tatsächlich nur, indem ich da eine Mail hinschreibe. Also da musst du echt eine Mail hinschreiben. Und dann kriegst du eine Mail zurück und dann wird gefragt, wie bla bla bla, authentifizier dich mal und so. Aber das ist dann so richtiger eins zu eins Mailverkehr, während du einfach so reinklickst und dieses Angebot bekommst. Die Stream-Auswertung ist ja auch immer, heute haben so und so viele Chatfrequenz war und peak und so weiter und so fort. Also die ziehen nicht so richtig rein in diese verschiedenen Status, Stati, die du so erringen kannst. Und eigentlich sollst du die behalten und nicht dein Twitch-Account löschen. Das ist ja unerhört.
Das wäre aber auch ein wichtiges Thema für ein Familienministerium, wäre es besetzt. Beziehungsweise, wer macht das jetzt gerade? Ich hab schon wieder vergessen.
Die Justizministerin, lieber Knecht, macht stellvertretend, weil man kann ja beides gleichzeitig machen.
Ja, man hat sich ja ohnehin nie um die Familien gekümmert. Dann braucht man das auch jetzt nicht zu machen. Also das Amt kann man einfach dann so mal schnell vergeben. Und das wäre aber ein ganz wichtiges Thema. Also wer zum Beispiel im Kinderchor ist, der Opa Frankfurt und tritt dort auf, da ist sofort Alarm, wenn da sich irgendwas verzögern würde. Also sagen wir mal, die Vorstellung fängt 20 Minuten später an. Dadurch verzögert sich der Auftritt des Kinderkurss und 20 Minuten. Dann gibt es schon Ärger. Dann muss das in der Oper so sein, dass der Chor vor der Pause auftritt, weil das sonst zu spät wird. Dann ist nach neun, dann geht nichts mehr. Wie lange haben die Kinder geprobt? Das wird alles sehr genau überwacht. Und ich bin gar nicht dagegen, dass das so ist. Das ist alles sehr gut. Und hier, dort wird man nicht entsprechend gemaßregelt. Und das ist schon ganz erstaunlich. Und ich habe natürlich auch viele junge Leute dort jetzt bei Twitch gesehen. Ich meine, da steht nicht immer das Alter da. Aber wo ich dachte, die sind garantiert keine 18, sondern die sind wesentlich jünger, die da streamen. Und wer weiß, was die da streamen und wie lange die da streamen. Und das waren tatsächlich oft Zeiten, wo ich dachte, die müssten ja eigentlich im Bett sein.
Ja, du musst ja gar nicht den Kinderchor der Opa nehmen, sondern jeden Karnevalsverein. Die Sitzungen sind üblicherweise abends 20 Uhr. Und natürlich treten da auch die Kleinen noch mal auf. Die haben ja auch einen Tanz einstudiert. Die sind natürlich immer gleich die Ersten. Aber wer, es geht nicht pünktlich 19.11.20.11 Uhr los, sondern verzögert sich, dann wird das Ei gleich brenzlig. Das stimmt. Und eigentlich könnte man, es ist eigentlich noch viel einfacher als im Karnevalsverein. Bei Karnevalsverein, da müsste immer einer vor Ort sein, der dann begutachtet. Bei Twitch kannst du ja einfach Twitch sagen, mach mal die API für mich auf und zeig mir, wann deine User was gemacht haben. Denn Twitch selbst beobachtet seine Nutzer natürlich auch. Du kriegst ja zum Beispiel nach 30 Minuten den ersten Hinweis im Chat von Twitch hast du schon was getrunken, du steams jetzt schon seit 30 Minuten, vergiss nicht dich zu hydrieren.
Ach so.
In der Hinsicht, ja ja, dass sie da im acht Stunden sitzen, wird da ein bisschen auf dich geschaut. Und da kann natürlich auch ein oder andere juristische Hinweis mal codiert werden. Das heißt, man wird da auch betreut. Du wirst da betreut, genau. Twitch könnte dich auch noch hinweisen, dass du ja erst 13 bist, wenn du am Donnerstag 21.30 Uhr noch streamst.
Ja, ja, das findet allerdings dann nicht statt. Was mir aufgefallen ist, sind auch ein paar ältere Sternchen wieder aufgetaucht bei Twitch. Also man sieht ja dann doch, dass manche sich von früher noch mal überlegen, kann ich noch mal eine neue Plattform nutzen, wenn der Fernsehsender mich eigentlich nicht mehr will. Kaya Yana ist dort Twitch sehr regelmäßig und, wie ich auch dort gesehen habe, ewig nicht mehr irgendwo erlebt. Erkan und Stefan, dieses Comedy-Doo, die sind auch des Öfteren bei Twitch unterwegs. Was aber viel interessanter ist, sind eigentlich diese Streamer, die diese Langzeitstrecken machen, die dann nicht gamen oder irgendwas, sondern die einfach nur zum Beispiel arbeiten. Also es gibt ja auch Livestreams bei YouTube. So gibt es, darauf wurde ich hingewiesen, James Scholz. Der hat so eine besondere Lernmethode. Der lernt 45 Minuten, macht dann 15 Minuten Faxen, beantwortet Fragen aus dem Chat und lernt dann wieder 45 Minuten und kann das acht Stunden am Tag so machen. Und so geht er so durch sein Studium. Und dem kann man dabei zusehen. Und diese Livestreams bzw. diese Videos dann am Ende haben dann 300.000 Aufrufe zum Teil. Das ist unglaublich. Oder was ich jetzt bei Twitch auch schon ein paar Mal gesehen habe, ist, dass man dort Leuten beim Schlafen zusehen kann. Auch das soll dann beruhigend sein für andere, die nicht einschlafen können. Dann sagen die, ach, da liegt schon einer im Bett. Dann lege ich mich doch auch jetzt mal hin. Wir sehen Einsamkeit. Wir haben das schon früh hier im Neuen Zwanziger Podcast gesagt, ist ein großes Thema. Und das ist sicherlich auch mit dafür verantwortlich für einen Trend bei Twitch, der jetzt in diesem Monat heiß diskutiert wurde. Und zwar geht es um die Hot Tubs. Das sind ja Planschbecken in der Regel, manchmal auch Jacuzzis. Die haben Leute in ihrem Zimmer stehen oder in ihrem Studio und die streamen aus diesen Planschbecken heraus. Und wenn ich sage Leute, dann muss ich das jetzt ein bisschen eingrenzen. Es sind in der Regel junge Frauen. Es gibt jetzt auch ein paar Männer, die im Hot Tub sitzen, aber es sind vorwiegend junge Frauen, die leicht bekleidet, das heißt also mit sehr knappen Bikinis auf irgendwelchen Gummiflamingos oder so sitzen und in diesem Hot Tub dann die ganze Zeit Chatfragen beantworten. Oder auch dann gegen eine Spende sich die Namen der User auf den Bauch, auf die Oberschenkel, wohin auch immer schreiben. Und das ist etwas, was sehr umstritten war bei Twitch, soll Twitch das länger noch zulassen. Jetzt ist es sogar so gekommen, dass man nachdem man erst mal eine Streamerin verbannte, Amurans oder so hieß die, hat man jetzt sich entschieden, okay, diese Hot Tub, die verschwinden nicht mehr und außerdem sind die auch wichtig für uns. Wir machen jetzt eine eigene Rubrik, also man kann unter Gaming, E-Sports und alles Mögliche gucken. Es gibt jetzt auch die Hot Tub Rubrik und die erfreut sich großer Beliebtheit. Und dort sitzt man in den Planschbecken. Jetzt fragt man sich, warum sitzen die in den Planschbecken? Das war eigentlich dazu da, um eine Richtlinie zu umgehen von Twitch. Und zwar hat Twitch sehr wohl in seinen Richtlinien stehen, dass man keine sexuellen Dinge zeigen darf oder keine Nacktheit zeigen darf. Es geht darum, angemessen gekleidet zu sein. Und in einem Planschbecken hat man nun mal ein Bikini oder eine Badehose an und nicht einen Anzug. Und so konnte man das Ganze umgehen. Und jetzt gibt es diese Rubrik da. Und es ist schon sehr, sehr furchtbar, bisweilen, was da passiert. Also gerade wenn es darum geht, dass zum Beispiel man sich Namen auf entsprechende Stellen des Körpers schreibt und dafür dann Leute Geld zahlen. Also man versucht hier natürlich nichts Pornografisches zu machen. Das darf man ja auch nicht. Aber was interessant ist, dass sehr viele diese Hot Top-Rubrik nutzen, um dann aufmerksam zu machen auf ihre Pay-Content-Inhalte bei OnlyFans. Oder wir haben es da auch mit Porno-Darstellern zu tun, die dann irgendwelche Pay-Geschichten verkaufen wollen und das dann auf diese Weise tun. Und diese Plattform, aber ja, Twitch, ist ja ab 13. Das heißt, also theoretisch werden auch Jüngere schon da sein, aber das ist ja jetzt keine Erwachsenen-Plattform. Insofern hören wir mal ganz kurz so einen Talk rein auf Bonniva. Und zwar unterhalten sich dort mehrere über diese Hot Top-Diskussion. Und da hören wir jetzt mal, was Hauke dazu sagt. Er ist bei den Rocket Beans gewesen und ist inzwischen in Tokio, lebt er und streamt auch, aber nicht aus dem Hot Top. Aber er sagt, wo eigentlich die Problematik für ihn darin besteht.
Also, dass man theoretisch in einen Raum, der nicht als erotisch ausgewiesen ist, Erotik bringt. In einer Zeit, in der ein Überfluss an Erotik für viele junge Menschen ein extremes Problem ist, mittlerweile ein psychisches Problem. Und das ist ein Argument, das einzige, das ich bisher gehört habe, bei dem ich dachte, okay, das kann ich verstehen. Dass jemand sagt, ich hab ein Problem mit Pornografie. Ich kann damit nicht umgehen. Und dann möchte ich auf Twitch gehen und in den Top 20 Streams sind vier Streams, die einfach einen erotischen Reiz auslösen und die sich in ihrer Präsentation zumindest extrem visuell einen Pornos annähern. So, ich sag nicht, das ist Pornografie. Ich sag nur, die Kameraeinstellung und die Beleuchtung, die erinnern dann doch stark an ein Pornoset. Also Twitch ist ja an sich eine Plattform, die jetzt nicht auf erotischem Content ausgelegt ist, sondern auch Plattform, die halt ab 13 Jahren ist. Und da kann man jetzt natürlich auch wieder sagen, ja, aber die können ja auch auf Google gehen. Aber das ist ja eine ganz andere Hemmschwelle, wenn du auf Twitch bist und halt vielleicht zufällig über so was stolperst.
Ja, aber Twitch strampelt natürlich auch. Die wollen ja auch im Konkurrenzkampf bestehen. Und lassen die User da natürlich gewähren bei so was.
Genau, das war jetzt zuletzt noch Baso, die wir gehört haben, die das auch eher kritisch sieht. Und manche sagen jetzt, ja, das ist auch ganz toll. Das ist doch Empowerment, dass man jetzt seine Sexualität ausleben kann. Na ja, also ich würde sagen, das ist schon eine sehr monetarisierte Sexualität. Und jedem sei ja das frei zugestanden, was er da machen möchte. Und ich will ja auch nicht pornografieren oder irgendwas verurteilen. Nur glaube ich, auf dieser Plattform hat es einen sehr negativen Effekt. Denn diese Zuschauer sind sehr jung und gerade diese fließenden Übergänge, also nicht diese bewusste Entscheidung, ich gehe auf eine entsprechende Plattform, sondern ich bekomme das jetzt auch noch so mit untergejubelt, finde ich hochproblematisch. Und so viel Konservatismus gönne ich mir, um das zu sagen. Und es ist mir dann auch aufgefallen bei jemanden, der auch jetzt exklusiv bei Twitch ist, nämlich Rezo. Rezo ist ja quasi von YouTube weg. Also er ist da noch, hat da auch noch mal einen Kanal. Da darf er dann nach 24 Stunden so einen Supercut machen von seinem Twitch-Stream. Da gibt es dann so 10, 15 Minuten, so ein Best-of. Aber eigentlich ist Rezo jetzt auch bei Twitch. Offenbar scheint sich das finanziell dann zu lohnen, wenn man dort ist, auch als Rezo. Wundert mich ein bisschen. Ich hätte gedacht, da kriegt man mit diesen ganzen Influencer- Werbekooperationen einfach so mehr hin, als sich dem auszusetzen, 6, 7 Stunden streamen. Na ja, aber dann sah ich ihn natürlich dort auf der Plattform und hab dann das einfach mal angeklickt. Und dann war er sich mit einer jungen Frau am Unterhalten, die ich nicht kannte, die heißt Shaden. Und die hab ich dann gegoogelt. Und es handelt sich dort dabei um eine Hardcore-Darstellerin, die aber auch so auf verschiedenen Plattformen wohl unterwegs ist und Pay-Content anbietet und so was. Und das fand ich jetzt auch dann, um noch mal konservativ zu sein, oder vielleicht ist es auch einfach vernünftig, hochproblematisch, wenn jetzt für so ein wirklich sehr junges Publikum, das Rezo ja nun mal hat, das wird ja kein 30-Jähriger gucken, wenn Rezo dann dort am späten Nachmittag sich mit einer Pornodarstellerin über zum Beispiel so etwas unterhält.
So, nächste Frage. Ich glaube, boah, ohne Scheiß, das ist eine Frage gemacht für dich. Wie gibt man einen guten Blowjob? Worauf sollte man achten? Beziehungsweise, was gefällt den Typen am besten? Ich finde, das ist schon ein guter Tipp.
Ja, es geht dann immer noch weiter so und das wird so ein bisschen ausgeblendet zu ein paar Worten, dass es für YouTube damit der Algorithmus da nicht anspringt und die Monetarisierung zum Beispiel verbietet.
Ja, das ist immer auch Rezo und viele andere. Ich meine, ihr habt das Argument Influencer in aller Tiefe gemacht. Es sind, auch wenn da viel Geld verdient wird, prekäre Lebensverhältnisse dadurch, dass man diesen Plattformen ausgeliefert ist. Wir haben ja Kevin Roos gelesen, der auch meinte, die Creator bei YouTube sind die am höchsten Maße gesteuerten Mitarbeiter, die es auf der Welt jemals gab. Denn die müssen sich einfach an dem Algorithmus orientieren und die haben gar keine Beschwerdestelle nirgendwo hin. Und einer von diesen ganzen YouTubern, die immer die ganzen technik- gra Sachen vorstellen, die ich mir dann auch immer gucke, das sind immer alles so Leute, die eigentlich auch einen ganzen Tag streamen, aber dann immer noch ihre neueste Kamera und so weiter präsentieren. Und der meinte, der ist jetzt von Twitch zu YouTube gewechselt und hat einen Einbruch von 15.000 Dollar im Monat auf 3.000 gehabt. Also Twitch scheint tatsächlich super lukrativ zu sein, wenn man das etablierte Publikum, das man hat, mitnehmen kann. Weil der Transfer von einer Plattform zur nächsten ist ja immer ein bisschen schwierig. Wenn man viele YouTube zuschaut, kann man nicht sagen, die abonnieren jetzt auch alle bei Twitch. Aber es scheint so eine Strategie zu geben, zu sagen, okay, dann nehme ich mir halt ein paar Monate und bau das auf. Und das ist hier so ein Aufbauprogramm. Also man muss dann halt in diese Richtung gehen, wo man glaubt, das ist so eine gewisse Attraktivität, die man da einfach ausbeutet, um dann Nutzerzahlen abzugreifen. Und hier sehen wir dieses Prekariat mal so richtig in solchen Ausschnitten wie von Rezo.
Ja, da geht's dann über Sex, weil man sagt, Sex selbst, das funktioniert irgendwie immer. Und wenn wir ja mal zurückdenken an Facebook, dann ist ja Zuckerberg derjenige, der als allererstes etwas ganz, ganz Simples programmierte, als er noch an der Uni war. Nämlich so ein Tool, mit dem man die Kommilitoninnen bewerten kann. Und zwar konnte man die ja nur in Hot or Not einteilen. Und dieser simple Mechanismus, der liegt eigentlich diesen Plattformen immer noch zugrunde. Denn man könnte ja tatsächlich im Livestream auch wiederum interessante Dinge machen. Also man könnte ja dann wegen mir auch sagen, hier erfährt man mal was über Landwirtschaft, was es so vielleicht im Fernsehen nicht zu sehen gibt oder so. All das ist ja möglich, genauso wie das ja auch in einem Podcast möglich ist. Aber es ist doch erstaunlich, dass man dann immer auf solche ganz, ganz billigen Mechanismen geht, um irgendwie eine Reichweite zu vergrößern. Dann nimmt man sich natürlich eine Hardcore-Darstellerin, die dann entsprechende Dinge auch dann sagt. Und dann weist man noch dreimal auf deren Videos hin, sodass die auch nochmal ihre Reichweite erhöhen kann und all das. Das ist schon sehr furchtbar und stimmt einen wieder kulturpessimistisch, wenn man sich das ansieht. Denn es ist fast nur so. Also ich habe in dem Monat, außer dass ich jetzt sage, ja, da haben ein paar Leute wahrscheinlich ein vernünftiges Fitness Workout gemacht, so wie ich das beurteilen kann, habe ich dort nichts gesehen, wo ich dachte, großartig. Also da decke ich jetzt beispielsweise im Podcast-Universum fast täglich irgendwas, wo ich sage, ach, da kann man ruhig häufiger mal reinhören.
Ja, in der Ansicht sind die Streaming-Plattformen wirklich super lame. Also wenn es Gaming nicht gäbe, gäbe es das alles nicht. Und Gaming lebt davon, dass es da manchmal so Welten gibt, in denen man sich einfach gerne wohlfühlt. Was weiß ich, irgendwelche wilden Western-Szenarien oder Los Santos und so weiter und so fort. Also wenn man das hier noch mal rundeprägt, dieses Rezo-Ding, könnte man auch wirklich sagen, Rezo ist ein Medienunternehmer, der sich um Erfolg für sich selbst zu garantieren eine Porno-Darstellerin gebucht hat, mit der er Content kreiert. Ja. Allerdings für eine Plattform Die und das ist eben das Besondere. Klar, Onlyfans gibt es jetzt auch, aber er könnte einen echten Porno weniger gut abrechnen als ein Twitch-Gesprächsporno, weil da gibt es eben die etablierten Abrechnungsmechanismen bis hin zu 5 Euro buchen und so weiter. Ich kenne jetzt keine Zahlen von Onlyfans, aber das hat ja wahrscheinlich in der Pandemie auch so ein bisschen zugelegt und hat für einen oder anderen Einkommen gesichert, das ansonsten weggefallen ist. Da muss man dann allerdings bereit sein, tatsächlich alles zu zeigen. Hier bei Twitch kann man natürlich so eine sichere Nummer schieben.
Ja, es ist auch so ein bisschen wie das Privatfernsehen in den 90ern. Dann sagt man, wir laden jetzt mal noch die Dolly Buster ein und die erzählt man, wie das dann eigentlich ist. An so einem Porno-Set, so macht man das dann hier auch. Und dann ist das alles so ein bisschen reizend und kitzeln. Und der Rest kann dann ja bei Interesse noch gebucht werden bei Onlyfans. Da verdient sie dann wieder dran, aber so haben da beide gewonnen. Man sieht aber hier sehr schön auch wie Rezo und glaube ich ganz viele dieser Twitch-Streamer bzw. dieser Content-Creators in einem Verblendungszusammenhang sich befinden. Denn es kommt eine sehr interessante Frage von der Community. Und da soll jetzt noch mal Rezo und Shaden drauf reagieren. Und das können sie eigentlich gar nicht adäquat.
Da ist ein Typ, welcher mich im Bus immer anschaut und ich ihn halt auch. Aber ich habe Angst, ihn anzusprechen, da ich mit heutigen Standards nicht mithalten, da ich halt nicht den geilen Körper habe. Oh mein Gott, wie traurig ist diese Frage denn? Was wurde denn dieser Person eingeredet, dass die glaubt, ich kann mit den heutigen Standards nicht mithalten, deswegen kann ich jetzt einen Typen im Bus nicht ansprechen. Das ist ja absurd. Das ist doch einfach absurd.
Ja, vielleicht hat da eine Person sehr früh irgendwelche Pornoideale immer wieder von Leuten wie Rezo präsentiert bekommen, dass sie an sich runterblickt und sagt, komischerweise sehe ich gar nicht so aus und kann nicht immer und will nicht immer und alles und wie kann das sein und werde ich überhaupt so jemanden ansprechen können. Das ist genau das, wie nämlich diese Medien auf einen wirken. Und da ist dann der Content Creator überfordert mit, wenn er plötzlich mal zurückgespiegelt bekommt, was eigentlich da die ganze Zeit an Idealen produziert wird. Und dass das auch eine Sache ist, die nicht einfach nur dort stattfindet, sondern die hat was mit mir selbst dann zu tun, weil ich dann sage, warum sehe ich nicht so aus?
Ja, und diese Frage an Rezo zu stellen, ist genau der richtige Adressat.
Ja, ist genau der richtige Adressat und es wird dann noch ein bisschen doller, denn es geht bei Twitch ja auch um Reaction-Videos. Also ganz viele Leute sitzen jetzt einfach da, gucken sich YouTube an und reden darüber. Nun hat ja Bibi von BibisBeautyPalace sich eine Brust- und Nasen-OP hingegeben und hat das ja alles begleitet mit der Kamera und hat dann ganz viel Auskunft gegeben, hat dann immer wieder gesagt, ich mache hier keine Werbung für Schönheitsoperationen. Haha, was natürlich eine Werbung für Schönheitsoperationen ist. Und ja, Rezo konnte es natürlich auch nicht lassen, weil er Medienunternehmer ist und die Reichweite steigern muss, sich zu Bibi zu äußern. Und dann sieht man auch, dass hier das kritische Bewusstsein relativ gering ist, denn man könnte ja durchaus mal fragen, ist das sinnvoll, in dieser Weise Schönheitsoperationen zu präsentieren? Es geht ja hier nicht um die Frage, kann nicht eine Frau für sich selbst entscheiden, sich operieren zu lassen. Die Frage brauchen wir gar nicht stellen. Ja, selbstverständlich, wir leben in einer freien Gesellschaft, kann jeder machen, was er will. Aber die Frage ist ja, was präsentiere ich und was sage ich, was mache ich jetzt schmackhaft meiner Community? Und Bibi macht natürlich genau das, dass sie sagt, das ist eigentlich toll, hier so eine Operation zu machen und zeigt dann jetzt mal hier erste Erfolge und Rezo reagiert darauf.
Aber gerade hier im Bereich von Jochbein, das ist doch echt noch sehr anstrengend. Meine Nase ist mega krass zu. Ich kann es halt nicht hochziehen, nicht durch die Nase atmen.
Und das ist echt sehr krass.
Und heute um 17.30 Uhr...
Alter, das sieht so schmerzhaft aus, das sieht so anstrengend aus. Das sieht so krass aus.
Mega geil. Was mich sehr glücklich macht.
Ey, das ist super, das freut mich sehr, dass das so gut gelaufen ist. Einfach sweet, Leute. Einfach sweet. Ey, aber das ist doch ein Update jetzt gewesen für die Situation mit der Brustvergrößerung und der Nasen-OP. Auf jeden Fall strong.
Ja, da fehlt ja nur noch, dass er ein Rating abgibt, was jetzt 7 von 10 oder 9 von 10 strong ist. Das ist natürlich, das finde ich immer wieder beeindruckend, das sieht man bei YouTube auch ganz oft, dieses sozialkonforme Antworten. Sie hat was an ihren Brüsten machen lassen. Wir sagen nichts Negatives über Körper. Deswegen ist natürlich klar, dass wir das super cool finden. Wir finden da keine Worte für. Also es ist fünfmal sweet, genau wie sie über ihren eigenen Körper. Wär krass, wenn sie jetzt bei YouTube sagen, das war eine Fehlinvestition. Scheiße. Geht natürlich auch nicht. Sondern in der Ansicht ist es völlig erwartbar, was da abläuft. Und man fragt sich nur noch, wie wird es ausformuliert? Und da ist, da können wir jetzt einfach ästhetisch sagen, Rezo ist nicht besonders gut in der Lage, über irgendwas einen Werturteil zu sprechen, oder?
Ja, bzw. hat natürlich eine große Angst, sich dazu zu äußern, weil er diese Bewertung eigentlich nicht vornehmen darf. Ich bekam auch einen Ärger auf Twitter, dass ich für Deutschlandradio ein Interview gegeben habe über diese Operationen. Und dann hat sich aber niemand offenbar von diesen Leuten das Interview angehört. Denn weder ging es dem Moderator noch mir darum, zu bewerten, ob das sinnvoll ist, sich operieren zu lassen, oder wie die Operation geworden ist. Sondern es ging allein darum, zu fragen, welchen Mechanismus legt das eigentlich bloß, was die Plattform anbelangt, beziehungsweise welche Wirkung wird das auf die Follower haben, wenn dort jemand so sehr von den Schönheitsoperationen berichtet und das so sehr in den Mittelpunkt stellt und auch immer von Nasenkorrektur spricht. Was ja schon impliziert, dass etwas nicht korrekt ist, was also erst mal korrekt gemacht werden muss, wo dann jeder selbst sagen kann, oh Gott, sind eigentlich meine Beine korrekt, ist mein Busen korrekt, diese Fragen. Aber das wurde gleich so unter dieser Rubrik, Mann spricht über Frauenkörper, dann gefrankt und dann regen sich Leute auf. Und da muss man sagen, dann dürfte es auch keine Männer mehr geben, die Brüste operieren. Das gibt es ja auch. Also das ist ja nun alles vollkommener Unsinn. Also man kann über alles abstrakt reden.
Genau, es ist auch, man darf es auch nicht zu verlogen erwarten in den Medien, also wenn so eine Kritik kommt. Denn wie Menschen im Fernsehen aussehen, passiert nicht einfach so. Sondern da machen sich Menschen aus Verlagen, aus Redaktionen, aus Agenturen Gedanken. So und wenn Bibi eine Brust-OP macht, das ist wie bei ihrer Schwangerschaft, dann kommt ihre Agentur zu ihr und sagt, dein Marktwert ist und wir können ihn durch die Schwangerschaft um 30 Prozent steigern. Und jetzt kannst du überlegen, wie weit bist du denn bereit? Und ich vermute, dass es sogar so weit geht, dass die Agenturen dafür Vorschüsse zahlen. Also dass sie gar nicht abwarten, wie tatsächlich der Markt dann aussieht für eine schwangere Bibi, sondern dass sie ihr das auch sozusagen um da, ne?
Ist wirklich.
Es ist halt wie Bücher schreiben, man kriegt halt so einen Vorschuss. Wenn du schwanger bist, wir zahlen ja hier so und so viel, weil, ne, und dann geht das Risiko auf uns über, aber die wissen natürlich, dass steigert die Attraktivität. Der Frauen-Mutter-Markt ist ja riesig. Unsicherheit ist ja heute durch die wenigen Kinder und so weiter so groß. Alle Kinder sind im Grunde immer die ersten Kinder. Man hat selber noch keine Erfahrung. Beim zweiten Kind ist ja alles total entspannt, aber beim ersten Kind. Und wenn du so ein junges Publikum hast, hast du eigentlich ein Publikum immer Frauen, die das erste Kind erwarten und die greifen dann überall zu, bei jedem medialen Angebot, das sich bietet, um irgendwie Orientierung zu schaffen. Und das steigert natürlich Marktwerte. Und in deren Sicht wird das kalt durchkalkuliert und das darf man dann auch ruhig mal vor Publikum als Analyse machen.
Ja, aber selbstverständlich. Also dann brauch ich ja gar nichts mehr machen, überhaupt kulturell. Also dann kann ich immer nur noch sagen, dann lassen wir die Leute selbst zu Wort kommen und dass das alles nicht ohne Kalkül entsteht und dass das sind alles Leute, die das sehr bewusst in die Öffentlichkeit zerren. Das ist ja nicht, dass da irgendjemand erwischt wurde vor einer OP oder so, dass da jemand an der Kliniken Paparazzi aufgestellt hatte, sondern das ist einfach so, dass das alles mit eingepreist ist. Na ja, wir haben es hier mit Reaction also zu tun, mit einem Reaction-Video und das ist ein ganz großes Genre da. Ich musste aber auch daran denken, vielleicht leben wir auch in einer extrem langweiligen Zeit, in der nur noch so geremixed und kommentiert wird. Ich habe etwas gefunden und zwar ging doch ein bisschen viral diese Ankündigung, da gibt es etwas im Berliner Dom, das ist so eine Reihe mit Literatur. Und als Jan-Josef Liefers sich ja da merkwürdig äußerte zur Corona-Politik, alles dicht machen und so, da wurde das immer eingeblendet, dieser Screenshot. Und zwar ist er auch im Oktober dort. Und dann steht hier einfach, Jan-Josef Liefers liest einen Überraschungstext. Und dann gab es natürlich da gleich bei Twitter und so solche Scherze, ja welchen Text könnte er einander lesen? Kann man sich ja vorstellen. Okay, aber was für mich viel verrückter noch war, war eine Veranstaltung, die wohl vorgestern stattgefunden hat, beziehungsweise stand so auf dem Plakat. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist es ausgefallen wegen Corona. Jedenfalls war für den 29.5. im Berliner Dom folgende Veranstaltung angesetzt. Giovanni di Lorenzo und Iris Berben lesen aus eigens für die Zeit geführten Interviews. Das ist die Veranstaltung. Wie verzweifelt muss man sein, um sich das zu geben, dafür Tickets zu buchen? Und wie irre und selbst überzeugt kann man eigentlich sein, wenn man sagt, gut, wir re-enacten jetzt unsere eigenen Interviews. Ich hab mir überlegt, wäre das die Tournee für 2022 für uns beiden? Wir re-enacten den Podcast von 2020 oder so.
Wir spielen immer ein Jahr vorher den Podcast nach. Als wäre noch Corona. Noch mal das Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl erwärmen.
Irgendwie sowas, ja. Ich kann auch noch mal so ganz... Wir bleiben zu Hause. Ja, vielleicht das noch mal. Es ist wahnsinnig, von daher darf man sich vielleicht nicht wundern, wenn man dann auch erleben kann, wie die YouTuber jetzt schon auf ihre eigene Geschichte reagieren. Also Lagerfeld war ja immer jemand, der sagte, interessiert mich nicht, was ich gemacht habe. Ich lebe jetzt, ich muss an die nächste Kollektion denken. Erinnern Sie mich nicht daran, ob da in den 70er Jahren so und so die Kleider getragen wurde. Ich bin kein Museum. Und damit meinte natürlich immer, ich bin nicht wie Yves Saint Laurent, weil der ja irgendwann nur noch Montreal wurde. Aber hier bei Twitch ist auch schon das Museum angekommen. Rezo und Julien Bam noch mal ganz kurz.
Ich habe mir gedacht, wir sollten doch mal auf alte Videos reagieren. Das heißt, was wir jetzt machen, ist, dass wir reagieren auf alte Videos von dir und mir, die wir zusammengemacht haben und erzählen dazu ein paar Sachen. Wir können so ein paar funny Stories erzählen. Wir können ein bisschen sagen, wie peinlich das ist, weißt du so. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Video, das haben wir zu zweit gemacht. Da haben wir How It Is von Bibi in verschiedenen Styles gemacht.
Ja, das nennt man den Infinite Loop. Und wenn man nicht aufpasst, verstreckt man sich da drin. Passiert vielen alten Leuten, die bei REWA noch mal die Zeitschrift kaufen, was vor 50 Jahren im Fernsehen kam.
Ganz genau. Ja, die gibt es ja, diese Nostalgie-Klatschblätter jetzt. Und das war ja auch schon die Reaktion auf etwas. Also dieses Video, auf das sie da Bezug nehmen, war schon ein Reaction-Video bzw. eine Variation von einem Bibivideo. Es ist absurd. Zum Schluss noch ein Punkt, den wir vielleicht auch ein bisschen unterbelichtet haben, noch so in der Öffentlichkeit. Wir waren uns vor vier, fünf Jahren sehr einig, wie wichtig YouTube ist für die Politik. Und wie sehr die Verschwörungstheoretiker sich dort verbreiten, das wissen wir auch. Aber mir ist dann was Interessantes aufgefallen. Ich klickte mich so durch. Es gibt dann auch diese Rubrik, wo einfach Leute so ein bisschen talken, dann sagen die ja, wenn sie irgendwas besonders ernst meinen, immer Real Talk. Und ich sah dort irgendjemand aus Bayern, ein Mann, ich würde sagen so Ende 30, der saß da, war am Frühstücken, erzählte so ein bisschen aus der Weltgeschichte und wurde dann plötzlich im Chat gefragt, was er denn eigentlich von den Grünen hält und sagt er, ah nee, also Grünen, lasst mir da mal mit. Also wir haben die ja hier auch im Stadtrat sitzen. Also ich kann euch sagen, das ist nicht zu empfehlen. Also passt da ja auf. Also kann ich euch nur sagen, mehr sagt er gar nicht. Aber das waren immer so, nee, nee, also passt mir ja auf mit den Grünen. Und das fand ich interessant, weil das einfach so so beiläufig wurde da mal gerade politisch agitiert. Und dann ging das wieder mit anderen weiter. Und es war aber auch im Chat dann so eine Einigkeit da. Also irgendwie war das so eine Community, so sagte. Nee, also die Grünen wählen wir niemals. Dann hat Montana Black sich, der ja auch ein sehr, sehr erfolgreicher Streamer ist. Montana Black hat sich zu den Grünen mehrmals wohl schon geäußert. Tat das aber jetzt auch noch mal vor einigen Tagen. Und da muss ich sagen, das ist schon ganz erstaunlich. Wie einflussreich vielleicht dann doch Twitch sein könnte. Denn Montana Black, das ist jetzt was, das gucken 10.000 auf Twitch. Und dann gibt es gerade von sowas dann nochmal bei YouTube Videos, die dann durchaus Millionen Aufrufe haben. Und wir haben über die Zerstörung der CDU viel geredet. Und das war ein Video. Aber wie viel passiert da eigentlich laufend, was in eine politische Richtung geht und vielleicht in eine doch eher problematische, wie jetzt hier dieser Ausschnitt zeigt?
Die Grünen wollen überall 130 Maximum machen. Das Einzige, was die Grünen machen, ist gefühlt dauerhaft Scheiße laden. Wer die Grünen wählt, hat den Bezug zu Realität verloren. Punkt. Ich sag euch nicht, was ihr wählen sollt. Aber wenn ihr euch ein bisschen mit der Thematik auseinandersetzt, wählt nicht die Grünen. Okay? Ich würde jetzt noch so vieles so gerne sagen, aber es würde wahrscheinlich darauf hinauslaufen, dass ich eine Anzeige bekomme. Oder ein Bann. Deswegen halte ich mich ein bisschen zurück. Aber wollen wir es mal so sagen, die sehen nicht alle so glücklich aus, die ich da sehe, die da arbeiten. Die sehen alle recht sexuell unzufrieden aus, mit ihrem Leben selber nicht so zufrieden und wollen das, was uns Spaß macht, nehmen.
Ja, wenn ich sowas höre, denke ich mir immer, bei welcher Agentur knallen gerade die Korken? Das ist ja dieses typische Inception. Wir haben es jetzt auch schon wieder bei Biontech, dass irgendwelche Streamer so eine E-Mail bekommen. Könntest du mal das und das über Biontech sagen? Da sind ja sehr viele Leute gestorben. Die einen labern das dann einfach nach, die anderen gucken mal in die Statistik. Ah ja, stimmt, da sind echt viele gestorben. Aber die Lebenserwartung von 102-Jährigen ist halt auch nicht länger als ein Jahr. Und die erste Biontech-Impfung ist halt schon eine Weile her. Da sterben halt auch Leute. Also in deren Sicht ist das immer so ein... Aber hier vermute ich immer, bei so großen Streamern, glaube ich sowieso, dass sie unter Dauerbombade, was sie selber nicht richtig mitbekommen, von Agitationen sind.
Meinst du, das wäre hier der Fall? Aber ich glaube, wir haben hier einfach jemanden, der extrem viel Geld verdient hat. Und dieses Geld auch vor allem in schnellen Autos dann nochmal haben möchte. Und das ist dann jemand, der sagt, naja, wie, die wollen 130? Die haben sie ja nicht mehr. Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob du da noch eine Agentur brauchst dahinter. Ich glaube, die sind schon ideologisch auf Linie.
Nee, würde mir ja schon reichen für die Bestätigung meines Arguments, wenn irgendwann vor einem Jahr oder so jemand dachte, ey, können wir nicht Montana Black hier einfach so des und des Auto mal testweise zur Verfügung stellen? Dann gewinnt er da so richtig Freude dran und so weiter. Und dann ein Jahr später hat das Effekte hinsichtlich, ach so, die Grünen wollen jetzt das schon wieder. Nee, wählt die nicht und so.
Ach so, meinst du das?
Dass sich das so aufschaukelt. Also das ist wirklich unter dem Radar ohne Abrechnung einfach Inception stattfindet.
Und das ist aber so ein Lifestyle, der bei Twitch sehr gepflegt wird, bei den Influencer natürlich auch. Aber dass man dann diese Leute sieht, dass die auch mit dem Privatjet durch die Gegend fliegen. Habe ich gesehen bei Bibi. Bei Bibi, ich glaube bei Knossi auch kürzlich, wo ich dachte, das ist ja erstaunlich, dass das also von der Community so gut aufgenommen wird. Und da sehe ich ein sehr großes, junges Potenzial, das mit Klimawandel nichts am Hut haben will. Das dann einfach sagt, wir wollen hier konsumieren und die wollen uns unseren Spaß nehmen. Und diese ganzen Follower, die werden natürlich selten in Autofahren überhaupt mal ordentlich PS hat. Aber dennoch sagen die, aber die wollen den Montana Black das Auto wegnehmen.
Das geht ja nicht. Ja, da laufen irgendwelche Kämpfe im Untergrund, die man nicht so genau weiß.
Ja, muss man im Auge behalten.
Wir reden gleich noch über Google und machen aber einen kleinen Brückenschlag, denn mir ist was aufgefallen bei YouTube. Und zwar gucken wir jetzt mehrere Videos, die alle den gleichen Tenor haben. Die sind noch alle recht kurz. Das sind natürlich längere Videos, aber den einen Satz, den alle gleich haben, den tu ich raus. Und da wir uns eben schon imprägniert haben, hinsichtlich, wir dürfen durchaus auch über Körper und so weiter sprechen, wir hören jetzt sehr viele Leute, die sagen, dass sie keine Freunde haben und irgendwie darunter leiden. Und Wolfgang und ich, wir können die aber sehen. Es ist im Grunde die erste YouTube-Suchergebnisseite, wenn man einfach nach No Friends sucht. Also einfach wirklich No Friends. Und ich möchte gern anfügen, das sind alles sehr, sehr attraktive Leute. Also wir haben es hier nicht mit irgendwelchen, ah ja klar, der hat keine Freunde, sondern es ist anders gelagert. Und die Arbeitshypothese, also wir hören uns das erst mal an und dann hätte ich so eine Frage einfach an dich, Wolfgang, und an alle anderen, denn das beschäftigt mich so ein bisschen für die Rentenrepublik, bei der es mir ja sehr um Gemütszustände geht. Und Gemütszustände sind immer abgekoppelt, manchmal so ein bisschen von Realität. Beispielsweise durch mediale Verblendung, wie wir es vorhin im Fernsehen gesehen haben, dass man in den 70ern sich gar nicht über die Realität informieren konnte, sondern nur ein Fernsehbild bekam, das irgendwas Artifizielles zeigt, so wie wir das jetzt auch schon wieder bei Twitch und so weiter sehen. Denk an sich, gehen wir mal diese kleine Liste durch. Ja, sie weiß gar nicht so richtig, sie ist erst mal über ein Video gestolpert, dass sie gucken muss, und dann ach so, man kann gar keine Freunde haben und das ist ein Zustand, über den man sprechen kann, ja dann mach ich das mal, aber ich habe ja auch keine Freunde. Es fiel ihr dann so auf irgendwie. Beispiel Nummer zwei.
Du kannst so viele Dinge selbst machen.
Ja, sie redet sich das schon schön. Kommt sie also ein bisschen tiefer, aber sie hat sich auch vorgestellt mit.
An einem tollen See, sie weiß das Leben zu genießen, auch ohne Freunde.
Das ist schon so ein Kandidat, der rennt mit einem Gymshark-T-Shirt hier vor sein YouTube-Video, hat auch entsprechend Bizeps, absolut astrein gestylt. Könntest du sofort in den Otto-Katalog stellen, kann ja alles verkaufen.
Scheint aber den Sportern immer allein zu machen. Ich hab keinen Sportkumpel.
Und beklagt hier, er hat zwar eine tolle Familie, aber no friends. Ja, so kann man das natürlich auch sehen. Er ist ein toller Ingenieur, der schon bei Google und überall gearbeitet hat und glaubt, er ist halt einsame Spitze, also Spitze, aber eben einsam, so wie es ist. Naja, das ist auch einsam, also das Genie, dass es den einsamen Weg geht. Genau, der hat mit diesem Video auch über eine Million Views gesammelt. Jetzt schwenken wir kurz um zu einem Ted X Talk, denn es hat tatsächlich schon Kreise gezogen. Eine junge Frau steht auf der Bühne.
Wenn ich um 22 Jahre alt wäre, würde es Wochen dauern, bevor jemand es bemerkt.
Ja, sie hat sich selber rausgezogen, sagt sie hier. Also für sie ist das so ein gewähltes Schicksal. Dann hat sie festgestellt, es ist gar nicht so gut. Wenn ich mit 22 Jahren gestorben werde, würde es über Wochen keiner mitbekommen, sagt sie. Ich bin 25 und habe keine Freunde.
Ich bin 21 und habe keine Freunde. Und ich werde nur darauf achten, warum das so ist.
Hey Leute und willkommen zurück auf meinen Kanal.
Und der Grund warum ich diese Videos bringe, ist, weil ich einen Lack.
Also das sind jetzt alles Leute, die auch wahnsinnig gut gestylt vor der Kamera sind. Also die wissen auch genau wie es funktioniert. Also die sprechen auch entsprechend mit der Kamera, kokettieren ein bisschen mit der Kamera, spielen mit ihr. Das sind also jetzt keine Leute, bei denen man sagt, oh das sind Menschen, die eigentlich auch immer nur ihre Fußspitzen sehen, die nicht in der Lage sind jemanden anzusprechen oder die in irgendeiner Weise groß verschüchtert sind. So wirken die alle nicht.
Ja, um an diesen Resupunkt anzuknüpfen. Die gucken nicht an sich runter und denken, ich halte hier nicht mit oder so. Sondern ich habe halt einfach keine Freunde, sagen die. Und die fragen sich warum.
Also, das ist das vierte Mal, dass ich dieses Video ausprobieren wollte. Und wenn ich es mache, dann tut mir leid.
Mhm, noch so einen.
So, sie hat das.
Ich frag mich, haben die jetzt wirklich alle keine Freunde? So wie die eine bei dem TEDx Talk, die sagt, wenn ich jetzt sterben würde, würde das über Wochen niemand mitbekommen. Oder hängen die so einem Traum, so einem Wunsch hinterher, der aber eigentlich in Erfüllung geht, weil einfach Maßstäbe verloren gegangen sind?
Aber bei der von dem TED Talk würdest du schon auch sagen, das ist eine Person, die unter Einsamkeit gelitten hat. Also darunter gelitten hat, keine Freunde zu haben. Und hier bist du eher einem Trend auf der Spur.
Ja, ich bin so ein bisschen skeptisch, was sie sagen. Denn dieses Gefühl, keine Freunde zu haben, kann ja zwei Ursachen haben. Entweder man hat wirklich keine, also niemanden in der Nähe, mit dem man mal einen Austausch machen kann. Oder man hat so eine Idee von Freundschaft. Und wir kennen das aus der Liebe. Wo kommt die Idee von Liebe her? Natürlich aus Romanien und aus den Filmen. Und das sind natürlich immer alles idealtypische, stereotypische Darstellungen. Außer so ein Film bricht dann mal so richtig raus. Wo man weiß, naja, das findet halt im Film so statt. Aber wenn man dem jetzt hinterherfährt, dann hat man nie eine glückliche Ehe. So irgendwie, ne? Und das ist ja bei Freundschaft dann ganz genauso. Welche Ideen von Freundschaft herstellen hier mittlerweile vor? Was wird uns denn vorgegaukelt für den Maßstab Freundschaft? Wenn wir Rezo und Julien Bam sehen, wie sie da richtig Halli Galli Gaudi und so weiter, obwohl wir wissen, die haben da einen ganzen Tag gefilmt und haben dann 13 Minuten daraus rausgeschnitten, ihre eigenen Highlights. Das ist jetzt Freundschaft. Also daran angedings, oder reicht es nicht, so ein aktives Vereinsleben zu haben und zu sagen, seh ich zwar nur einmal die Woche und dann geht es auch immer nur um das und das, aber das sind ja dann trotzdem Menschen, die einem irgendwie nah sind. Auch wenn man nicht sagen würde, das ist jetzt ein Freund oder so, aber führt trotzdem jetzt auch biologisch genau zu diesen Körperreaktionen, die eine Freundschaft auch nicht besser ausbilden kann. Also in der Ansicht glaube ich, sind hier auch ein paar Maßstäbe verloren gegangen, was wieder mal auch zu diesem Argument oder Hinweis führt, wir sollten jetzt doch darauf achten, dass die Medien mal wieder den Moment einfangen und nicht ihren eigenen kreieren. Also dass es da wieder diese Kluft mal ein bisschen zu nähern gilt.
Doch sprachen wir ja eben von Vereinzelung und wir können diese Individualisierung nicht nur in den Familien ablesen, sondern sicherlich auch daran, wie jetzt das Leben sich gestalten lässt, wenn man zum Beispiel mobil und flexibel sein muss, wenn man auch oft den Ort wechselt. Also nicht mehr in dem Dorf immer bleibt, in dem man groß geworden ist, wo man auch erstmal Freundschaften geschlossen hat, sondern man geht auch nicht in die nächste Stadt und bleibt dann dort, sondern man ist in sehr vielen Städten unterwegs, ist wieder in neuen beruflichen Umfeldern. Und auch die Leute, an die man sich gewöhnt hat, die sind dann auch wieder weg. Das heißt, das ist ja auch sehr schwer, dann Freundschaften herzustellen, die halten, wenn man sagt, eine Freundschaft muss auch mal direkte Begegnung bedeuten, kann nicht nur sein, dass man sich Nachrichten schreibt oder dass man miteinander telefoniert. Ich glaube, dass das auch eine große Schwierigkeit ist, wenngleich eigentlich jetzt meines Erachtens die große Zeit der Freundschaft ist, weil die Familien nicht mehr diese Wichtigkeit haben und wir uns auch nicht mehr so verbunden fühlen. Also wir sind ja sehr viele Freunde, viel näher als die meisten meiner Verwandten. Also da ist ja Onkeltante, das so spielen so gut wie keine Rolle. Da sind selbst irgendwelche Bekannten, die ich regelmäßig treffe mir wichtiger oder die wissen mehr von mir, als das einen Onkel oder eine Tante tut. Und von daher glaube ich eigentlich ist dieses Konzept der Wahlverwandtschaft, das ist ja dieser schöne Roman von Goethe, der nicht gut ausgeht, aber ich finde, man kann ihn auch gut ausgehen lassen, dass dieses Konzept der Wahlverwandtschaft eigentlich das ist, was in unsere Zeit heute sehr gut passt, was ich auch bei mir selbst sehen kann. Bei mir sind oft auch Freundschaften sehr stark über das Telefon gepflegt, weil das Leute sind, die weiter weg wohnen und gerade jetzt auch während der Pandemie war das Treffen nicht so gut möglich. Aber auch sonst ist das nicht wöchentlich möglich. Und das wird dann über das Telefon, ich will nicht sagen aufrechterhalten, sondern wirklich gepflegt und gelebt. Aber ich glaube generell ist eigentlich jetzt eine ganz gute Zeit, um solche Freundschaftskonstellationen zu haben, die eine Verlässlichkeit haben, die einen Austausch gewähren. Ich glaube, was hier vielleicht ein bisschen von den Leuten suggeriert wird, ist, ich habe eher den Eindruck, die suchen einen Lebenspartner. Also die suchen nicht eine Freundin oder einen Freund, also die wollen heiraten, haben aber da noch niemanden gefunden. Und was sie vielleicht erkennen müssten wäre, dass es nicht in der Freundschaft nur geht, dass man sich so gegenseitig spiegelt und toll findet oder so, dass man nicht diese merkwürdigen Symptom-Interaktionen hat. Also das brauche ich eigentlich nicht, da brauche ich keine Freunde, dann kann ich mir Twitch ansehen. Sondern man muss eigentlich, wenn eine Freundschaft sinnvoll sein soll, sie auf etwas Trittes auslegen. Das kann, wie du jetzt das gerade sagtest, Sport sein. Dass man sagt, wir machen gemeinsam gerne Sport, dann haben wir da was Trittes. Das wäre jetzt bei mir eher, wir gehen ins Museum, wir gehen ins Konzert, wir diskutieren über etwas. Also dann ist dieses, wir verabschieden uns jetzt aus unseren eigenen Blasen und versuchen uns zu öffnen für was Trittes. Das ist eigentlich das, was Freundschaft ausmacht. Und da habe ich hier bei diesen Leuten, die sehr, sehr selbstverliebt sind, meine Zweifel, ob sie sich auf was Trittes ausrichten wollen und ob sie dann auch in der Lage sind, da eine Freundschaft überhaupt in Gang kommen zu lassen.
Genau, diese Selbstverliebtheit hast du da ein bisschen untergemogelt jetzt. Denn das können wir ja nicht wirklich draus ablesen. Allerdings, wir sehen die Wahl des Mediums. Deswegen würde ich das auch unterstellen. Es ist nicht normal, auch heute nicht, dass Menschen sich selber filmen und irgendwas über sich erzählen. Es gibt aber ein paar, die machen das ganz virtuos. Einer davon ist Lana Blakely. Und bevor ich das Argument von dir noch mal aufgreife, dass die eigentlich was Tieferes suchen, aber dann nicht Freundschaften, sondern dann im Singular in Beziehung zu einer Person, der sie dann auch sozusagen sich anders zeigen als wahllos anderen, spontanen oder häufigeren Bekanntschaften. Oder der Begriff für dieses, sich wieder sichtbar werden, in einem Raum sein, dieses raumgebundene, auch wenn du es jetzt übers Telefon, da würde ich das auch noch mit einklammern, aber im Grunde so dieses sich einander aussetzen und so. Lana Blakely hat auch so ein Video gemacht, das hören wir aber nicht, beziehungsweise nicht den Ausschnitt, wo sie sagt, ich habe keine Freunde und so weiter, sondern sie redet hier mal über Social Media, weil wir danach noch mal über Dating Apps im Speziellen kurz sprechen. Aber sie ist so eine junge Schwedin, sitzt einfach da und macht in diesem Stil, wie wir es jetzt hören, Videos, die immer so zehn Minuten gehen und eigentlich immer so ein tristessmelancholisches Thema haben. Also ganz merkwürdig. Ich würde sagen, es ist eine Kunstform an sich. Man muss hier nicht zu tief reingehen und eine Persönlichkeit darin vermuten, aber wie sie über Social Media spricht, finde ich ganz gut. Ja, it never ends. Also diese Belanglosigkeit von Social Media, glaube ich, wäre so meine Arbeitshypothese, überformt den Freundschaftsbegriff, der tatsächlich auf rauf raum gebunden ist, sichtbare, nahe Personen, mit denen man aus welchen Gründen auch immer Zeit verbringt. Also dadurch, dass das eine so gestört ist, hat das irgendwie Effekte auf die andere Seite. Und ich meine...
Doomscrawlen ist ja jetzt der Begriff dafür. Da gibt es ja einen Artikel jetzt auch bei Jacobean dazu.
Ja, das ist das Phänomen dahinter, genau. Es ist diese endlose Belanglosigkeit, der Infinite Scroll sozusagen, und das erste, was Menschen, die aus psychologischen, gesundheitlichen Gründen eingewiesen werden oder sich selber einweisen, dass die allererste Maßnahme ist heute flächendeckend, Handy weg. Ah ja, es wird reglementiert, gerade bei Kindern und Jugendlichen. 15 Minuten am Tag kriegt man sein Smartphone. Die restlichen 23 Stunden, 45 Minuten ist man bitte mit sich beschäftigt über andere Medien, wenn man sich an die Welt andockt, als das eigene Smartphone. Und allein das scheint schon enorme Effekte zu haben. Und in deren Sicht scheint es hier dann tatsächlich so Niederschlag zu geben, dass es jetzt plötzlich so eine No-Friends-Welle auf YouTube und so weiter gibt, wo sich alle darin bestärken, eigentlich keine Freunde zu haben, obwohl ich die Vermutung habe, dass sie eigentlich doch, wenn sie sich noch drauf einlassen würden, ausreichend soziales Umfeld haben für ein gesundes Beisammensein.
Doch Stefan, sag mir mal, warum sehe ich jetzt hier schon das zweite Video mit jemand, der eine Kaffeetasse in der Hand hat? Neben war schon eine da, dann gibt es sie jetzt hier, die ganz virtuos eine Kaffeetasse in der Hand hält. Und dann denke ich an die Videos von MyTea, die immer eine T-Tasse in der Hand hält. Ist das so etwas, was man jetzt bei YouTube machen muss? Muss ich jetzt auch mir eine Tasse hinstellen für die nächste Filmanalys? Was schlägst du vor?
Warum gibt es Cocktailspartys? Was ist die Funktion einer Cocktailparty? Oder eines Stehempfangs?
Der Stehempfang ist ja dazu da, dass man miteinander ins Gespräch kommt. Nein, der Stehempfang habe ich bei Margaret Dünser gelernt, kommt eigentlich daher, dass das irgendein Bankettwahlköniglich ist und es waren aber nicht genug Plätze da. Und dann hat man eine gewisse Schicht beziehungsweise Adelsklasse, die musste stehen und die Worte wurde da positioniert. Und dann wurde das aber irgendwann schick zu stehen. Und so ist das Ganze ins Leben gekommen. Aber meinst du, das hat hier diese Funktion. Also ich sehe ja jetzt hier Leute sitzen mit einer Kaffeetasse oder Tee-Tasse dort, trinken in der Regel auch nicht, sondern rühren höchstens mal um. Aber was wollen sie mir jetzt damit signalisieren? Holt ihr auch eine? Ich glaube, MyTea fordert auch immer auf, nehmt euch erstmal einen Tee.
Also der Stehempfang hat eine ganz wichtige Funktion. Erhält die Leute mobil, während sie gleichzeitig in Gesprächen miteinander kommen können, aber nicht gebunden werden, wie wenn sie am Tisch säßen. Auf einer Tischordnung. Denn das Aufstehen und Gehen, das ist doch ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, deutlicher konnotiert als einfach nur ah und so. Und dann ist man plötzlich so weggedreht, ja.
Ja genau.
Die kalte Schulter gezeigt. So man will also stehen mobil sein und trotzdem im Gespräch, aber nicht zu eng gebunden. Und das Problem ist, wenn man nicht am Tisch sitzt, was macht man mit seinen Händen? Man braucht was für seine Hände, also gibt man ein Getränk. Und an dem kann man sich festhalten, wenn es brenzlig wird. Und genau das machen die hier auch. Die haben ihr Tesschen in der Hand, damit sie mit den Händen dir zeigen, ich muss jetzt hier nicht gestikulieren oder so, sondern alle fühlt sich gut aufgehoben. Sie fühlt sich auch gut aufgehoben. Sie weiß genau, was sie macht mit ihrer Hand, mit ihren Füßen. Das ist einfach eine Person, die nicht in einer prekären Lage ist, die dich also nicht herausfordert, jetzt taktvolles Verhalten zeigen zu müssen. Taktvoll im Sinne von die Schwächen des anderen ausgleichen durch indirekte Kommunikation, ist schon gut und so weiter. Das kommt schnell auf, wenn Menschen so anfangen zu gestikulieren. Die wissen dann nicht wohin mit ihren Händen. Danny hat das mal ganz toll in seinem Podcast erklärt. Er hat mal so einen Fotoworkshop gemacht für Leute, die auf einer Preisverleihung oder so mit auf einem Foto auftauchen müssen. Aber die Situation ansonsten nicht kennen. Wie verhält man sich da eigentlich? Und das muss man vorher üben und dann muss man Skript abspielen. Und dann darf man nicht anfangen, in dem Moment, wo die Vorderberater schon anfangen, loszuschießen, dann plötzlich die Hände doch in die Tasche, doch nicht, vorm Bauch oder nicht. Sondern die Pose muss man kennen. Und das begegnet mir hier immer wieder. Das ist einfach, daran erkennt man Professionalität. Sie bringt das kleine Gimmick mit rein, ohne dass es stört, sondern es beruhigt beim Zuschauen.
Genau, es wird aber noch gleichzeitig so getan, als sei das so was, man hat die Kamera angemacht und trinkt noch einen Tee. Was natürlich jeder weiß, dass das falsch ist. Man weiß ja auch, wenn jetzt, ich weiß nicht, wie lange MyTea dreht, aber da wird der Tee siebenmal kalt sein. Also sie suggeriert damit so eine Alltäglichkeit, die natürlich überhaupt nicht gegeben ist. Mir wäre ja alles sympathischer, wenn mal wieder in den Videos geraucht würde. Da kann man sich ja auch schön dran festhalten an der Zigarette. Aber warum passiert das nicht mehr? Das wissen wir. Da sind glaube ich auch die Algorithmen mittlerweile davor. Da wird man glaube ich schlechter gerenkt.
Genau. Paul, unser Paul, der gerade in Reutlingen auf der Reportageschule ist, hat jetzt auch dort einen Reutcast und habe ich gestern gehört Adepia zu Gast, eine Mitschülerin, die auch davon berichtete, ich wusste immer nicht wohin mit mir in der Pause. Sie reden über Pause, Pause, die Bedeutung von Pause. Und dann habe ich angefangen zu rauchen. Plötzlich war die Sache klar, es ist Pause, also gehe ich raus und rauche. Und dann stehen da noch andere Raucher und mit denen rede ich dann. Und plötzlich war das ganze Ding geregelt. Wichtige Funktion auch der Salutierungsordnung im Militär. Wer salutiert eigentlich wem? Üblicherweise geht man über den Campus und fragt sich, in drei Sekunden begegne ich beim Vorgesetzten. Was mache ich, was mache ich? Ist natürlich klar, was du machst. Du salutierst und damit ist Ruhe und Frieden auf dem Campus. Und alle wissen, was zu tun ist. Naja, wenn man sich allerdings in soziales Präkariat begibt, weil man beispielsweise, und dann kann man sich nicht einfach auf eine Tasse zurückziehen oder auf eine Zigarette, jemanden kennenlernen möchte, für tiefere Gedankengänge.
Dann gibt es das große Problem der Peinlichkeit. Das ist ja das Lebensthema von Thomas Mann. Es ist alles so entsetzlich peinlich.
Genau, die Grundlage der Erotik, sich auch mal verletzlich zu zeigen, kann auch schiefgehen. Und dann nutzt man heute Dating-Apps. Und so wie Lana hier eben über Social Media allgemein sprach, gibt es hier im Pivot Podcast, vorhin schon kurz angesprochen, von Cara Swisher und Scott Galloway. Die haben mit Nancy Jo Sales gesprochen über ihr Buch Nothing Personal My Secret Life in the Dating-App Inferno. Das Dating-App Inferno. Es ist ja ganz wichtig, dass Inferno mit im Titel steht, gleich hinter Dating-App. Und sie beschreibt hier auch mal so eine Sachlage, von der ich auch wieder sagen würde, ja. Und das trübt eben diesen ganz normalen Offline-Sozialverkehr dahin, dass Leute plötzlich sich selbst Gespräche aufnehmen, darüber, dass sie eigentlich keine Freunde haben.
So that's the lie of the advertising, but the business model is actually engagement and addiction and constant, you know, endless swiping, et cetera, which is exhausting. That's a word that comes up a lot when I interview people about apps, men, women, whatever. It's exhausting, it's exhausting, because I think it is labor. It's unpaid labor. In fact, in a lot of cases, you are paying to labor for them. You are swiping, swiping, swiping, giving data, answering questions, questionnaires, exchanging back and forth messages, where you might mention things that you buy or places you've been.
Ja, Dating Apps Inferno, das ist vielleicht nicht ganz falsch. Man kriegt das immer wieder, diese Zahlen. Sehr viele Leute lernen sich kennen, aber man lernt sich halt kennen. Man muss sich kennenlernen wollen. Und wenn man es auf einer Dating App macht, dann ist halt für alle gleich klar, ach, hier geht es ums Daten. Jeder Ansprache, der kommt, ist gleich offenbar und offensichtlich. Und da ist dann sozusagen kein Raum für das, um was es eigentlich geht. Und es prägt dann halt auch wieder, wie man grundsätzlich mit solchen Sachen umgeht. Und dass man dann relativ zügig dazu kommt und sagt, ich hab eigentlich keine Freunde und bin einsam, liegt irgendwie dann doch auf der Hand. Also hier baut sich doch so ein Bild zusammen, dass Leute so langsam die Maßstäbe verlieren. Und jetzt klären wir abschließend die Frage, wie kommt es, dass die Maßstäbe so verloren gehen? Und meine These ist, Google ist mittlerweile in einem ideologisch kranken Zustand, dass man sich wirklich fragen muss, können wir noch länger, sollten wir uns noch länger Google aussetzen? Oder sollten wir nicht so langsam mal die eine oder andere Schranke einziehen, um uns wieder zurückzukämpfen aus einer googlosen Welt? Und Google hat, so wie viele, diesen Mai seine Entwicklerkonferenz eröffnet. Die fand natürlich nur online statt und so weiter. Kennen wir ja. Hören wir erstmal was Google Chef Sundar Pichai, ich glaube, das ist der Investorscall, hier zu YouTube sagt. Wir haben jetzt eine Weile über YouTube gesprochen. Lassen wir doch nochmal YouTubes Chefe über YouTube sprechen.
In der Tat, nach einer letzten Studie, die Ipsos gemacht hat, haben 77% von den Nachbarn YouTube im Jahr 2020 benutzt, um eine neue Wende zu lernen.
Ja, 77% der YouTube Nutzer haben YouTube genutzt 2020 während der Pandemie, um was Neues zu lernen, was sie vorher noch nicht kannten.
Was ist denn damit jetzt tatsächlich gemeint? Also es kann ja jetzt nun nicht sein, dass 77% entweder eine neue Sprache gelernt haben oder jetzt in die höhere Mathematik eingestiegen sind. Bedeutet das auch gut, man hat jetzt mal ein Video angeklickt mit irgendeinem Vortrag oder hat sich ein Videoessay angesehen, ist das dann schon zu den 77%, wo man sich ja fast eher fragen muss, wie kann es sein, dass dann 23% das nicht gemacht haben? Was haben die denn dann eigentlich gemacht? Die haben dann nur Julien Bam und Rezo geguckt oder was?
Fragen über Fragen, die Maßstäbe für diese Aussagen sind mir völlig unklar, dir auch. Und in der Ansicht ist das Quatsch. Wird aber den Investoren so dargelegt. Auf der großen Bühne für alle, das ist jetzt, hat man auch an der Qualität gehört, das ist dieses typische Telefongespräch für die Investoren, wo die ganzen Banker da sitzen und fragen, was sie jetzt mit meinen Werbeumsetzen. Es gibt natürlich, das war jetzt Quartal 1, 2021, war ein mega-Quartal für alle, weil die ganze Welt im Lockdown war. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Google IO die Entwicklerkonferenz, wo er hier auch nochmal auf der Bühne steht und sagt, Bildung, Bildung, Bildung. Nichts ist uns bei Google so wichtig wie die Bildung.
Manchmal geht es darum, in den großen Momenten zu helfen. Chromebooks sind jetzt die Nummer 1-Device global in K-12-Education.
Ja, 150 Millionen neue Nutzer in Google Classroom, die kamen einfach dadurch, dass arme Länder wie Italien, und ich weiß, arme Länder ist ein bisschen übertrieben, aber wo einfach der Bildungsminister bei Google anruft und sagt, ich brauch für jeden meiner Schüler einen Google-Account.
Ganz richtig.
Wir müssen jetzt Classrooms in der Schule machen.
Und sonst hat man ja gerade das Jahr 2020 gesehen, wie wenig es bei YouTube um Bildung geht. Also wir haben ja gerade dort die große Desinformationswelle gehabt, die kam ja als erstes über Google, über YouTube. Das kam ja erst später mit Telegram, dass das so groß wurde und dass die alle dorthin dann ausgewichen sind. Aber wir haben YouTube als die Grundlagenplattform, wo auch diese ganzen Leute, wir wollen die Namen nicht nochmal alle nennen, ihre Reichweiten schon hatten und dann mitgenommen haben zu Telegram über. Und ich habe es ja bis heute, dass ich durch zwei Klicks schon bei der Desinformation bin. Also gerade jetzt, wenn man so zu wirtschaftlichen Dingen ein bisschen was nachsieht. Das ist ja immer noch Kraut und Rüben, was dort ist. Ich bin jetzt nicht dafür, dass man das löscht. Ich will nur sagen, das ist immer noch das, wie dieser Algorithmus programmiert ist. Es geht überhaupt nicht um Bildung oder um wirkliches Informieren.
Genau. Also hier bräuchten wir mal so einen großen Moment, wie vor 60 Jahren, dass der Präsident kommt und sagt, wir brauchen hier mal einen kleinen Impuls. Wir wollen hier nichts kaputt machen, aber wir bräuchten einen Impuls für besseren Zeitvertreib im Internet. Naja, die Maßstäbe Googles sind atemberaubend. Mittlerweile, jeder kennt es, der im Computer kauft, da ist eine CPU und eine GPU drin, also ein Computerprozessor und eine Grafikkarte, die nochmal die speziellen Visualisierungs-Sachen besonders gut rechnet. Und dann gibt es auch noch TPUs, also für Tensor. Das T steht für Tensor, TensorFlow, dieses Artificial-Intelligence-Zeug und so, was man da auch so machen kann. Google baut das mittlerweile alles selbst, also so wie Apple die Prozessoren für die Geräte, die man zu Hause hat, diese M-Chips selber baut, baut Google seine eigenen Rechenzentren, Dinge in einem Ausmaß, das wirklich schwindelerregend ist. Er beschreibt hier mal die Einheit eines Computers, die man dort mittlerweile hat, der man jetzt eine Aufgabe widmen kann. Also die Rechenzentren, klar, sind einfach viel Power, aber man könnte jetzt eine Aufgabe an einen Computer richten und dieser Computer ist wie folgt groß.
Denk an es so. Wenn 10 Millionen Menschen jetzt ihre Laptopstöne anbieten, dann werden alle Laptopstöne fast gleich wie ein Computer von einem Xaflop. Das ist das schnellste System, das wir in Google geplant haben. Und ein historisches Anlass für uns.
Ein Xaflop-Computer, der so mächtig ist, wie 10 Millionen Laptops, die Privatmenschen zu Hause haben. Und schon seit 10 Jahren ist es so, dass man sich vorstellen muss, für jeden Laptop, der über den Ladentheke geht, den man zu Hause stehen hat, hat Google einen gleichstarken Äquivalenten im Rechenzentrum stehen. Also alles, was man selber als User inputmäßig macht, können die da gegenspiegeln. Und das haben sie mittlerweile so aufgebohrt. Das ganze Internet kann von Google einmal gespiegelt werden. Und das machen sie mehrfach jetzt. Naja, so entsteht ja der Index. Und dann können sie ja an ihrem eigenen Index Manipulationen vornehmen und dann eine Indexversion gegen eine andere Indexversion ausspielen. Und das hat mir Schömerer damals schon vor 10 Jahren oder so erzählt, dass er gehört hat von diesen Experimenten, dass man halt sagt, ab 3 Uhr nachts keine blauen Webseiten mehr. Wir arbeiten nur noch mit dem Suchindex, der keine blauen Webseiten hat. Und dann gucken wir mal, ob dann die ersten Suchergebnisse erfolgreicher beim Nutzer ankommen oder nicht. Also das ganze Internet hat mehrere Kopien, die live eingespielt werden können von YouTube auf den Computern der Nutzer vor 10 Jahren. Und jetzt haben wir hier die Sachlage, dass sie einen einzelnen Computer quasi gebaut haben, der 10 Millionenfach die Rechenkraft eines Nutzers übersteigt. Also es sind einfach unendliche Dimensionen an Rechenkraft und Rechenpower und echter Schlüsseltechnologie, die wir hier haben.
Das heißt, Google kann also die virtuelle Realität, und anders kann man sie ja nicht nennen, also die virtuelle Realität immer wieder so modifizieren, wie das jetzt mal gerade ihnen in den Sinn kommt. Das heißt, die Realität erschaffen dadurch. Also es ist eine Kopie der Welt, die aber dann transformiert wird.
Wenn du eine Googlesuche machst, du gibst einen Suchbegriff oben ein, da kriegst du ja Suchergebnisse. Da steht dann unten, das sind jetzt eine Milliarde Seiten oder so, unendliche Nullen. Da wird dir ja nicht das Internet angezeigt, sondern die Ergebnisse des Googlesuchindex. Und davon gibt es mehrere Kopien. Und je nach Laune zeigt dir Google dann den, der gerade für dich adäquat ist. Und dann gibt es eben Experimente, um zu sagen, keine Ahnung, jetzt sparen wir mal die Farbe aus. Die Heuristik ist ja immer nur der AB-Vergleich. Dass man einfach sagt, das oder das. Und dann guckt man, welches von beiden erfolgreicher war. Und dann wählt man das aus. Und wenn dann irgendwie heißt, ne, wenn die Leute innerhalb der ersten drei Suchbegriffe auf Seiten klicken, wo die Überschrift 25 Pixel hoch ist, dann ist denen das zu komisch. Dann denken die, das ist von so einem Honk gemacht. Dem glauben wir nicht. Und dann schlägt das nieder auf die Reputation des Google-Suchergebnisses. Also sortieren wir diese Seiten aus. Durch solche Experimente kommen die halt darauf, dann irgendwelche Farben auszusparen. Bewegende GIFs wurden so aussortiert und so weiter, bis man dann die ersten drei Seiten nur noch seriös aussehende Sachen hat. Aber das sind halt eben A-B-Vergleiche, die so megamäßig viel abliefen, dass man heute so ein Bild davon hat, wie man so einen Algorithmus gestalten muss, was er aussortieren muss, was er überbewerten muss und so weiter und so fort.
Exakt so hat man ja auch den Obama-Wahlkampf damals gemacht, weil man wissen wollte, wie funktioniert das eigentlich online. Und dann hat man immer mit A und B-Vergleichen gearbeitet. Cooklick hat das ja auch in seinem Buch Granulare Gesellschaft nochmal so schön gezeigt, wie dann gesagt wurde, naja, was ruft denn wirklich zu Spenden auf? Spenden Sie jetzt, Sie können uns unterstützen. Blau hinterlegt, rot hinterlegt. Und das wurde immer dann mit so tausender Gruppen, wurde das schnell ausgetestet. Und dann hat man das dann für alle freigegeben, das, was dann erfolgreich war.
Und Trump hat das ja dann spezialisiert, in der einfach der Dingsterbums, wie heißt er, Brad Dingsterbums, sein digitaler Wahlkampfchef, einfach hunderte verschiedene Versionen der gleichen Werbebotschaft hatte, um dann zu gucken, welche schalten wir heute Abend, 20 Uhr, wenn die meisten dann online sind, wirklich scharf. Dann hat man ab 14 Uhr 6 Stunden lang aussatiert und dann abends der Primetime, wenn alle vorm Fernseher saßen und Second Screen und so weiter, hat man dann die erfolgreichsten Dinge scharf geschaltet und die wurden dann ausgeliefert. Also in der Hinsicht ist das alles ein großes Spiel. Und, und es in der Hinsicht eskaliert es hier so richtig, Realitätserzeugung. Und dann, unter dieser Maßgabe muss man sich dann immer so Kleinigkeiten angucken, wie hier, dass Google dann wirklich groß eingreift und die Städte so ein bisschen mitgestaltet. Denn bei Google Maps gibt es jetzt eine Ergänzung. Man kennt das schon so ein bisschen, aber jetzt wird es intensiviert.
Aufgrund des.
Ganz, ganz wichtig, hier haben wir mal einen Ausschnitt.
Eine Technologie, die wir hier im Pioniering haben, ist Differential Privacy, die uns ermöglicht, große, aggregierte Datasets zu verwenden, während wir garantieren, dass deine einzelnen Daten niemals identifiziert werden können. Niemand hat die Zufriedenheit von Differential Privacy mehr als wir.
Ja, und hier hört man so ein bisschen differenzielle Privacy. Das kannte ich bisher nur von Apple, aber es stimmt. Google hat das tatsächlich damals pioniermäßig entwickelt. Also die Idee, das Konzept vorgestellt, dass man einfach viele Datengrundlagen in einen Top wirft und daraus dann Durchschnittswerte, wo man auch wieder Einzelelemente reinbaut, diese eigentlich so gar nicht gab, also die sozusagen verwässern auf elementarer Ebene, aber im Allgemeinen trotzdem eine Aussagefähigkeit, wie zum Beispiel bei den Stadtteilen. Man kann da nicht mehr runterbrechen, welches Handy war tatsächlich da und hat signalisiert, hier sind aber ganz schön viele, aber die Summe stimmt dann trotzdem. Also man sieht einfach in dem Stadtteil ist viel los und so weiter. Und hier versuchen gerade, das von Apple wieder rüber zu holen, denn eigentlich hat Apple und Tim Cook macht das seit Jahren auf der Bühne von Differential Privacy in allen Belangen zu erzählen. Und jetzt kommen sie hier so um die Ecke mit. 2021. Wir betonen jetzt nochmal, dass wir eigentlich die Erfinder davon sind. Also da sieht man auch, sie haben gemerkt, dass der Zug so ein bisschen abfährt langsam.
Nur sind sie ja darauf angewiesen, dass sie personalisieren können, was die Werbung anbelangt, was jetzt bei Apple nicht notwendig ist, oder?
Ja, also sie haben ja dieses neue Vlog, Federate Learning, wo sie nicht mehr über Cookies speichern, sondern wo sie so ein Katalog an Eigenschaften... Das heißt, du kannst sie im Browser vorhalten und dann nur Häkchen setzen. Ist interessiert an Dings, Dings, Dings, Dings, Dings. Im Grunde, da es um mehrere hundert Kategorien geht, kann man dann wieder auf das Individuum zurückschließen. Aber man müsste es eben gezielt auslesen und genau das erlaubt man dann den Werbetreiber nicht mehr. Sie können dann nicht mehr die eindeutigen Cookie auslesen, sondern nur noch den Katalog an Vorlieben und so weiter. Und in deren Sicht unterbinden sie das schon, dass man immer noch als Werbe- also Google kann das, aber das Werbetreibende, die die Plattform nutzen, um Werbung zu adressieren, dem wird das so ein bisschen unterbunden.
Die Frage ist, wann wird dann Facebook darauf noch reagieren?
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht, weil sie sich eingerichtet haben. Sie sehen ja, dass der App-App-Plattform...
Aber sie haben ja jetzt ein Problem mit Apple. Also dadurch, dass jetzt Apple das ausschließen lässt, hat man ja schon gesehen, dass Apple diese Nachverfolgung, diese Kukisierung des Daseins, dass das nicht mehr so weitergeht. Also dass nur, glaube ich, 5% oder was auf Ja geklickt haben. Und 95% sagen, nö, ich will aber auch nicht getrackt werden.
Genau, wir hatten das ja hier besprochen. Und wir wissen heute, nachdem iOS 14.5 jetzt da ist, 95% der Leute sagen pauschal, ich will nicht mal die Frage gestellt bekommen, ob mich hier irgendwer ausspielen darf, ich sage einfach nein. Und alle Apps wissen jetzt, okay, das ist nein. Wie groß dieses Problem ist, wird sich jetzt zeigen. Da muss jetzt einfach praktische Intelligenz sozusagen reingeben. Facebook sieht jedenfalls nicht allzu betrübt aus gerade. Aber mal gucken, die Quartalszahlen kommen ja dann. Und iOS ist ja eine entsprechend große Plattform, wo auch die vermögenden Kunden sozusagen drauf sind. Dass man es dann doch sehen sollte, wenn da irgendwas ist. Aber das warten wir mal ab, das sehen wir dann wahrscheinlich so im Juli oder so. Naja, dieses Federal Learning wird hier auch noch mal kurz vorgestellt. Das ist ja das neue große Ding.
Another important technology is federated learning, invented here at Google in 2016. It enables machine learning models to be trained centrally without any raw data leaving your device.
Ja, also hat sie es so gesagt, wird da nicht tiefer vorgestellt. Aber das ist so dieser neue Ansatz, den sie da haben, dass sie es noch mal eine Aggregationsstufe einbauen, für die, die dann drauf zugreifen. So, Meetings, großes Thema. Wir haben es ja eben schon in Google Classroom und so weiter. Menschen müssen jetzt miteinander klarkommen, auskommen, sich was beibringen, wie auch immer Geschichten erzählen, ohne dass sie im selben Raum sind. Und das haben sie noch mal ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben mit einem Feature, das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
To help both office and remote teammates remain an equal part of the conversation, no matter where they are, we're launching companion mode in Google Meet. Companion mode gives each of Adu's teammates in the office their own video tile, so they can stay connected to their remote colleagues and everyone can participate in polls, chat and Q&A in real time. Companion mode is coming to Google Meet later this year. Team mates can also be heard wherever they work with noise cancellation powered by the best of Google's AI.
So, also man sitzt zu dritt in einem Konferenzraum und irgendwo auch anders auf der Welt sitzt noch mal einer, noch mal einer, noch mal einer. Sechs Leute schalten sich zusammen. Aber auch die drei in einem Raum nehmen einzeln an der Videokonferenz teil. So dass die Technik wirklich auf jeden einzelnen Zugriff hat, selbst dann, wenn es gar nicht nötig wäre, weil sie sind ja in einem Raum. Und da kann man sich natürlich überlegen, welche Idee steckt dahinter, welches Potential wollen sie hier ausbeuten. Dass dann auch wenn wirklich alle in einem Raum sind, sagen wir mal, sie wollen irgendwas dokumentieren, viel später oder so. Dass man dann sagt, ja, wir machen es, wir schauen trotzdem alle auf unsere Bildschirme in die Kameras. Wir gucken uns nicht gegenseitig an, sondern hier steht die Musik. Obwohl man offline zusammensitzt. Also nennen sie sich, das geht schon mal in die richtige Richtung für Google, so einen Vorschlag zu machen. Und dann Noisefeature. Man muss natürlich auch genau zuhören in so einem Meeting. Jetzt hat er eben schon gesagt, Noisecancelation ist natürlich dabei. Aber man will wirklich wortwörtlich verstehen, um was es geht. Könnte ja sein, dass ihr heute in einer anderen Sprache teilnimmt.
Und seine Kollegen weltweit können mit Live-Folgen, sogar Translations, in ihre native Sprachen folgen. Wenn ein Du sein Präsentation beendet, fühlt er sich nicht von Zeitzonen oder Sprachen oder den Geräten, die sein Team nutzt. Vielmehr fühlt er sich mit Google-Meet-emersivem Erfahrung verbunden und in dem Moment.
In dem Moment. Genau, dann fühlt man sich zusammen, egal in welcher Sprache, wo, auf der Welt, zu welcher Tageszeit man sprach. Alle haben sich gegenseitig verstanden. Dieses Live-Transkribieren und auch Übersetzen finde ich immer so ein bisschen klar. Das ist total nützlich. Nur das kennen, glaube ich, alle Podcaster. Man weiß nicht mehr, was man irgendwann mal irgendwie gesagt hat, weil es gibt ja bisher keine Transkripte. Jetzt gibt es Google Podcasts und die bieten einem natürlich an, dass sie für einen einen Podcast transkribieren. Und plötzlich weiß Google Zusammenhänge oder Entwicklungen in der eigenen Gesprächsgeschichte, die man selber nicht mehr auf dem Schirm hat, weil man hat nur die Autodateien und eben keine Transkripte und vor allem keine Analysemöglichkeit über jedes einzelne Wort hinweg und so. Also in der Ansicht, hier will Google einfach aus Meetings mehr rausholen als diejenigen, die diese Meetings veranstalten. Und es gelingt ihnen mit solchen Angeboten natürlich super, wenn dann alle, obwohl sie in einem Raum sind, immer noch diese Art der Technik nutzen. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Ja nur so können genügend Daten produziert werden.
Genau.
Wenn man das nur analog macht oder wie im Agentenfilm, da geht man unter die Dusche oder irgendwo in den Wald spazieren, um sich zu unterhalten, damit auch ja niemand was abhören kann. Und hier sagt man auch, auch beim analogen Gespräch können wir alles mit dabei haben. Also es gibt ja von Edward Snowden immer wieder solche Sachen, dass er dann Telefon ausstöpselt und so im Hotelzimmer, solche Sachen waren ja da zu sehen damals in der Doku. Alles muss irgendwie weggepackt werden. Jetzt erlebt man ja aber nicht mehr solche kleinen Spionagegeräte, dass man nicht weiß, hört das Smartphone jetzt noch gerade mit, sondern man macht es halt jetzt ganz transparent. Und es scheint offenbar auch nicht zu sein, was noch irgendwie auf Ablehnung stößt. Ganz im Gegenteil. Und ich glaube ja, weil wir uns auch hier schon mal darüber unterhielten, wie diese Audio-Welt eigentlich suchbar wird im Internet, ist das für eine Suchmaschine wie Google immens wichtig, zu wissen, über was wir hier eigentlich sprechen. Und nicht nur so ein kurzer Text. Heute haben wir über Twitch und Joe Biden gesprochen, sondern auch was fiel da, welche Schlagworte, welche Namen wurden genannt. Und wenn sie das auslesen können und dann vielleicht noch in mehreren Sprachen zur Verfügung stellen können, beziehungsweise das suchbar machen, ist das ein Riesenmarkt. Also das sind ja auch solche interessanten Informationen, die sich überhaupt aus dem Sprechen heraus ergeben. Also was offenbart eine Stimme? Wie redet jemand? Was ist so da noch rauszulesen? Also wir hören natürlich bei einem Warren Buffett, dass der nicht mehr 22 ist.
Und auch dringend neue Haftcreme braucht, hatte ich den Eindruck.
Das auch, behalte unbedingt das Thema Sprechen im Hinterkopf, denn das ist Googles neues Privacy-Megathema. Sprache, Synthetisierung, Lambda ist ja neues Konzept. Das haben wir aber am Ende, weil ich baue es ja hier nach Eskalationsstufen auf.
Gut.
Und jetzt sind wir an einem Punkt, der ist auch ein bisschen... Na ja, das, was wir eben gehört haben, wird jetzt in die produktiven Systeme eingebaut. Also wenn wir uns hier im Juni dann wahrscheinlich zum letzten Mal per Google Meet zum Podcast verabreden, dann gibt es diese Features alle schon, die hier angepriesen werden, weil wir nutzen ja auch Google Meet für diesen Podcast.
Weil wir hoffen, dass wir dann uns sehen können. Das ist der Grund. Also wir hören nicht mit dem Podcast ab, sondern wir wollen uns mal wieder begegnen und einen Schnitzel danach essen.
Schnitzel gibt es schon. Hab ich gestern schon gesehen. Da wurde auch schon ein Großhochzeit gefeiert. Jetzt Videokonferenzen. Sie haben hier einen Prototyp. Wir haben alle das Problem mit Videokonferenzen. Also ich kenn es ehrlich gesagt nicht so sehr, aber Menschen können sich nicht in die Augen schauen, weil die Kamera ist ja immer an der einen Stelle und der Bildschirm, man schaut jemand an, ist an der anderen Stelle. Und dann klappt das immer auseinander. Und man weiß deswegen nie, wenn man in so einer Schulklasse ist, wer guckt ja eigentlich wen gerade an oder so. Und das scheint Leute in so Zoom-Fatigue zu bringen. Mir ist das so ein bisschen fremd, aber ich mache auch nicht allzu viele Videokonferenzen. Also ich bin nicht mehrere Stunden am Tag oder so damit belästigt. Und hier wollen sie das Problem jetzt lösen. Näher stellen, indem sie es wieder ermöglichen, sich in die Augen zu schauen, obwohl man sich nicht gegenüber sitzt. Also wieder reale Gespräche. Dafür müssen sie aber komplett in Synthetisieren ausbrechen. Das ist wirklich crazy.
Was ist das?
Ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen, was da passieren würde, wenn die Schraube aufgerissen wäre.
Einige gewünschten Advancen haben diese Erfahrung möglich gemacht. Erst mit hochschulenden Kameras und custom-builden Depth-Sensoren fangen wir die Form und die Erkenntnis aus multiple Perspektiven an. Dann fügen wir sie zusammen, um eine extrem detaillierte, real-time 3D-Model zu kreieren. Und wir haben ein breakthrough-Light-Field-Display entwickelt, das euch die realistische Repräsentation von jemandem, der gerade vor dir sitzt, in drei Dimensionen.
Das ist so verrückt.
Unglaublich. Du musstest glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen erklären, wenn man das jetzt nur gehört hat. Aber wie kreieren einen nach digital?
Man wird synthetisiert, denn man kann nicht in die Kamera schauen, wo keine ist. Sondern wo die Augen abgebildet werden, wo ein Bildschirm ist. Jetzt könnte man natürlich irgendwie fasziniert von einem durchsichtigen Bildschirm, wo die Kamera dahinter ist.
An sowas hatte ich gedacht.
Teleprompter oder so ginge das ja. Aber sie lösen es anders. Sie holographieren dich. Sie haben ein Kamerasystem, das ein 3D-Modell von dir entwickelt. Und dann haben sie das optische Kamerasystem, das die Farben wieder drauf projiziert auf das 3D-Modell. Also man begegnet sich, aber man sieht auf einen zu 100% synthetisches Avatar, das so aussieht wie der andere, weil es eben mit sehr hochauflösenden Kameras gut abgenommen wurde.
Und dieser andere guckt einen auch richtig an, während der richtige andere nach wie vor mit seiner Webcam guckt und weiß nicht wo. Und dieser Avatar, aber der ist in der Lage, eine Kommunikation auf Augenhöhe herzustellen, als würden wir uns treffen.
Genau. Und es wirkt dann so, als säße man am Tisch gegenüber, weil der Bildschirm ist entsprechend groß. Aber auch wenn wir uns tricksen können, im Sinne von das sieht ja echt aus, und nach fünf Minuten haben es alle vergessen oder so, es bleibt trotzdem die totale Synthese, die absolute Artifizialität. Es ist im Grunde dieses Motion Catching aus Hollywood, wenn ein Schauspieler tatsächlich mal einen Affen oder einen Drachen oder einen Lego Figur spielen will oder so. Das ist die Technik dahinter. Und dass man sich dafür entscheidet, dass der andere so aussieht, wie er halt auch in echt aussieht, das ist halt eine Entscheidung, die man so technisch treffen kann. Aber man könnte gut alles abbilden in dem Moment. Also jedes 3D-Modell drauflegen. Und das finde ich schon so ein bisschen hier bei Vergecast. Im Vergecast wird das nochmal so ein bisschen hinterfragt. Und da wird auch mal dieses Augenkontaktding kurz beschrieben.
Du siehst also eine ganze Person in 3D, die mit Hologramm-Technologie vorgesehen ist.
Wenn man sich so überlegt, was in Deutschland für Diskussionen geführt werden, weil irgendwelche Radiosender sagen, diese Nachrichten werden live verlesen, obwohl sie mit 10 Sekunden Versatz gesendet werden. Was das für Skandale ausgelöst hat. Und dann hier sowas, das finde ich einfach, hier fehlt so eine Ethik-Schiene, die hier einfach mal mit kommuniziert.
Und doch muss ich an etwas denken, was ich gestern erlebt habe. Stichworte Artifizialität. Und zwar hat mich gestern ein guter Freund abgeholt in einem BMW Caprio. Und diesen Caprio hatte, weil er dort eine Werbesache für die macht und so. Naja, auf jeden Fall hatte er dieses Auto und wir hatten uns zum Spazierengehen verabredet. Und jetzt fuhren wir mit diesem Auto dann nach Kuplins an den Rhein. Und das war sehr interessant. Man sitzt also in diesem Auto drin, das 370 PS hat. Und man kann auf verschiedenen Fahrstufen fahren. Man hat so eine normale Stufe, dann hat man so eine, ich sag mal, ökologisch bessere Stufe, die gleitet und die verbraucht dann nicht so viel. Und dann gibt es die Funktion Sportfahrwerk. Dann heult der Motor lauter, dann knattert es und macht sonst was. Wir standen an der Ampel und dann kam uns dann auch so ein Auto entgegen, das so richtig knatterte. Und dann hab ich gesagt, so kann doch heute nie und immer mehr ein Motor klingen. Wir sind doch nicht in den 70ern. Das hätte man doch beheben können. Und dann sagte mein guter Freund, nee, das ist auch nicht irgendwie an dem Motor, beziehungsweise das muss man künstlich erstellen, dass der Motor noch so klingt und das Neueste sei eben oder wird seit einiger Zeit praktiziert, dass Leute sich ein solches Sportauto kaufen und es dann mit einer Soundanlage ausstatten lassen, die ein Motorengeräusch suggeriert, das aber eigentlich nicht da ist, weil die Motoren heute so modern sind, dass da nichts mehr rappelt und knattert. Das heißt, man macht das, was der Ulf Posch hat, immer dann als so Freiheit und sonst was bezeichnet, das macht man sich auf artificielle Weise ins Auto. Und er sagte dann auch, ja im Prinzip kann man dann auch ein BMW klingen lassen wie ein Ferrari. Man müsste dann nur fragen, können Sie mir das Soundsystem da rein machen? Und das ist so absurd, dass Leute sich damit, ich will nicht sagen zufrieden geben, dass sie so etwas wollen. Also dass sie verarscht werden wollen auf diese Weise und bereits so eine Summe dafür zu zahlen.
Ist nur so halb. In Deutschland gibt es eine gesetzliche Vorgabe, dein Auto muss Geräusche machen im Schritt Straßenverkehr.
Ja, ja klar, das schon, ja.
So und dann kannst du natürlich, wenn du dir so ein Elektroauto holst, einfach, da ist ja schon sozusagen ein Lautsprecher drin, der diese Geräusche macht. Die meisten surren ja so elektronisch, dass man auch gleich hört, das ist ein cooles Auto und so. Aber du kannst natürlich alles runterladen. Das ist wie mit Klingeltönen früher. Du kannst einfach alles besorgen. Also dann knatterst du halt so ein bisschen wie so ein Trabi.
Dann darf man sich jedenfalls über Hologramme nicht mehr allzu sehr wundern.
Ja, so was Google noch macht und jetzt wird es so langsam brenzlig. Wir kennen alle vielleicht, die die iPhones haben. Es gibt die Funktion des Live-Fotos. Du machst ein Foto, aber es wird noch zwei Sekunden drum herum dieser Moment mit eingefangen und als Video gespeichert. Dieses Video wurde tatsächlich so aufgenommen, aber nur beim Bild, also bei dem, wo du entschieden hast, das ist das Bild, wird sozusagen einmal der Image-Sensor so richtig in Beschlag genommen und dann das ganze Bild abgebildet. Also du hast ein hochqualitatives Bild und ein bisschen niederqualitatives Live-Video drum herum. Google versucht das jetzt nachzubauen und wie natürlich rein synthetisch.
Wir verabschieden die Fotos und füllen die Gäste, indem wir neue Frames kreieren. Ich finde, das geht nicht.
Es wird einfach ein Moment A, ein Moment B und dazwischen wird einfach die Computer, ja, üblicherweise sehen solche Bewegungen dann so und so aus, dann wird das synthetisiert. Und dann ist dein Handy voller solcher Momente. Das haben sie hier im Vergecast auch nochmal entsprechend eingeladen.
Sie haben einen Gäste genommen, der sich diese beiden Foto zwischen den Händen bewegt. Aber sie wissen es nicht, sie sind es einfach herauszufinden.
Das ist eine Stunde Verge, Angst. Statistisch könnte es eine aktuelle Repräsentation in diesem Moment sein. Vielleicht an einem hohen Niveau.
Es ist Statistik. Es ist eine Verteilungsschance, dass du existierst.
Also solche Gespräche driften dann schnell ab aus Gründen und klar, wenn man das mit 100 Jahre alten Weltkriegsfotografien irgendwie macht, so nachträglich, ja, aber wir können nicht jetzt Archive anlegen mit lauter Sachen, die nie passiert sind, nur weil Google meint, das sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus, wie wir das hier gerade kreiert haben. Jetzt hat er ja...
Das ist, wenn man die Welt nur nach Statistik noch formt.
Genau.
Also das ist nicht gleich Abbild, das vergessen ja manche Leute auch schon mal. Also das ist nicht das Abbild, sondern wir haben dann eine Statistik, das heißt eine Interpretation von gewissen Fakten, die vorliegen und der Rest wird weitergesponnen.
Ja, in deren Sicht nochmal der Hinweis auf Dirk Brockmann, der war bei Markus Lanz, der große Modellierer, der hier die Pandemie modelliert hat und ist nochmal wirklich zu Kreuze gekrochen. Also Matthias hat das nochmal so in zwei Minuten zusammengefasst. Wie er dann nochmal sagte, ja klar, wir hier die Pandemie modelliert, aber eigentlich kann ich Ihnen jetzt sagen, also länger als eine Woche kann man damit nicht vorausschauen, wenn überhaupt. Und die Variablen nicht unter Kontrolle. Und eigentlich ist Pandemie modellieren totaler Quatsch, sag ich mal so als Modellierer. Also so war dann so sein Lanz Ding jetzt. Das klang natürlich Januar, Februar, März ganz anders bei diesen Leuten. Naja, jetzt hat er, Nilay Pettel, gerade gesagt, Quantencomputer. Ja, Quantencomputer spielten hier auch eine Rolle. Und sie machen so ein kleines Werbefilmchen, sind in dem Raum, in dem Labor des Quantencomputers. Da sieht es natürlich total schnicker aus, wie sie in so einem Google-Fernsehstudio irgendwie. Und wie sie da über die Natur und die Annäherung an Realität und so weiter reden, da kommt einem wirklich so ein bisschen die Gänsehaut.
Is this a Bob Ross?
Tell me he's on the team.
He's not on the team.
See, quantum is the language of nature and we're learning to speak it here.
Ja, äh, quantum ist die Sprache der Mutter Natur und wir versuchen hier die Sprache der Natur zu sprechen und...
Deswegen hat man auch ein Naturgemälde da, dass ein bisschen wie Bob Ross aussieht.
Genau, und jetzt fragt er, ist Bob Ross on the team? Also soweit ich weiß, ist Bob Ross seit 20 Jahren tot? Und man macht hier so Scherze darüber. Irgendwie ist es ja völlig Banane, es drifft uns völlig ab, auf ganz vielen Ebenen, wie das hier vor sich geht. Naja, jetzt hatten wir zum einen die Cinematic Moments, also die nachträglich synthetisiert bewegten Bilder, die man dann in seiner eigenen Familiengeschichte so hat. Jetzt gehen sie mit dem eigenen Familienarchiv. Sie haben ja Google Photos noch anders um und das ist einfach crazy, wie sie hier ans persönliche Fotoarchiv eingreifen.
Für mich heisst meine Familie Hanukkah.
Ich kann also auf eine Kollektion von Hanukkah-Moments in meinem Fotogrid schauen.
In Bezug auf die Personalisierung des Content, wollen wir auch mehr Kontrolle geben.
Das ist ja vollkommen absurd. Was ist das jetzt für ein komisches Argument?
Sie blenden dir die unangenehmen Fotos aus deinem Archiv durch ihre eigene Arbeit, um dich nie wieder damit zu belästigen, aus, damit du nicht daran erinnert wirst, wenn du mal durch deine Fotoarchive gehst, sondern dann wird dein früherer Ehepartner oder dein vorheriges Geschlecht, oder was auch immer, dann einfach ausgeblendet, findet nicht mehr statt in deiner Erinnerungsgeschichte. Das ist der Ansatz bei denen.
Ja, und auch diese Bilder auslesen. Wir haben das jetzt hier gesehen. Es geht um Hanukkah und dann hat man jetzt eine App, die es schafft, diese Bilder zu erkennen und zuzuordnen. Hanukkah, das kann man dann auch sagen. Bilder, auf denen ein Tannenbaum zu sehen ist, das ist Weihnachten, Hasen, Ostern. Und dann kann man das so zuordnen. Und damit werden dann auch diese Fotoalben kuratiert. Aber dieses einfach rausnehmen aus der Erinnerung. Also das ist kein Aktive, dass es dann nicht mehr aktiv ist, sondern jetzt arbeiten sie da mit irgendwelchen Experten zusammen und so weiter. Das ist sehr, sehr kurselig.
Damit es mehr inclusive wird, weißt du?
Ja.
Damit sich alle aufgehoben fühlen. Sie fassen mal beides zusammen, die Cinematic Moments und diese Archiv-Entrümpelungen.
Das machen sie dann irgendwann noch bei Filmen. Warte mal ab.
Ja, kann durchaus sein.
Das wird dann kommen, ich möchte gerne Netflix gucken oder ich möchte gerne alle Disney-Filme sehen, aber bitte nichts, wo dies und das vorkommt. Und kreiert mir doch jetzt mal den Film so, wie ich den gerne hätte.
Ja, nichts, wo jemand stirbt, weil ich hab gerade mit Verlust zu kämpfen. Und Netflix sind nur noch... Also sie macht hier immer ihre Zusammenfassung. Ja, meaningful memories. Sie entscheiden für dich, welche meaningful sind. Sie entrümpeln also dein Archiv, sie blenden Sachen aus, die wirklich passiert sind. Gleichzeitig packen sie dir dein Archiv voll mit irgendwelchen kleinen cinematic Moments, die so nie passiert sind. Und das ist dann dein neues Ich, mit dem du dich rückversichert wärst. Bin ich eigentlich wirklich? Ich geh mal durch meine Bilder durch. Also diese Ansprüche, die hier drinstecken, sind wirklich atemberaubend.
Man kann sich dann gut vorstellen, wie dann, wenn so etwas sich wirklich etabliert und wenn es auch praktiziert wird, wie man dann erst reagieren wird, wenn man Fremdheitserfahrungen macht, Erfahrungen macht mit Dingen, die einem nicht so lieb sind, wie man darauf reagiert. Also man kann das ja jetzt schon bei Twitter beobachten, wie Leute in Rage geraten, wenn irgendwas nicht so ist, wie sie sich das vorstellen, oder ein Wort fällt, das ihnen nicht gefällt, oder sie hatten doch schon mal gesagt, dass das so und so ist. Oder auch in Bezug auf Filme und wer hat die Filme gedreht und was ist da mal in der Vergangenheit gewesen oder was wird in Zukunft sein. Da sehen wir schon, wie empfindlich diese Leute werden, die das die ganze Zeit nutzen. Und wenn dann die Umwelt, wenn die Gesellschaft nicht so funktioniert wie Google, sondern wenn sich da plötzlich jemand nicht einfach rauslöschen lässt oder jemand sich ins Bild drängt und wenn es nicht nach meinen Vorstellungen entspricht, wenn die Momente, die ich hier gerade erlebe, nicht so cinematik sind. Was dann los ist, kann man sich alles schon gut vorstellen.
Genau, dann hast du ein Jahr lang Einsamkeitsgefühle und machst dann Videos darüber, dass du gar keine Freunde hast, weil dir diese Art von, ach, da wird einem was zugemutet bei sozialen Erlebnissen. Das spielt keine Rolle mehr. Na ja, Leo Laporte macht hier mal einen ganz interessanten Hinweis. Twitt und so weiter. This Week in Tech. Google hat ja eigentlich ein Ethiksteam, das sich damals, nachdem sie auch diese englische Artificial Intelligence Bude da gekauft haben, mit denen sie dann auch den Go-Computer entwickelt haben und so weiter. Die haben eigentlich damals mit reingeschrieben, wenn ihr uns kauft, müsst ihr aber ein Ethik-Board einrichten, denn das hatten wir auch. Das ist hier nicht unbedeutend. Und jetzt hat Google ja Ethik-Mitarbeiter, also die sich hier oben ethische Fragen kümmern, hat die aber gefeuert. Diese Diskussion muss man hier gar nicht groß aufgreifen. Man weiß nicht genau, was da vor sich geht. Menschen schreiben halt auf Twitter, ich bin gefeuert. Und alles andere unterliegt irgendwelchen Verschwiegenheitserklärungen. Diejenigen, die da gefeuert wurden aus diesem Ethiksteam, haben allerdings einen Text geschrieben, bevor sie gefeuert wurden, aus dem liest Leola Port hier nochmal vor.
Sie haben nicht die Führung von zwei AI-Ethikereachern erwähnt.
Als wir das dieses Wochenende bei Google gemacht haben, war Kevin Marks dran und er hat dieses Papier aufgesucht. Ich sehe, ob ich die exaktige Sätze hier finden kann.
Der Risiko von wesentlichen Schaden, z.B. Stereotyping, Denegation, Erwachsenheit in extremistischer Ideologie, Unmöglichkeit, Erfüllung. Hier ist die letzte Sitzung.
Wir kallieren auf dem Feld, um zu erkennen, dass Anwendungen, die menschliche Anwendungen anstehen, die extrem Schaden bringen, die synthetische menschliche Behörde sind eine freundliche und ethische AI-Entwicklung, wo die downstream-Effekte in der Modellung verstanden werden müssen, um die Schaden an der Gesellschaft und den verschiedenen sozialen Gruppen zu schützen. Das ist genau das, was du gerade sprichst.
Da sitzen also zwei Ethik-Mitarbeiter und schreiben darüber im Fazit, also wenn ihr nachmacht Mimik, also nachmimt, was Menschen, aber das ist eigentlich nicht echt, sondern das ist euer Computer, dann muss man darüber mal diskutieren. Und alles, was wir bisher gesehen haben zum Thema Videokonferenzen mit 3D-Models und Avatar, Cinematic Moments, das sind alles dieses Nachmachen, dieses Mimik-Zeug. Und da hat sich Google gar nicht sensibel gezeigt, da seid ihr einfach rausgeschmissen. Und klar, es gibt nur noch externe Kritiker daran. Nur was will man jetzt Google kritisieren? Das ist ein 2-Billionen-Unternehmen und so. Und hat keine Handhabe und nichts. Und tja, jetzt stehen wir damit.
Und da kann man auch nicht einfach wie Charlie Munger sagen, it's good for our country.
Richtig, genau. Also das ist eine Diskussion. Wir kommen ja darauf zurück, Antitrust und so weiter. Das wird hier mal in Tiefe zu diskutieren sein. Bevor wir auf den absoluten Eskalationshöhepunkt zum Thema Sprache kommen, hier noch ein Punkt, der sehr viel jetzt mit Pandemie, Influencer, Konkurrenz der Amazon und so weiter zu tun hat. Shopping. Google möchte sich ganz neu platzieren. Der Shopping-Craft, wir kennen ja den Social-Craft und so weiter. Wurde alles mittlerweile schön kartografiert. Unsere sozialen und sachlichen Landschaften. Jetzt versucht man das auch mit dem Shopping zu machen.
Building on the knowledge graph.
So, also aus allen Richtungen, auch von den Herstellern, werden jetzt Daten zusammengetragen um, und das ist ja der große Vorteil von Amazon. Man weiß nicht nur, was es kostet, für was man sich interessiert, also was es wirklich ganz konkret kosten würde, wenn man es morgen zu Hause haben will, sondern auch, was ist es eigentlich? Was sagen die Leute dazu? Also diese ganzen Daten, die da so zusammenfließen. Und das möchten sie jetzt hier nachbilden mit, und sie sind ja schon krass auf die Nase gefallen mit ihrem Shopping. Da haben sie ja schon von der EU diese riesige Kartellstrafe gegen die sie da noch ankämpfen von 9 Milliarden oder so bekommen. Jetzt ist es ihr zweiter Versuch, den sie hier machen. Und jetzt hat er so einen Anwendungsfall. Man macht ein Foto von irgendeinem Basketballer, der hat tolle Schuhe an und fragt sich, was sind das eigentlich für Schuhe? Also ich mach nie Bildschirme, Fotos oder Fotos von irgendwas, was ich mag, wenn dann vielleicht einmal im halben Jahr, weil ich denke, das kann ich mir wirklich mal für, aber für ihn ist das so, ich mach jeden Tag fünfmal.
Ja, ja, das wundert mich auch.
Ich hab alles voll.
Ist mir aufgefallen, bei den Influencern hin und wieder machen ja Influencer einfach mal einen Post, der keine Werbung ist. Das passiert selten, aber es passiert. Und die haben aber dann trotzdem irgendwas hier an. Und du kannst davon ausgehen, spätestens der zweite Kommentar zu so einem Post ist, von welcher Marke ist denn die Hose? Das ist wirklich so virulent in dieser Gesellschaft, dass ich ihm das tatsächlich abkaufe, dass er so ist.
Das sind Leute, die verdienen hier mehrere Zehntausend Dollar im Monat, die funktionieren auch nicht wohin mit ihrem Geld. Also gucken sie die ganze Zeit, analysieren alles, was kann ich kaufen?
Hier ist eine, die ich für ein Paar Sneakers gesehen habe.
Ja, soweit so gut kennt man.
Könnte aber dann für die Influencer irgendwann problematisch werden. Wenn das zu gut ist, dann kann ich einfach so immer alles anklicken, dann brauche ich nicht mehr Leute, die mir Rabattcodes und so weiter präsentieren, sondern dann kann ich das wieder selbst in die Hand nehmen.
Ganz genau, Rabattcodes und so weiter. Google Chrome, also der Lieblingsbrowser aller Menschen auf der Welt, ich selber nutze ihn nicht als Hauptgerät, aber wir wissen, der ist jetzt bei 70-80% angekommen. Google Chrome soll der ultimative Einkaufswagen werden.
For example, I'm reminded that I've still got a shirt in my Tentree cart and a few things in my Lowe's cart. We'll also find you promotions and discounts for your open carts if you choose to opt in. Here I can see Electronic Express is offering 10% off.
Ja, also das ist so meta-megamäßig. Du legst irgendwas bei Amazon, bei Salando, bei Otto.de in deine Einkaufswagen. Google kriegt das mit, zeigt dir das dann, wenn du selber einen neuen Tab aufmachst, dass das da überall verteilt drinnen liegt und sagt dir dann, hier kannst du es billiger kaufen. Das ist natürlich auch eine richtige Kampfansage an alle diese Händler, dass sie das so automatisieren. Also das ist schon mal crazy. Und wenn man schon mal einen Einkaufswagen hat, wieso baut man nicht den ganzen Marketplace drum rum? Hat doch bei Amazon auch gut funktioniert.
We're making it easier than ever for merchants of all sizes to get on Google. Together with Shopify, we're excited to launch a seamless integration, so that the more than 1.7 million merchants on Shopify can reach more consumers in a matter of minutes.
So, also Shopify, das hast du uns ja schon vorgestellt, das kanadische Ding, wo einfach jeder so seinen kleinen Shop aufmachen kann. Die arbeiten dann so mit Google zusammen, dass du, wenn du bei dir irgendwo was in Einkaufswagen drin hast, dass dich Google darauf hinweist, dass es ja bei diesem und jedem Shopify-Store und so weiter gerade zu dem und dem Preis gibt. Sie bringen jetzt damit alle miteinander in Konkurrenz und schaffen sich selber diese Meta-Aufmerksamkeit, wie diese ganzen Versicherungsvergleichsportale und der ganze Flug, der billigste Flug und so weiter. Und sie wollen das jetzt auf den ganzen online Einzelhandel ausweiten und sich da so als Spinne ins Netz setzen.
Das heißt, wir werden hier noch eine enorme Monopol-Entwicklung haben, also die ja ohnehin sehr groß ist. Aber wenn diese Wette aufgeht, dann bedeutet das auch für die anderen Vergleichsportale wirklich das Ende. Also wenn das jetzt alles darüber zu strukturieren ist.
Für die Händler, für die Vergleichsportale, für alles. Sie sind dann der neue Marketplace, weil jeder kann einen eigenen Shop aufmachen, nur geht man damit dann nicht mehr zu Amazon und lässt es darüber vertreiben, sondern man macht es direkt einfach über Google und Shopify. Weil Shopify erklärt dir alle Logistik-Fragen für dich und Google macht die ganzen, werde ich auch gefunden und Marketing-Sachen für dich. Und in der Hinsicht, ich vermute, es wird nicht aufgehen. Das ist hier nur eine Kampfansage und so weiter. Wir werden es glaube ich nicht in einem Jahr so erleben, aber dass sie es überhaupt so versuchen und die hören ja auch die ganzen Amazon-Leute zu und so, finde ich schon, hm, also das ist echt der Krieg.
Und es wird zu spät sein, Shopify zu kaufen. Das kann dann selbst Google nicht, das ist nicht unmöglich, oder?
Das kann sein, oder dass sie es nicht wollen. Aber schon allein um kartellrechtlichen Fragen dazu zu ergehen. Ja, da sieht er einfach so, als ist, aber ich meine, am Ende sitzen sie dann da drin und reden alles darüber. Im Investorscall haben sie es hier noch mal. Das Kalkül kann man hier, glaube ich, raushören. Also er sagt hier, it's been a year. Und wir wissen, a year, wenn er das im Mai 2021 sagt, dann war das gerade zwei Monate in die Pandemie, wo Amazon schon gezeigt hat, wir versorgen die Welt und so weiter. Da kam sie auf die Idee.
Und da gab es den Shopify-Boom. Der war schon so deutlich wie noch nie zuvor.
Ja, also das ist hier so eine Pandemiesache, die Google da gerade versucht auszubrüten.
Und die Kombination von freier und bezahlter ist eine sinnvolle. Wir hatten ein Set von neuen Partnerschaften mit Shopify und PayPal, die Retailer viel mehr Wahl geben. Und wir werden weiterhin die, wir nennen sie End-to-end-User- und Merchandisexperienz simplifieren, natürlich. In der Partikulation versuchen wir, die Backend-Experienz der Merchandise zu steigern und hart zu arbeiten, besonders für hybridische Retailer. Retailer, die in Bezug auf Brick, Motor und Digital spielen. Und insgesamt wollen wir es viel, viel einfacher machen, für Retailer, die auf Google starten und ihre Information über die Flächen zeigen.
Ja, also mal gucken, ob sie es schaffen oder nicht, wäre natürlich eine Katastrophe für alle. Weil was soll das ja? Also wenn die Welt da nichts dagegen stellen kann, dann würde ich sagen, dann sollten wir uns alle geschlagen geben und sagen, dann danke übernehmt. Macht uns, unsere Geschäfte und unser Leben organisiert uns. So, letztes Thema Sprache. Google und Sprache. Wir wissen alle, da hat auch Amazon wieder vorgelegt mit Echo und so. Sprache ist das neue Ding. Google überlegt seit ewig, wie kriegen wir aus Sprache Geld? Weil damit fällt der Bildschirm weg zum Beispiel. Bildschirm, Bild, also Anzeigen und so weiter. Und jetzt haben sie eine neue Sprachsynthese Lambda. Nennen sie die L-A-M-D-A. Sunder Pichai ist ganz außer sich. War auch das zweitgrößte Thema nach Privacy, das er hier vorstellt. Und er ordnet hier gleich mal zu Beginn ein. Ein großes Tool, unsere Sprache und so weiter. Das finden wir jetzt nicht noch näher zum Menschen.
Die Wünsche und die Flexibilität der Sprache machen sie eines der größten Tools der Menschheit und eines der größten Herausforderungen der Computer-Scienzen.
So, das größte Werkzeug des Menschen, die Sprache, das unterscheidet uns vom Tier, ist die größte Herausforderung für die Computer. Und wir haben es jetzt gelöst. Und jetzt müssen wir mal alles zusammenbinden. Wir haben viel über Influencer gesprochen, Personalisierung und so weiter. Es geht nur noch um Menschen, selbst in der Politik, dass die CDU kein Programm hat, ist egal. Die Hauptsache, wir wissen, welcher der beiden Kontrahenten setzt sich denn hier durch und wie sieht der Konflikt aus? Und jetzt hab ich in den Redaktionsschluss damals geschrieben, es gibt ja diese norwegischen Literaturwissenschaftler, die sagen, wenn alles jetzt auf Sprache und Personalisierung geht und so weiter, dann stürzen wir zurück ins Mittelalter. Dann begegnen wir uns wieder spontan auf dem Feld und dass man auch was festhalten kann, sei es in einem Terminkalender oder einem Vertrag oder so. Es zählt alles nicht. Es zählt nur noch Aufmerksamkeit, Momente, Spontanität, Spiel, Gelegenheiten nutzen, als Gewinner vom Feld gehen und so weiter und so fort. Also nur noch Spontanität, Simulation, Spiel. Und was sie jetzt hier an Demo vorstellen, ist wirklich haarsträubend. Denn angenommen, du bist ein junger Schüler und kriegst den Vortragsauftrag. Morgen hältst du einen Vortrag über den Planet Pluto. Was machst du? Du gehst in deine Enzyklopädie und plattest nach Pluto und schreibst raus, was da drin steht, gehst zur Wikipedia oder führst ein Gespräch mit Pluto.
Lambda versteht schon viel über Pluto und Millionen anderer Themen.
Ich bin froh, dass du siehst. Ich bin froh, dass du siehst.
Ich wünsche, dass Leute wissen, dass ich nicht nur ein random Eisball bin.
Ich bekomme nicht die Erkennung, die ich nenne.
Oh Gott, Stefan, ich sehe jetzt unsere Bildungspolitiker. Ich erinnere mich an unserer an unsere Folge über die Gamescom. Und da hatten wir schon Doro Beer und Andy Scheuer, die dann sagten, ja, wie toll wir können jetzt alle mal spielerisch lernen. Und ich will nicht mehr so von oben herab, sondern jetzt mit Leuten in den Dialog treten. Und das ist ja genau das hier. Also Google, glaube ich, bräuchte das jetzt nur in allen Bundesländern hier vorstellen. Und sofort würden die Staatskassen geöffnet werden dafür. Denn wir haben ja sehr bildungsferne Politiker. Und ich glaube, das ist so dieses niederschwellige, was man ganz, ganz großartig findet und was natürlich das Ende bedeutet für uns.
Also mal gucken, die Schulen haben ja den Angeboten Googles und so weiter gut widerstanden. Die nutzen alle so ihre eigenen Sachen und haben sich da irgendwie arrangiert. Und es geht ja die Pandemie so ein bisschen vorbei. Aber auch im Vergleich zu dem, was wir vorhin, wir haben von Videos geguckt, von Leuten, die sagen, ich habe irgendwie keine Freunde. Wir wissen, wie roland ist, Hass Speech, Hate Speech und so weiter. Das nervt die Leute und so. Und dann haben wir hier eine Entfaltung eines Gesprächs, wo plötzlich Pluto einem Planeten Gefühle unterstellt werden und man als Gesprächspartner sich darum kümmert, dass es ihm auch gut geht, dass er anerkannt wird. Obwohl manche Menschen sagen, es ist ja nur ein Zwergplanet und gar kein richtiger Planet und so. Und dann wird plötzlich diese Art der Emotionalisierung, also nicht nur Personalisierung, sondern auch Emotionalisierung, Werturteile in dieses Gespräch rein bis zur Verabschiedungsformel, die dann möglichst höflich ist und so, um Pluto nicht zu verletzen. Das ist doch absolut Banane, dass wir so was 2021 als Fortschritt darstellen.
Genau, aber ich würde schon sagen, dass das ein ganz, ganz dominanter Diskurs ist. Wir haben ja jetzt auch wieder irgendwie so ein neues Buch draußen, das heißt die Shitstorm Republik oder was. Wir haben so, also viele wünschen sich eigentlich, dass wir so miteinander reden. Und ja, es gibt ja Hass im Netz, aber ich wäre da auch mal sehr vorsichtig bei diesem Begriff Shitstorm. Man kann das ja bei den Twitter Trends immerhin transparent sehen, auch wenn das die Leute nicht kapieren. Wenn es so ganz schlimme Hashtags gibt zu irgendetwas so Aufregerthemen, momentan war ja dann Baerbock oder was da irgendwie bei Twitter in der Mangel, da muss man mal schauen, wie viele Tweets werden dazu abgesendet. Und da sprechen wir dann von 1000 bis 4000 Tweets. Das wird da angezeigt. Das heißt, das ist gar nichts. Da kann man eigentlich sagen, es findet nicht statt. Es ist nur in den Trends, weil man ganz leicht in die Trends kommt. Wir könnten jetzt, ich glaube, 30.000 Leute oder was hören uns zu auch sagen, passt auf, am Samstag um 12 Uhr verabreden wir uns alle bei Twitter. Da machen wir unter Hashtag so und so machen wir jetzt eine kleine Aktion und werden in den Trends. Und es wird aber darauf geschlossen, dass alles so voll Hass zu ist und so weiter. Wir haben ja auch schon mal darüber diskutiert, ob man nicht zum Teil ein bisschen mehr hassen in der Politik brauchte und deswegen glaube ich aber dieses Sprechen, mit dem ist ja alles möglich. Also das ist wirklich ein neues, herrschaftliches Sprechen, eine neue Sprachregumonie, die hier auftaut. Denn dieser alte Befehlston, der funktioniert nicht mehr. Da sind alle gleich, nee, das so lass ich nicht mit mir reden und das wollen wir nicht und das ist autoritär. Aber auf diese Weise kann man, wenn man so mit Leuten spricht, alles durchdrücken. Dann kann man die neue Shopify-Kooperation machen. Damit kann man dann sagen, ja, guck mal und ist doch schön, wenn wir dein Fotoalbum und deine Erinnerungen kuratieren. Und es ist doch toll, wenn wir statistisch auswerten, was die eigentliche Momente im Gesicht deines Kindes sind, die wir fotografieren. Damit kann man das alles wunderbar hinlegen. Also da, da glaube ich, kann man wirklich mal von Neusprech reden. Aber soweit ist dann selbst Orwell nicht gegangen in seiner Fantasie.
Genau, bei Google ist das allerdings alles gut. Wetter, Pluto ist natürlich weit weg. Was liegt uns näher? Ein Papierflieger. Das zweite Beispiel, wie man Sprachsynthese machen kann, ist, man führt ein Gespräch mit einem Papierflieger.
Lambda hat sensibelere Antworten, behält den Dialog offenend. Naturale Gespräche sind generativ und sie nehmen niemals den gleichen Weg. Und Lambda kann eine Gespräche tragen, egal, was wir darüber reden. Mal sehen, was passiert, wenn wir mit einem Papierflieger reden.
Vor 500 Jahren war es völlig normal, dass Menschen in den Wald gehen, weil sie wussten, da treffe ich magische Wesen. Und alle sprechen, die Bäume, die Tiere, die Pflanzen. Heute wissen wir, dass es eigentlich krankhaft ist.
Das ist so neuer Animismus. Aber auch hier müssen wir mal ein bisschen die Postmoderne mit zur Verantwortung ziehen. Bruno Latour, der sehr geschätzt wird, den ich wirklich hasse. Bruno Latour hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Das Parlament der Dinge. Und Bruno Latour ist jemand, der sagt, wir müssen auch mit in den parlamentarischen Dialog die Dinge einbeziehen. Wir müssen auch hören, was der Tisch mir zu sagen hat. Das ist genau diese Denkweise, die ich in ihrem Relativismus schon immer sehr verachtet habe, die hier jetzt wieder kommt. Für mich war Bruno Latour, der ohnehin großer Wendehals und Karrierist ist, für mich war diese Art zu denken schon immer der Weg genau in so eine Silicon Valley Ideologie.
Bei Bruno Latour kann man sagen, das ist französischer Scheiß, das liest eh niemand. Aber hier haben wir es leider mit Google zu tun. Und naja, das ist jedenfalls die neue Google-Realität, die uns hier verkauft wird. Aber Leute, bedenkt, zu einer Pichalle weist du uns noch mal drauf hin.
Wir haben uns auf die Sicherheit konzentriert, dass Lambda unsere sehr hohen Standards treffen, auf Fairheit, Akku, Sicherheit und Privilegität.
Bla, bla, bla, naja. Gut, wir sind hier am Ende. Wir schaffen es jetzt leider nicht mehr über die Impfpatente zu sprechen. Mein Fazit wäre allerdings gewesen, lieber Joe Biden, finanziere bitte die Impfungen anstatt den Impf-Kreationsplan irgendwohin zu setzen. Damit kann niemand was anfangen. Wir haben in den New York Times gelesen, wie kompliziert dieses RNA-Zeug ist. Das schafft niemand. Man muss jetzt ein Produkt verkaufen und bitte stell es her.
Ja, also man kann natürlich diese Patentfreigabe fordern, aber nur die zu fordern und die auch umzusetzen würde nichts bringen, dann müsste man sie schon an Knüpfeln an Produktionsstädte. Und die Frage ist, ob das wirklich dann von denen gewollt ist. Denn tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass in den Entwicklungsländern, überhaupt in fast allen Ländern, die nicht westlich sind, extrem wenig geimpft wurde bislang. Und das ist sehr dramatisch und da macht sich der Westen auch schuldig. Und da muss halt was getan werden. Aber ich warne auch davor, zu sagen, jetzt sind wir im Westen immer schuld daran. Also wir lieben das auch sehr, für alles verantwortlich zu sein. Das ist auch eine Form von Konjunkturismus. Deswegen möchte ich noch zum Schluss, weil wir jetzt auf das Impfen nicht nochmal genau eingehen, aber ich möchte zum Schluss auf einen Artikel hinweisen. Und zwar heißt der Indian Apokalypse mit Ansage von Vidya Krishnan. Dieser Artikel ist jetzt in der Juni-Ausgabe der Blätter erschienen. Und da sagt die Autorin ganz deutlich Folgendes zu dem Impfdesaster in Indien, weil da auch schon wieder zu lesen war, ja seht ihr, das ist der Westen, der ist schuld daran. Wir haben da nicht die Impfstoffe hingeliefert, wo ja Indian selbst versprach, wir sind die Produktionsstätte der Welt für den Impfstoff. Und sie schreibt hier wirklich in aller Klarheit Folgendes. Indiens Scheitern in der Pandemie ist die unvermeidliche Konsequenz der blinden Unterstützung für die anti-intellektuelle Regierung von Modi und der BJP bei zwei aufeinanderfolgenden Wahlen. Dies ist das größte moralische Versagen unserer Generation, also der Inder. Es ist zuerst das kollektive moralische Versagen Indiens und erst dann das politische Versagen der BJP. Die Schuld dafür trägt nicht nur ein Mann, wie ungeeignet Modi für sein Amt auch sein mag, sondern sie liegt ebenso sehr bei jenen Leuten, die zweimal für diese Inkompetenz stimmten in der Annahme, dies werde sie nicht betreffen und ihre Betonblasen würden sie vor dem Chaos schützen, das anderen zugefügt wird. Die Struktur und das Handeln der Modi-Regierung verhöhnen alle Bürger, die damals ihr Vertrauen in sie gesetzt haben. Und dennoch wurden die Anführer dieser Regierung mit Blinderheldenverehrung belohnt. Und das war der Todesstoß für die indische Demokratie. Die zynischen politischen Entscheidungen der vergangenen sieben Jahre suchen uns nun heim. Wir waren uns als Volk deswegen so lange mutwillig nicht bewusst, in welchem Zustand sich unser Gesundheitssystem befindet, weil es Leben forderte, die für uns nicht zählten. Diese Blase ist nun geplatzt. Unser kleines und großes moralisches Scheitern hat sich zu Indiens fatale Antwort auf die Pandemie summiert. Wir selbst haben dieses veritable Horror-Kabinett geschaffen. Hier auch nochmal ganz deutlich, wir können jetzt nicht nur nach Indien blicken und sagen, ja, da hätte der der besten Impfstoff und alles. Das ist auch ein Versagen von Indiens Gesellschaft selbst, dass sie Modi gewährt haben. Und auch das muss man in postkolonialen Zeiten jemand zugestehen, dass die sich auch selbst verwellt haben. Und zwar zweimal. Und jetzt ganz, ganz schlimme Konsequenzen davon tragen. Und das können wir nicht immer nur auf uns schieben und so tun, als wären wir immer noch in irgendwelchen kolonialen Zeiten. Das ist erst einmal nicht der Fall, sondern auch in Brasilien. Liegt das daran, dass es da so katastrophal ist, weil da Bolsonaro an der Macht ist? Das liegt nicht nur daran, dass Biontech seine Patente behalten will.
Bolsonaro, das ist wirklich erschreckend. Den kleinen Clip 30 Sekunden, wie Bolsonaro über die Impfung spricht.
Brasilien ist hinter dem Rest der Welt laggen. Eine der Reasons ist das Präsidenten von Brasilien, der letzte Sommer 70 Millionen Pfizer-Dosen bestanden hat und sich um einen Kontakt erzielt hat, der allgemein den amerikanischen Pharmaceutical-Geräten nicht für mögliche Nebenwirkungen zur Verantwortung nimmt. Wenn du ein Krokodil wirst, ist das dein Problem. Wenn du Superman wirst, wenn eine Frau ein Haar wächst oder ein Mann in einer hohen Stimme beginnt, ist das dein Problem.
Ja, so kann man natürlich drüber reden und dass die Bevölkerung einfach vor die Hunde gehen lassen. Das ist brasilianische Verantwortung und ja, dafür hat man sich entschieden so zu wählen. Alle wussten vorher, was das für ein Typ ist.
Und da hilft auch jetzt keine Patentfreigabe, wenn er da so einen Unfug erzählt.
Ja genau, nützt da gar nichts, sondern jetzt muss das einfach gekauft werden da. Und wir haben alle noch Lauterbach im Ohr, der die Amerikaner dafür lobte, eben nicht nur Produkte zu kaufen, sondern richtig reinzugehen in dieses Investment, Impfstoffversorgung und dadurch hat es geklappt. Und einfach nur jetzt einen Brief zu verschicken, wo drin steht, wie man es macht. Also die Anleitung nützt dir wirklich niemand. Das ist zu komplizierte Technologie. Und ein Prototyp reicht eben nicht. Hier geht es wirklich darum, Milliarden Dinger herzustellen. Das ist wie, wenn Erdogan ein Elektroauto vorstellten, alle so, ist das jetzt der Angriff auf VW? Nee, das ist nur ein Auto. Das sind nicht 10 Millionen im Jahr.
Und das ist ein Versagen des Westens, was wir ja hier vor Ort erleben konnten, dass man die Produktionskapazitäten nicht rechtzeitig ausgebaut hat. Aber was auch man auf internationaler Bühne dann betrachten kann, denn natürlich hätten die EU und hätten die USA dafür sorgen können, dass in Afrika große Produktionsstrecken gebaut werden, damit jetzt dieser Impfstoff da produziert werden kann. Insofern ist es natürlich auch scheinheilig, wenn jetzt der Heiko Maas sagt, nee, nee, mit der Patentfreigabe, das hilft uns nicht. Wir müssten jetzt ja den Impfstoff überhaupt da mal produzieren können. Und das dauert, bis man solche Produktionsorte ausgebaut hat. Na ja, das hätte man ja angehen können. Aber daran hat man sich ja hier schon nicht orientieren wollen, sondern hat einfach mal geguckt, was passiert. Und natürlich in den anderen Ländern dann noch viel mehr. Es ist schon sehr traurig, das zu sehen. Und man kann nur hoffen, dass das nicht nochmal in anderer Weise zu uns zurück schlägt, wenn sich dann doch noch das eine oder andere dort bilden kann durch Mutanten, weil da eben so wenige Menschen geimpft sind.
Na mal gucken. So, wir haben eine Punktlandung gemacht. In sechs Minuten macht der Kindergarten zu. Wir haben jetzt also noch drei Minuten, um darüber zu reden, was im Salon passiert. Wir lesen Amy Klobuchar Anti-Trust. Das sind 600 Seiten oder so. Keine Ahnung, es ist mega.
Aber 300 Seiten Anhang. Und das ist beeindruckend bei einem Politiker, das hier richtig wissenschaftlich gearbeitet wurde. Ich glaube, bei Sarah Wagenknecht ist das ein bisschen anders. Da bin ich gespannt, was du da erzählen kannst.
Was für ein schlechtes Buch. Ich will es nur kurz teasern. Viele haben gefragt, könnt ihr mal Wagenknecht lesen? Üblicherweise ist es so, dass Menschen irgendwelche komischen Reden halten, im Interview so ein bisschen Hype-Gar, und dann im Buch aber mal so richtig darlegen, um was es eigentlich geht. Und ich wünschte, ich hätte es nicht gelesen. Mein Sarah Wagenknecht-Bild ist jetzt zerstört, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn ihr eine ordentliche Kritik von Sarah Wagenknecht zu buchen wollt, schaltet ein nächste Woche.
Ich bin auch sehr skeptisch. Ich hatte mal kurz reingelesen und habe da wirtschaftlich ein paar Anmerkungen zu machen. Ich habe mich aber mit Literatur beschäftigt. Ich habe gedacht, wir müssen, um die Neuen Zwanziger zu verstehen, mehr Literatur lesen, und zwar Altes wie Neues. Ich stelle etwas vor aus dem 19. Jahrhundert, das neu rausgegeben wurde, etwas aus dem 20. Jahrhundert, was neu rausgegeben wurde, aus Japan, Mishima, aus dem 19. Jahrhundert Russland, Togynia und dann 21. Jahrhundert, da gehen wir hoch in den Norden, da gehen wir zu Jonas Eicher, jemand, der Science-Fiction auf eine unglaubliche Art betreibt, die Literatur da zu einem neuen Weg, glaube ich, führt. Sehr, sehr interessant. Also von mir gibt es dreimal Schöngeistiges und dann noch zwei journalistische Texte. Aber gerade das Literarische ist jetzt wichtig.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Ich bin gespannt. Ihr seid auch gespannt. Wir haben dieses 2222-Ziel ein bisschen verpasst. Ich glaube, es fehlen so 13 Leute, um 2222 Salonmitglieder zu sein. Aber das kann man ja jetzt im Juni dann lösen. Sehr gut. Haut rein, Leute.